[Music]
thank you
already on day three of the 2023
Champions Chester we will get the match
that we're all dreaming of the two
biggest Rivals and online
Carlson versus Hikaru Nakamura in the
winners final of the air things Masters
but first two more players will be
knocked out of the tournament and Wesley
so is one of the players fighting to
stay in the game
I'm really looking happy with himself
the king can't move wait wait wait wait
wait wait this move is breaking the
rules whoa everything under control but
suddenly the position has changed this
just looks glorious Hawaii Big Choice
from origin irrigation there we go the
Avalanche continues
[Music]
his genius
and Magnus Carlsen will have to bring
his very best today because in the
winners final later today he's gonna
face Hikaru Nakamura in an incredible
match we're looking forward to that and
to safely guide us through this day
three in the air things Masters
Grandmaster David owl International
Master Tanya and Grandmaster robber test
and uh David what a day it was yesterday
but I'm gonna tell you the Highlight for
me even with two armageddons
what's this
I need to hit the gym a bit more clearly
we got a little bit of a MTV Cribs tour
of your apartment seeing that nice gold
medal but the Armageddon David we had
three matches decided that Norma get on
yesterday what do you think we did and
it was the first sight uh the first
Glimpse we've been given of this bidding
process I really liked it it added an
extra layer the Mind Games there that we
saw it added the strategy and uh it did
end up favoring the stronger players in
most of those or at least the higher
receipts on paper and I expect to see
more as we go through the tournaments it
was really dramatic yeah and Robin
you're a big sports fan so as a
sportsman do you like the direction
chess is taking now also with his
Armageddon bidding I love it you have to
break a tie somehow and you put it all
in the player's hands they chose the
amount of time they're willing to bid
they chose the color that they wanted to
play with so I think they were very
exciting games and we had three
Armageddon matchups yesterday it was
awesome yeah and today is going to be
another awesome day we're going to to
start out with a match between two
Indian teenagers Tanya ergassi and you
cash what you expect from that one I
can't wait for that one this is going to
be an epic fight it's going to be so
much fun because these two players are
absolute beasts and they play
uncompromising chess it's going to go
down to the wire no quick draws I am
expecting a tremendous effort from these
two who are good friends but on the
board they don't care about the
Friendship also looking forward to see
Kaya who India's rooting Focus they've
got such a massive fan base so I'd love
to hear from all the Indians who are
joining us for this one definitely
were you rooting for two players sitting
in India we have six players left in the
air things monsters spread out across
the world those two young Indians and
Magnus Carlsen one of three players
sitting in the US Wesley Seoul playing
from his home in Minnesota today he's
gonna face Alexei serrana who yesterday
knocked out one of the biggest names in
online chess
a Furniture doesn't move quickly
immediately Serrano replies again he's
hammering home the point wow
what just happened ignore the attack on
his Queen and he counter attacks against
the black queen now all of the queen
side pawns have disappeared but the
Knight is trapped that is what Alexis
surround has been and he brings his
Bishop back the Knight is stuck
everything just happened there in the
blink of an eye and uh there we go
spurge is about to resign White's Pawn
Central Pawn did run through promote and
uh just in time to stop black spot
foreign
I think shocked by this last decision by
Eric icy it did feel to me like Magnus
was trying to provoke this move I think
Magnus would have happily invested two
or three moves to provoke black to push
his Pawn to G6 oh discover checks all
over the shop here if Magnus once it's
just a nightmare everything is a
weakness in Black's Camp right now a
rook trade and white will make a new
Queen Arjun is about to resign losing on
time as well and he looks off
immediately now feels like momentum is
on magnus's side five minutes though
against nine and a half he's got to
speed up
uh everybody at least doing the right
things breaking out asking questions
there's going to be blunders there's
going to be mistakes they're only human
but the Queens are off the board this is
great news for our generic I see look at
that black Horton in the center it's
tying down the white rook and the white
Bishop he's essentially playing up a
piece and Magnus gesturing wow he's gave
away the pond and he's lost he's giving
away the game
it is looking dangerous for both sides
but this is Armageddon and that's
exactly what happens look at what hikara
has done he's throwing a thorn into the
white side this black H1 if you capture
it your structure is ruined the white
king is going to be weak forever Hikaru
so focused up on the clock up on the
position yeah just a master class Wesley
so with a draw in this game Wesley is
knocked down to the losers bracket
Hikaru Nakamura makes it through
and also in the studio we have
international Master Ivanka houska and
Ivanka you play chess almost your whole
life what do you think about what's
happening in chess with online chess
with rapid and Blitz chess and
Armageddon and bidding and everything
going on yeah I think it's actually
quite brilliant because you get maximum
drama maximum tension and everyone out
there quite frankly loves it because
this is what sport needs totally agree
let's take a look at the results from
the winners semi-finals yesterday
Hikaru Nakamura it went all the way to
Armageddon against Wesley so and bidding
as low as 9 minutes and 28 seconds in
the Armageddon Hikaru still got the draw
he needed to win the match with the
black pieces but that is a little bit
that is a little bit but I have to say
Hikaru was a man with a plan because he
actually wanted to play an Armageddon he
had worked out in the break exactly how
low he could go to make that bid and he
decided okay he wanted the black pieces
and this was the maximum time he could
give Wesley and uh it worked out what
can I say he was a perfect strategy from
Hikaru and then Magnus Carlson he also
won his match in Armageddon but he did
lose his first game of the 2023
Champions chess tour season he's not
unbeatable no he's not unbeatable and I
have to say it was a bit surprising to
say because Magnus started the day on
such good form you know he looked
Unstoppable and then of course he just
took the foot off the paddle for the
those games two and three and then again
Magnus is the king of comebacks and when
it came to the Armageddon Magnus was
just again back on unbeatable form
still on the winners bracket Magnus
Carlsen but then the losers round won
yesterday two players were knocked out
Ali Raza farusha and the Ralph mama
dogesh and Serana making it through to
today's losers quarterfinals and we're
gonna follow the winners final between
Magnus and Hikaru later today because
first it is the losers bracket and the
losers quarterfinals with Wesley so
against Alexa Serana and Arjun ergassi
against gukesh Wesley so fighting to
survive in the tournament and he's
playing a lot of online chess yeah
Wesley he's in the Last Chance Saloon
but you know that doesn't bother him
because yesterday you know before the
match against Hikaru Nakamura he plays
the early title Tuesday won that 10
points out of 11 and then after his
match against Hikari perhaps needed to
burn off some frustration and he also
played the late title Tuesday one that
with nine and a half points out of 11.
completely unbeaten yesterday day so he
is a man in form and fighting to survive
today Wesley so yesterday with all the
drama going on we also enjoyed a very
nice puzzle that you had with you Ivanka
so we're gonna have another puzzle for
the viewers today and uh let's reveal it
yeah I mean this puzzle I think is just
amazing it's a study composed by Vitali
kovalenko and it's one of my personal
favorites now it looks quite simple it
looks like a pawn race but there is such
a nasty Twist on the board
and don't get confused don't get uh
swayed by those ghosts but I'm going to
leave it out there it's white to play
there's a lot of twists and turns and uh
it's the kind of puzzle quite frankly
which once you've solved it don't cheat
please that's not fun but uh you kind of
like message your friends you message
your family and you share it with
however many people you like because
it's just amazing yeah
solve it together with friends family
maybe you're at work maybe you're at
school gather everyone around and try to
solve this puzzle that has a lot of
twists and turns very cool now Magnus
Carlsen he doesn't have a lot of Nemesis
but he certainly did struggle against
Indian teenagers on the tour last season
oh look at the bar yeah it's this clever
or is this madness Okay actually Prague
finds the best move I was about
stockfish the computer had three
suggestions there move I mentioned
taking that white Pawn would have been
fine for black but this is even better
okay Magnus does try and create that air
for his King but as you guys mentioned
the only Escape Square for that wiping
is up the board on a light Square 8.5 on
the bar trackmate it's just coming Cliff
Edge yeah but oh wow what a move black
cuts the coordination between White's
queen and the second Rankin is Magnus
about to resign Magnus Carlson the world
champion loses to 16 year old pregnant
on that it looks winning Fair guys is he
getting his revenge
I I want to put wow I would never play
this move in a million years
looks hopeless doesn't it for Magnus
really do you think he knows just yeah
this is his expression leaning forward
he knows it's all out of control at
least
um I mean he's just trying to make
things messy at the moment yeah pretty
is off you guys
he needs business
oh but he's getting all the Rooks off
the board now and Magnus reacts surely
this is winning for white
he is so upset angry with himself and
there it is it's over Magnus Carlson he
loses to 19 year old Arjun Eric icy
foreign
Something's Happened
um it did feel a bit wrong for Magnus to
play this move I actually thought Magnus
had something
um a bit stronger is the queen trapped
wow Lawrence the queen is actually
trapped in the center and the Queen on
B6 protects the E6 Pawn that's that's a
crucial thing yeah oh they said that's
the real threat just like a house of
cards his position just completely fell
apart it is over Magnus Carlsen loses to
another Indian teenager
he actually became the youngest player
ever you catch to beat Magnus Carlsen
after Magnus became a world champion and
was a year young dukesh had last year he
played for the Indian B team in the
Olympiad they took a bronze medal and uh
playing on the first board yukash also
took the gold medal this must have been
huge in India Tanya this was a big
moment we were hosting the Olympiad and
then we had this a young India beat Team
and they were phenomenal alongside of
course Uzbekistan who took the gold
medal but gokish led the team he was the
front runner he won a gold on board one
and what a performance an absolute
breakout moment for gokish yeah and the
other young Indians as well had a
fantastic tournament in the Olympiad the
Eric I see on the Indian a team took an
individual silver medal on board three
Prague took the bronze medal oh wow the
guy in the center looks really
taking the gold medal on board through
your very own David I don't think I
don't think I see the metal I wonder if
we have something else so we can
actually see
[Music]
you got me again
it was a huge moment for you though
David taking that gold medal I do feel
guilty uh just kind of getting in there
ahead of fairy geisi and Prague to uh
players who are clearly going to be at
the top of world chest for a long time
but it was an honor to share the podium
with them yeah and talking about the
pragma Nanda he's not playing in
division one here in the air things
monsters but he's playing on uh in
division three and he has a big match
coming up today Robert yeah he's
performing excellently in division three
he takes on Sam Sevin by the super Grand
Master From America also very young but
no longer a teenager so probably a big
opportunity to score a victory and head
on to the Grand Final wow impressive
stuff by Young Prague and in division
two they are also playing some
interesting matches today and it's
especially interesting to look on the
losers bracket in division two one very
big match coming up here Jana pomyachi
against blood McCormick how did they end
up here Robert you would expect to see
that in the winners Yeah final in the
top division by Jana Palmer he didn't
play yesterday I think he was in transit
Vladimir chromic lost the match in this
rapid format not always his best friend
but we see another all-russian matter
Dimitri on Drake and Daniel dubo that
too could be a division one One winners
final so division two super strong as
well definitely and remember the winner
of division two qualifies for division
one in the next event on the Champions
chess tour now we are going to follow
division one today starting out with the
losers quarterfinals it is best out of
two rapid games and if they are tied
well then we know it's gonna head to
Armageddon it's Wesley so against Alexa
is Serana and then Arjun erag icy
against dukesh you're not rooting for
any of them are you Tanya I'm so torn in
this one I'm Gonna Keep the unbiased
approach here and it's a bit bittersweet
because one of them will go forward but
it will be the end of the road for one
of the Indians and their friends they
know that and I think they will be happy
whoever goes through they will feel
slightly bad at the same time yeah and
you've brought with you some uh some
cool footage of these two there as you
mentioned good friends what am I seeing
here is this go cash in a boxing Rome
this happened and then we have the face
Ruby this was a death match organized by
chess space India and it was a huge
event there were thousands of people who
were watching and there we see Arjun
walking in with his uh with his boxing
suit on they really went at it with each
other in this one what a match this was
uh just so much fun to watch they played
different formats and in the end just in
the last moment the last game Arjun took
this Championship away what a cool cool
event that was the credit to uh chess
face India for sharing that footage with
us and here they are ready for the big
fight Arjun aragaisi 19 years old
against dukash 16 years old best
attitude rapid games the winner will
make its room to tomorrow's losers
semi-finals
and it is Arjun starting out with the
white pieces
what should we expect from this match
well Aldrin plays pretty much every
opening Under the Sun and he plays them
all extremely well so it will have been
hard for kukesh to prepare for this game
looks like the clock has started we
don't have the moves coming in yet uh
we'll try and get that refreshed as soon
as possible but uh yeah it's unclear who
the favorite is every guy see a couple
of years older than uh his countryman
here slightly more experienced you would
say but good cash has had a fantastic
these two met over the board in tata
steel just a few weeks ago it was a draw
very hard for draw there and um okay
where are the moves yeah we want an
update ghost moves there are some
technical issues moves are coming out do
you have them up on your computer yeah I
think they're they're just getting
underway it started as a caracon so
hopefully the moves come up shortly you
catch with the black pieces there they
are our generic I see playing what is
well regarded as the fantasy variation
of the caracon so let's see what kind of
fantasy it will continue to be for the
Indian fans who don't know who to root
for and it's already a fascinating
position why is it called fantasy
variation
I understand it's quite hard to know the
answer to them I'm not sure it's like
the genre it's not like a Lord of the
Rings type of position but uh it's just
I guess takes to create a bit of
creativity to push the white Pawn to F3
on move three against the Karo Khan uh I
should just explain we're ignore
ignoring the Lifeboat for now that one
isn't updating so this is the analysis
board are going to focus here because it
is the current position and we'll follow
it here on the central board for now
until we get things fixed but uh crazy
coincidence just two days ago I was up
until 3am in the morning studying the
fancy variation preparing notes for a
student of mine in this opening from the
black side and I said don't go into this
it's too complicated it's too much to
learn and if you're not careful you
might get attacked on the F7 Square
you're very weak so I chose a different
sub variation but uh this one decent
reputation do you soon listen that's the
big question uh that's yet to be seen I
said go memorize these notes I doubt uh
I doubt that would have been heard but
uh meanwhile karakan of famously solid
opening and uh Arjun just tried to take
your cash out of uh more well-known
Waters I must admit I'm not used to
seeing the white Bishop on E2 normally
it goes to more active squares and uh
there we go the live board is working
again so we can't trust it and arjun's
last move was to centralize this night
night bd2 and both sides now will decide
where to cast tool and where to put
their pieces I think the opening
approach is going to be so important in
this match because both these players
Arjun and gokish they come from the Waka
school which is the west west bridge on
and chess Academy they've got the same
trainers the same mentors They Know Each
Other's repertoire so well so it's
really important to surprise uh the
opponent I think that's what Arjun has
managed to do with this fantasy
variation of the karakan so nice
approach and we're talking about the
uncompromising style of play and that's
exactly what we've been what we're
seeing look at those Central pawns they
look like they've given white so much
space but on the other hand they can
also turn out to be a weakness black can
start putting up piling up the pressure
on that E4 and the D4 Pawn both on open
files I love the activity that gokish
has currently the Bishops are out the
knights are developed it just looks like
archon might be slightly behind in
development and one of the big problems
when you have these pawns like this as
soon as you push one the square it was
previously covering is now handed over
to your opponent so if you push the
spawn up to E5 that Knight sinks into
the D5 Square you're not dislodging it
you don't have another Pawn to kick it
so that Knight is very happy to stand in
the center so I feel like these
decisions being very difficult for any
player Arjun will have to figure out an
exact plan he's going to have to come up
is it right to push the pawn can you
just slide your queen away you need to
protect those pawns and center and black
is going to aim his forces at those
pawns that are sticking out and what a
nice classy move there from gakash uh
well okay I got there a bit early we'll
see that move happen on the board in a
second uh it looks like Black's Bishop
is about to slide around and back and uh
he wants to eye up this White Queen it's
all about putting pressure on those
Central pawns I like the Symmetry in
Black's position right now with the
Bishops nicely placed and white also has
these pawns that you guys were
mentioning but doesn't really have the
peace development to back it up so we
will at some point see white race to get
his Knight out of the way of his bishop
and
still a middle game that could go in
either direction but right now it does
look like your cash has got a healthy
position as black out of the opening
that's all you can ask for in these very
short matches to survive with black to
get a playable position and he has
achieved that and speaking of a playable
position it was already on move number
eight that we were in absolute new
territory so both these players really
just want to get a game not go into any
theoretical battle and I think Mukesh is
happy about that because we know the
kind of opening preparation that Arjun
has it's phenomenal so I I like this
approach where you go for a middle game
where neither of you are familiar and
you basically get get a position with
everything to play for all three results
possible Bishop page five the move that
you were talking about I think we're
going to see it shortly on the board it
shows that gokish even though not so
many games here knows what he's doing
yeah it seems like he knows what he's
doing and uh Arjun meanwhile he's got a
healthy enough position if if he can
hold his pawns together so he'll be
figuring out just how to uh consolidate
how to get active again and uh in terms
of well we talked about both of them
being very strong players you're not
taking side to Tanya of course who do
you think on paper is going to be better
at this format this exact time format
with the elimination
it's just a Sprint here two games that's
a good question I think Arjun might just
slightly have a little more experience
he's uh been in the Champions Chester we
saw him in the finals but in terms of
strength I think it's really hard to
pick both these players have this very
energetic ambitious style of play they
don't go for the draws they always go
for the option that creates a mess on
the board Arjun relies a lot more on
intuition I think super good calculator
of course but he takes decisions which
are quite intuitive at times kukesh
meanwhile is a hardcore calculations fan
he can see lines really fast so I think
it's going to be a lot about those time
scrambles with Fighting Chess we can
expect a long game and in this format
it's going to be about who can keep the
speed and the nerves when the clock runs
down it's going to be an exciting match
and if you are rooting for any of these
two Indians then share with us either on
Twitter using the hashtag chess Champs
or in the twitch chat we will pay close
attention to that as well and uh really
really enjoy it when you guys join in if
you do have questions comments then
share it on Twitch we'll bring up as
many questions as we can for our
excellent experts in the studio here guy
you're putting 1.3 billion people in a
very tight spot right now let me tell
you that both these players have this
huge fan base because they're so mild
Manner and then they're so humble and
just really nice kids actually but on
the board there's a different side of
them that you see so I don't think it's
gonna be it's gonna be easy for the
Indian fans to pick a side today and I
think a lot of them are going to be
heartbroken a lot of celebrations at the
same time yeah yeah I tried to push you
Tanya I tried to say who's the favorite
you still didn't choose you still didn't
take sides and uh yeah impressive uh the
neutrality there but I mean while the
position has changed somewhat black has
parted with the bishop pair but that was
to provoke one of the white pawns
forward and that strong night on the
Rock Solid outpost on D5 has been
established the one that Robert was uh
pointing to earlier and uh kukash to me
on the face of things looks like he's
done a very good job of uh just Clinging
On and uh kind of
eroding uh the white porn Center here
just getting great squares for his
pieces but the question is what next and
uh Arjun now in the move will be maybe
centralizing his Rooks bringing more
pizza to the center
and uh still anyone's game one really
interesting tactic here in the position
that white has but it doesn't work David
is this knight jump to G5 imagine you go
Knight G5 and you're already threatening
a huge mate on 87 you say one second the
bishop on E2 Hanks but what happens if
black actually picks that up Queen at
seven well it's not a mate yet but the
king side steps one move but that's as
long as it's going to survive because
the Rook jumps into the attack and after
Rook F7 it would be game over but
thankfully for Arjun after Knight jumps
to G5 the bishop on H5 is hanging the
pawn on 87 is hanging the bishop can
actually slide back to G6 taking care of
everything on the board attacking
White's Queen so attempting option to
jump with the Knight but not accurate
yeah that would certainly have been the
first thing that came to mind the first
thing he calculated ardr generic IC but
instead going back he decided to use his
Bishop on this diagonal creating a
battery with the White Queen and
slightly surprising to me uh the pawn is
pushed forward to H6 covering any Knight
G5 jumps and uh taking the pawn off
please but now this bishop doesn't have
too many Escape squares so uh slightly
risky here Robert yeah definitely risky
and one of the common plays against the
structure is to throw in the check flick
that in Bishop H7 check to force the
king to the corner and then bring the
bishop back to F5 and now that move G2
to G4 is very threatening because the
bishop is not well defended on the G6
Square so I feel like white has the
upper hand here uh the king for black is
less safe than the white king but the
one thing that white needs to be pay
attention to is this Pawn on D4 it's a
backwards Pawn so if black is able to
bring the queen out to B6 eventually not
now there's a knight that would be loose
on D7 that pawn can be a bit tender
that's the hope that gukesh will have
here is that he can create counter play
against that pawn yeah so uh that
sequence looks very promising for white
at least it would ask him some awkward
questions of kukesh right now let's wait
to see what Audrey does if he just wants
to play an autopilot move maybe he'll
just centralize a rook but as you say
Robert's uh there will be at least a
time a time out for black to start
creating his own counter play so it
feels like there's a bit of urgency in
the position uh both players have played
relatively quickly up to this point it's
a very tense middle game uh let's let uh
Arjun aragaisy think and Ponder his next
move now guys it's kind of hard for me
to pick a favorite I'm I'm completely
torn but I have to ask you Kaya Robert
David you've seen these two on the door
uh what do you think about this matchup
and who would you think is maybe just
slightly slightly has a better chance
I'm slightly biased um I'm a huge fan of
both of these two uh but I'm biased by
my own experiences I've played gokesh a
few times first time I think when he
just became a Grandmaster he was 12
years old and I just uh played maybe the
most boring chess imaginable eventually
bought him to death and managed to take
the point I also played him in the world
Blitz last year and I managed to grind
him down in a rook end game but Arjun
eragisi I've played in Blitz and I've
never been crushed so badly in my life I
played him last year and he barely spent
10 seconds on his he was just playing
every move instantly just out playing me
strategically not many people were
capable of doing that in such a fashion
but it was very one-sided and he
destroyed me uh so I'm gonna say Arjun
and I think I know better than to answer
the question because you said you didn't
want the Indian population matter you I
don't want them mad at me so I'm just
saying both these players are awesome
we're ruin them both on but in all
seriousness they both have their
different strengths I mean they think
they're both versatile players and
despite the fact that they're teenagers
they've shown some great class they have
restraints and a lot of teeners struggle
with that they're afraid to go to the
end game because they think that in the
end game they haven't studied as as
deeply no these players the opening
middle game end game they're complete
well-rounded players and I think that
for our generic I see after the Tata
steel event it's hard to forget about
all those losses I know he is already
won a match here in the air things
Masters and he qualified for division
one which is an accomplishment in and of
itself but you want to get those wins
and gukesh beat him in tata steel that
was one of those losses he probably
wants that Revenge yeah probably we now
I'm definitely not gonna answer a
favorite but uh
but I will say one thing because Ivanka
brought my attention and I think this is
super cute uh sort of underlining the
age of these two uh players aragaisi uh
behind him is a shelf and in one of
those shelves is all his teddy bears I
think that's so cute so I like that he
has a lot of teddy bear fans behind him
at least yes cheering him on bringing
him luck everyone has a lucky mascot
right you guys or just me I don't know
it's just you
um I I don't have it here with me annoy
actually but I have a Pikachu like a big
cuddly Pikachu really let's uh it's been
at the end of my bed uh in England for
like 15 years
Pokemon fan yeah big Pokemon yeah I
missed those days on the Game Boy
when he missed those days you probably
still have that Game Boy dust it off
play it I know there are people in my
life who wouldn't approve these days but
yeah maybe after this tournament did you
did you guys practice the throw Pikachu
I Choose You
uh no even though I'm not that nerdy
hi Mr I miss the Pokemons yeah everyone
gets into games and uh sports or in
certain ways right and that was my way
into gaming in general just the
competitive aspect of Pokemon and nice
trying to beat my friends and uh that
kind of transported over to the Chess
World how about a chess set with only
Pokemons that would be super cool who
would be the king and the Queen
Professor Oak Professor Oak would be uh
would he be the king
Brock and Misty yeah Misty would be my
queen
back to the chest
so a few moves here Robert you predicted
the future White's Bishop did land up on
that F5 Square he's really forced black
to start retreating that glorious Knight
on D5 is forced to a passive post both
of those Black Knights now a bit tied up
defending what do we think of uh
developments here I mean I like White's
position you just have so much more
space the King on H1 it looks like it's
a bit Breezy vulnerable Queen D5 comes
in making use of a pin on the diagonal
but black is well defended for now the
knights are protecting their Bishop on
G6 that's of vital importance and that
D4 Pawn remains a backwards Pawn a
future Target so I just feel like
White's position is a bit flimsy so if
Arjun is not careful things could fall
apart but for now he has control of
those dark squares thanks to that
beautiful Bishop on B4 it covers the
length of diagonal can stick its teeth
into the D6 square at some point or
trade itself off for a night if the
moment calls for it so I like the look
of White's position for now I'm just
worried how the trajectory game might go
if he doesn't be accurate here and land
some kind of attack wow there have been
some very dangerous and committed
Decisions by white we are praising
White's positions but I think with every
pawn move there have also been a lot of
weaknesses in White's camp we see that
D5 Square which was first used by
Black's Knight and now the queen lands
there Rook has been moved to D1 to
defend that default key Pawn but we are
talking about how good whites Bishops
look I think it can be very dangerous to
play this kind of a position as well
imagine the Black Knight Landing onto E6
right now he's developed a final piece
the only piece that was not part of the
plan dukesh brings The Rook to the
center of the board as well always watch
out for threats like the Knight taking
the bishop forcing the white Pawn to
recapture and then the black Bishop
sliding back to H5 uh David where it
will hit the spin Knight now not just
pin to the king but also the rook and D1
I would be scared to play with white
hair yeah the key word there is
committal there's no going back now for
I see his pawns will not Retreat he'll
always be weak on the light squares and
in the current position as both of you
were alluding to there the white king
will always be weak so uh yeah how do
you proceed here if you're a guy see you
need to justify those commitments you've
made you need to keep stepping forward
it's like a bike you need to keep
pedaling otherwise you'll fall off and
uh here I'm wondering how we continue
the attack it would be very attempting
to post up the bishop on this night out
nice outpost on D6
to be honest though I'm running out of
other ideas I really want to get my king
off this diagonal but it feels too slow
to take your time out and put it on a
slightly safer Square it feels like you
need to do something but he doesn't
really see what to do right now I don't
I've got to be honest and he's burning
time on the clock and black is maximize
right look at all the black's pieces
they're staring at the White Center at
some point their Knight on E7 will chop
off the bishop on F5 and then once the
pawn recaptures the bishop will take use
of the newly free H5 Square so I think
we could see a variation like this and
that would be a problem for white the
Knight is loose it's pinned in multiple
directions that's quite scary stuff so I
do think that gukesh has played
excellent chess and if I'm looking at
some arjun's perspective maybe it's time
to get rid of that beautiful Knight on
E7 the bishop looks great but wow he
just had to push forward H4 he is
showing no fear whatsoever yeah but
first Roberts I think he made a very
wise decision he did get rid of that
black knight so at least now if there is
a bishop trade then no way to attack
this pinned piece and suddenly White's
another lunch they will start breaking
forward and storming the black king side
and uh yeah H4 it's criminal again but
once you've said a you might as well say
B just throw them all towards the black
king in this case once you've said g you
might as well say it
and there's really terrifying to see
White's position and this is one of
those games don't try this at home your
own Pawns in front of your own King are
supposed to be there to Shield it now of
course both these youngsters they're
super cat they're super at calculating
and they will pay concrete variations
but these can be so dangerous I still
like Black's position it just felt feels
like it's more safe no problems on the
black king all the pieces are playing
just so many loose spots in arjun's
position and I see that our eval Bar
says that everything's fine but from a
practical perspective I would pick black
any day of the week yeah often in these
positions especially in this time format
you just want a position that's easy to
play easy to handle you don't have to
calculate too much here for kakash until
white really breaks open some lines some
files towards the black king it feels
like you don't have to work out too many
things first you need a plan though so
that's why gukesh is thinking bring out
that night that night needs to come into
the game and I like the idea of playing
Knight E6 it's a move that we've been
talking about uh notice that F4 square
is a weakness a nice spot for the Knight
to jump into what is really interesting
to see is how fearlessly Arjun is
playing he's also keeping control on his
clock and making sure that he doesn't
fall back behind too much but I think
this is the kind of position David where
you really need time on the clock to
navigate when things get tricky and I
see that kukesh has gone on to improve
that night really logical approach
you're also targeting the D4 Pawn so
watch out for all these weaknesses that
you have voluntarily created in your
Camp yeah and this is a temporary Pawn
sacrifice but I don't think white should
get tempted to capture this bishop yes
the White Queen can back it up and take
this Pawn but you have opened a line
towards this piece we've mentioned in a
few variations now that this Knight is a
huge Target due to the pin and yeah
Suddenly It's just going to fall off the
board it's attacked once If you defend
it again then okay all sorts of problems
here and Knight fork for example hitting
the white Rook hitting the White Queen
and you could also just slide across
your rook and eventually you'll
overwhelm White's defenses Suddenly It's
all backfired all those Pawn pushers so
uh Arjun he wants to maintain the status
quo he doesn't want to open up lines
because that will only uh be a sign of
trouble for the white king and therefore
he steps forward maybe even plunting his
King on G3 behind the wall of Pawns uh
Brave stuff but yeah still nothing wrong
with it still in the balance the best
thing that gukesh has done is look at
that Clark management I feel like
throughout the everything's Masters he's
been ahead on the clock so he keeps that
lead and with the black pieces his King
is the safer of the two but I do like
that last move from origin he steps out
of any pins and we keep talking about
this trade the tension between the
Bishops on the light Square diagonal
black does not want to take the bishop
on F5 because it helps White Drive other
Pawn forward so black sufficient looks
excellent It's about coming up with
ideas maybe you'll try to break create a
pawn exchange at some moment but those
decisions are not easy so good cash is
leading the clock that's I think the
most important thing at the moment King
H2 a nice move just side stepping from
the fin and I think white has a threat
here you were talking about how Robert
black should not take that Bishop on F5
white wants to force black to do that on
the next move imagine advancing that
Harry the H Bond you go to H5 the bishop
and G6 will have no squares left and
have to take a call to trade on F5 and
now black would be super happy if white
was the one making that decision to open
that file but if black has to do it on
white stems then not such a happy
decision to be made so gokish now taking
a little bit of time here critical
moment a move like a night jump comes to
mind you know it's always so tempting to
get your knight into your opponent's
Camp yeah let's check out what happens
uh we're looking for ideas here for
gokesh his time advantage meanwhile all
disappearing now but if he does jump in
this is a call to just Advance the king
forward I'm hesitant to suggest it but
the similar ideas do appear in openings
like the French defense Robert's
favorite there you do often bring your
king up just uh nothing else to do you
have to kick away enemy pieces from your
half of the board you have to cover
squares and the King does at least Force
the Knight backwards just to show
Tanya's Point as well if we do nothing
for good cash if you just push a Pawn on
the other side of the board kind of a
relevant move here then white does get
the opportunity to break the tension in
uh arjun's favorite in this case and
suddenly the difference here is that the
Black Knight can't use the square
because the White Knight is no longer
pinned if you do jump white will be more
than happy to trade off and suddenly
these white pawns are stepping forward
uh suddenly it's bad news for the black
king
suddenly that black king which looked
safe as houses it's uh all out in the
open after a move like F6 so uh
Potential Threat on the board and kukash
doesn't look too comfortable he goes for
this night jump you predicted it Tanya
will we see the king step forward to
kick it out
the one good thing about Knight to F4 is
that the idea of pushing that H Pawn now
might not be as strong because after the
trades of the bishop you're forced to
recapture with the queen I think because
you can't take it with the pawn as the
H5 bond is now hanging video move King
to G3 that is brave David uh if Arjun
finds it that's going to be super
impressive we've heard King is a piece
in the end game but in this position
how is it still just marching forward
like that and not getting checkmated I
think the knight's gonna have to hide
that after King up to G3 you'll swap
Bishops it doesn't seem like it's
something you want to do but now the G4
Pawn captures the H5 square is available
to that Knight and is white really going
to go King G4
it looks fun right the Knight is
actually kind of Trapped over there so
what does black do in response I mean
there must be tactics saving block here
we see the eval bar suggesting that it's
about uh level but that's dynamic
equality that you need to find a series
of only moves because your king is up on
G4 but on the other hand the Black
Knight is trapped and King G3 step one
has been played by Arjun eragisi he has
shown no fear of this entire game I
think that King is going all the way up
to G4 this is wild if we got that
position with the King to G4
I I I'll be speechless which doesn't
happen very often
wow very brave played from Eric icy and
uh now both players are around the four
minute mark this one is going to end up
in a Time scramble and it's still going
to be wild I think this position
guarantees a bit of chaos I can't
imagine the Queen's coming off and some
really stable end game it doesn't look
like that type of position but Robert
does he even have an option apart from
taking that bishop and walking into this
line that we're talking about with white
skin marching all the way to G4 to win a
knight on H5 because you can't really
fall back with the Knight anymore now
it's too late the bishop and G6 might be
hanging yeah and the H5 move that we've
been advocating for as well so I feel
like you're right it is the time has
come where you have to take this bishop
but what's troubling me and I was just
praising gukash's clock management is
that suddenly he's thinking he made the
night move and the King came up and now
he actually is to E6 but spending a lot
of time so he does not feel comfortable
right now and we're saying chaos origin
era geissi he's kind of an agent of
chaos he's gonna throw the that H Pawn
up the board offer a trade and the take
with his Jeep on and try to use it as a
battering ram and open up the black king
yeah suddenly he's going to be sweating
go cash he's not going to be feeling
comfortable at all still questions if
the Knight moves for example of whether
you cannot break things open with your
king out on such a vulnerable Square as
well but it definitely feels like things
are turning in White's favor and he
doesn't hesitate he's uh trying to speed
up a bit on the clock here every guys
he's trying to hustle on the board as
well and we have that position in front
of us look how strong these pawns are a
few moves ago I agree with Tanya I would
have taken black every time I thought
black was Rock Solid but not anymore and
every guy see if he picks this moment
well to push one of these pawns forward
he should be able to launch a
breakthrough it does feel very strong
for weight not sure if now is the moment
or maybe it's time to run away hide and
then just get your Rook to an open file
first before we start attacking matter
of taste what would we do here in the
studio go for the attack now I think
such a big deal though is that black
doesn't really have a follow-up you
would love to put them with C5 as black
open up the position but the D4 pawn and
the queen cover the square so I do think
that with that being unavailable to
black white does have a move so I think
you can fix your queen the queen on C2
looks good I might bring it back to
scene one and up to F4 just making the
king feel safer and going for that H6
Pawn because if you throw in the move F6
and black is unable to take it that
spells Doom for the black king in the
corner yeah just a sample variation
showing uh what could happen if things
go wrong for black the queen could jump
in and this one's going to be game over
it's going to end in Checkmate very very
shortly so that would be a very sneaky
move instead he centralizes his rook and
uh also looks decent to me preparing
potentially a pawn push a bit later on
but good catch now has a move or two to
try and uh keep things under control
maybe parking the Knight on the
defensive square like this one is what
he needs to do it's not pleasant it's
not a great Square aesthetically but
yeah go cash on the back foot at least
with a small time Advantage still wow
started off so so excitingly super
exciting and I'm just amazed that
arjun's nerves in this one advancing
those bonds and not stopping at that
also advancing the king all the way to
G3 he has decided to move the Rook to E1
so making sure all the pawns stay
defended at some point he can also look
at a lift with the Rook or getting the
queen to the centralized E4 Square it's
a really nice Square to put a piece on
to keep everything together it's one of
those super rare positions in chess
where white skin on G3 with no bond
Shield is absolutely safe yeah I guess
modern chess yeah if there are no pieces
around to defend to attack it then it's
not that weak surely but uh yeah it is
brave nonetheless and we're seeing some
comments here using sides who are is uh
who are the fans supporting yeah I feel
like I haven't seen anyone actually
choose a song everyone except for you
David we know just to chill out and just
say hello great chess we do not want to
have an angry fan base on our heels
likes both of them it's so hard to pick
one you know they've got this similar
versatile style that you were talking
about they're so similar and that
strength both just amazing people off
the board and super strong on the board
you know playing playing ambitious chess
regardless of who they're playing
against they play fearlessly including
when they're playing against each other
and I think that's the reason it's hard
to pick and have a favorite
I did see a comment in the twitch chat
uh someone calling Arjun agent of chaos
yeah I said that yeah they're just
they're just taking my words and where's
the copyright somebody you know play
back the video
and I think Robert this game is such a
big example of Arjun being the agent of
chaos I mean he literally has created
chaos out of nothing there was no need
to go for any of this but he has just
made a mess on the board and right now
it looks like he's being rewarded and
he's in control of that mess is that
sort of his style as well it always
feels that way no matter how complex it
becomes he always seems to have
something up his sleeve he always seems
to have foreseen into the future uh
sufficiently to uh yeah to turn things
in his favor and if we think of Chess as
a battle game then it feels like white
is taking over the battlefield he's
stepped up to the fifth rank he's
controlling all the squares black is
just kind of huddling away in his half
now just hoping for the best and apart
from the black queen I really hate those
black pieces not well placed at all and
the Clark don't like that at all for a
good guess right now or generici I mean
he looks cool as a cucumber you would
not expect that he is in the middle of a
crazy position and look at this move the
Rook slides next to the king it's both
defensive and aggressive in some
positions because if that G7 Pawn just
throw it off the board then there's a
rook in line with the white king that's
why the white Rook steps in front so now
we have defense mixed with offense
multi-purpose moves by both players
white has so much extra space but black
is defending very accurately the clock
though is going to be a weapon for our
generic I see yep he's so quick he's so
ruthless when he when he gets the chance
Arjun and I do fear for gakesh this last
move retreating this Rook isn't one he
would have made happily and now how can
we add extra ingredients to this attack
watch Rick at the bottom of the board on
F1 feels a bit left out it wants to line
up with this fellow Rook on the G file
and finally that brave King that
Intrepid don't worry it steps back and
clearing the path for the G file but
when you're under attack on the side of
the board you have to strike in the
center I think black needs to push the
beat Pawn to push the C Pawn next and if
black is able to crack what's impressive
Pawn chain from D4 to E5 maybe then
there are some chances so I really think
it's now or never forgesh because you
can't just sit and do nothing forever
and oh wow and he plays a pawn push on
the other side of the board and the
evaluation bar doesn't really react
negatively so that's a an impressive
choice but if that white knight goes up
to G6 that would be Checkmate I guess
the Black Knight can step out the way
but it's looking scary for the black
king yeah F6 is another Super Brave move
in this position I mean imagine that
night on G6 it's game over but as you're
mentioning Knight H4 is an option here
threatening that ridiculous smothered
made on the black king but then black
has this defense of advancing his own
Knight to G5 blocking that G5 blocking
that Rook on G4 and creating a very
important look for the King on H7 yep
not quite smothered mate here you do
manage to escape and uh really creative
stuff it does kind of go against
conventional wisdom of touching pawns on
the side that you're weaker and Arjun
swings this queen across lining up on
the g-files from tactics he's under 10
seconds now go cash and he has to plug
that g-file with his Knight and now
could we be heading towards an end game
if there's a night trade suddenly the
Queens might disappear as well who do we
think this will favor I think if ever is
white because of the impressive Pawn
chain uh you could swap all the pieces
and then plant your Pawn on E6 that is
going to be a protected pass pawn and
the position is a bit closed for the
moment but that allows white the time to
bring that King play King of the Hill go
to the E4 Square then trying to open up
more files for your Rooks so I feel like
black is really playing on the defensive
here However if those pawns are
blockaded then maybe black has enough
time to go after some of White's pawns
but I do think that white has the upper
hand yeah so audrian potentially just
weighing up the pros and cons of going
into the end game he can keep the
tension for removal too longer if he
wants to but uh let's go back and see
what he's done okay he's pushed that
pawn forward first so the option of
trading the knights trading the Queens
still available to him could cash around
12 seconds he's playing purely on
Instinct right now yeah and uh okay he
does bring his Knight forward so
allowing a queen trade but he wants to
plant his Knight on this G6 Square cage
that black king for later on there will
be meeting Nets there will be mating
patterns that go cash has to fight
against for the rest of the game we have
the first result of today it's a great
start for Wesley so he has won the first
game with the white pieces against Alexa
Serana taking the lead in their match
and the loser is quarterfinals it is
best out of two rapid games to decide
these matchers on the losers bracket
it's looking very good for Wesley Seoul
right now
yeah it's also looking good for Arjun
aragaisy I think he's found a really uh
positive version of that end game we
were discussing a moment ago once
White's night does end up on the G6
Square after centralizing his King then
uh yeah he's got full control it's time
for a night sacrifice take those past
pawns Knight takes E6 you'll get two
pawns right there and then you'll also
be able to snag the H5 Pawn three pawns
is worth a night at least from a
prospective material worth but look at
this unfortunately for Google he just
pushed his a pawn now the trades it's
not going to be enough because that pass
Pawn is cemented there on E6 he's
playing with second look at the clock
it's all about the clock all his
decisions are beside it's down to zero
he makes a move but has he made it in
time or did gokish get flagged he made
it in time just wow whoa seconds left we
see we see the clock really reacting
here struggling to keep up because
they're playing
yeah Tanya it looks like a winning
tactic now you can give a check okay the
players they are not calculating they're
just relying on instincts and this looks
strong too he's just simply going to
advance his E Pawn forward bring that
white uh White Rook to the top of the
board and game over it's done he just I
just pushed the pawn then I think that
forces resonation on the spot yep and uh
here we go guys yeah once Rook is gonna
reach that eighth Rank and break the
black defenses the bar reacts and margin
is going to take the win he's been going
in its favor for a long time but there
we go I think he's going to confirm it
go cash lean's back is he gonna resign
no defense now for black there we go
result wow Arjun Ergo I see he strikes
first in the big Indian match against
gukesh winning the first game in their
losers quarterfinals that means gukesh
has to win the next uh game game two to
take this one to an Armageddon watch a
game some Chaos on the board
entertainment David take us through the
highlights yeah some crucial moments in
this game but just want to highlight one
that Robert actually mentioned but
kukesh simply didn't have enough time to
calculate and it was this critical
moment white is trying to play King of
the Hill my favorite variant by the way
trying to get the king into the center
of the board but this did allow black
one moment to save the game Knight takes
Pawn getting rid of those strong white
pawns would potentially have turned
things around somewhat what black does
get two pawns for the night this is a
check and maybe a third Pawn would drop
off on the edge of the board later
suddenly you've got rid of the strongest
part of White's position and great
chances to save the game instead he let
the pawn survive he simply moved his
Rook to the wrong side of the board and
we far if we fast forward to the end now
we saw the final stages of this game the
white Rook centralized and uh once the
pawn started stepping forward in the
center there was no way to save the game
Rook d8 eliminating the blockader and
white was about to make a new Queen
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is with
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
starting off the day with two decided
games Arjun Eric icy takes the first
point against his fellow Indian what a
game it was an incredible game I have to
say I'm slightly disappointed with the
outcome because
the cash pay the caracon and I love that
open and he actually played the
variation that I recommended in my book
but okay it was a great game I think
he's ready
I'm sorry okay so I'm not sure
very nice all right uh we're gonna keep
digging into uh the games of uh the
first set of games today but if you're
not a subscriber on Twitch here's a
twitch freak
[Music]
and we also have to talk about the other
game that happened Wesley so starting
out with the win against Alexa Serana
what happened in this one yeah it was a
very fascinating game actually it's
Alexis Arana came in with a plan he just
wanted to survive with the black pieces
he wanted to grovel for the draw
unfortunately he played a very imprecise
move and Wesley he took a long pause and
he used the time very wisely because
then he struck and it was
Alexi Serrano is King who was just
caught in the most Dreadful of positions
and Wesley I have to say his clock
handling was just magnificent because
often he was playing with less than a
minute on the clock and he just played
it perfectly wow so Wesley so seems to
be in top shape yeah absolutely you know
he's just not putting a foot wrong
he's incredible Wesley so and he can't
decide the match in the next game Alexey
Serrano he has to win the next game to
take it to Armageddon any other results
and he is knocked out now you did bring
with you a very cool puzzle today as
well Ivanka are people getting engaged
they're a puzzle ah they definitely are
I see a lot of right answers however
this puzzle this study is actually quite
multi-faceted because you have to
remember black has two pawns it's not
just one Pawn that can run so I'm just
gonna put that out there it's white to
play it's much harder than it looks but
when you find the solution oh my God it
will give you such a buzz wow
share your answer using hashtag chess
Champs on Twitter or share your answer
in the twitch chat gather friends family
whoever you are with and try to solve
it's a very it's a difficult puzzle even
for the title players like yourself it's
not difficult because it is the ideas
are quite straightforward but there's
just that one twist that keeps on coming
up and once you've figured out you'll
get it and you'll be like let me share
this with everybody I mean chess is like
that yeah best feeling to solve puzzles
and best feelings to win games as well
the second set of games on the losers
quarter finals is coming up
wow he just had to push forward H4 he is
showing no fear whatsoever yeah but
first robots I think he made a very wise
decision he did get rid of that Black
Knights the king G3 step one has been
played by Arjun air geisey he has shown
no fear this entire game I think that
King has been all the way up to G4
all right we're getting ready for game
choose on the losers quarter finals two
players they will have to win their
games right now to take it to Armageddon
two players can decide it now
withdrawals or wins go cash against Eric
icy and Alexa Serrano against Wesley so
so Robert what should we expect now from
the second set of games here Alexa
Serana gets the white pieces we know how
strong he is his record is almost
impeccable so he does have a shot and
then the other matchup between the
Indian Juniors it looked like a great
game from originara geisey it's going to
be tough for googes to bounce back but
if anyone can do it I think go cash can
what what do you tell yourself Tanya
when you're heading into must win
situations you have to just stop
thinking about what's happened and you
don't have to think that it is a
must-win situation he's still got three
games in the day so he starts with the
white pieces that's a positive and of
course knowing acacia's style of play
once again we can expect a long big
fight here uh no quick draws in this
match I think you just have to keep
going and make sure that you don't go on
tilt nothing has happened right now it
was a tough game could have gone either
way and uh I think kokesh will show what
he's made of he will try his best most
important is that he doesn't lose his
cool just yet in uh soccer or football
David we often say that two one is the
most dangerous lead to have in chess
it seems to be kind of dangerous to have
that one point lead when you only need a
draw that's when those blunders often
happen yeah we've seen it many times
before in previous seasons of the tour
even Magnus Carlsen can be affected by
this uh phenomenon normally the players
when they're leading they just want a
draw they take negative decisions they
take passive decisions and these top
players they're good enough to punish
you if you're not playing your best so
normally they do say the best way to get
the desired result to get the draw that
you need is to play your normal game but
it's incredibly hard to do
psychologically
your cash has the white pieces in this
must win situation
something's
nope something 's going on here
who are you expecting uh to win this
next game okay guys this says gokish's
last chance it's just two games yeah
it's not four games and I just realized
that I've been saying he has three games
but this is a win-on-demand game for
gokish actually so there's no time to
take things easy he's gonna come out all
God's blazing this is his final shot
yeah
it is must win for both Q cash and Alexa
Serrata and here we go yeah I was
wondering why you were looking at me
but uh yeah
I think she was looking at you because
you chose who you were rooting for and
everyone still is out to get you
I was right I should mention
you are gold medalist after all no
surprise that you're correct it's not
gonna be easy and we do have a Queen's
Gambit accepted in this game so it's
gonna be another big fight and the good
news for gokish is that well it is his
final game but he has the white pieces
and that's exactly what you want yeah
you want the white pieces and he did win
on Demand with white in the Armageddon
yesterday against Ralph memedov and can
he repeat that trick Arjun of course
very well booked up and it's the Queen's
Gambit accepted but it's not maybe the
traditional Queen's Gambit accepted
because White's Knight has come out to
the C3 Square very early that does
reduce your options often that white
knight wants to find different squares
or you want to get your king castled
first and start attacking in the center
instead kukesh keeps maximum tension he
Retreats his bishop and says okay we're
just going to get a game we're just
going to play chess
and Arjun I doubt he'll have prepared
this exact position before can he get
that type of solid position that he will
be craving in this game bringing out his
Knight putting pressure on White Center
we might well soon see an iqp position
with an isolated porn for white yeah and
these positions they start off quietly
but even if the Queens get traded that's
not the end of the story a lot of people
play these types of positions for a win
despite some of the limited material so
at the current setup we see that white
has three minor pieces developed black
has just developed his second and this
move A3 it's a very clever move you're
getting ready to take the black pawn C5
and now after the bishop will recapture
it you thrust that pawn forward to B4 so
that's sort of what's on the agenda in
this position is that you can expand
then develop your dark Square Bishop to
a useful diagonal by fan ketoing it and
that is what gukesh is looking for a
quiet start but there's more bite that
initially meets the eye yeah and often
it's a really tricky intricate waiting
game here because black doesn't have
that useful to move if you do move your
Bishop then white will force you to move
it for a second time by capturing as
Robert mentions and you've kind of lost
a Tempo if you moved the bishop twice in
the opening so do you release the
tension now because she's saying please
take me please at least clarify the pawn
structure and now we get a classical iqp
position isolated Queen's pawn and uh
plenty of ideas there that we'll explain
if we get to that position but uh if you
don't go for either of those ideas what
else well one of the ideas that we
should point out is that black cannot
pick up that pawn on D4 even though
you've got the Knight and the queen uh
attacking it and white has only one
Defender but watch out David if you do
get greedy in this position eventually
there will be a massive discover check
and you end up losing your queen and the
game on the spot so the Queen the pawn
is actually not hanging very often
you're absolutely right what black does
is to decide the center you don't want
to waste that move with the bishop
taking it at once and then forced to
again move it the next time when you
have to recapture it on C5 so I won't be
surprised if Arjun decides to actually
clarify the situation and then develop
his pieces so that at least he doesn't
lose that Tempo yep this will be one
option I guess uh it would be typical as
well to push a Pawn on the queen side
but are you ready for that you haven't
developed too many pieces okay he does
trade off in the center we see this
isolated Queen's Pawn it's not captured
of course as Tanya showed that and uh
the position now uh is about just
getting pieces out to good squares I do
kind of have a bias again towards the
white position here just because I
played isolated Queen's Pawn positions
my whole youth but uh yeah it tends to
be out of fashion these days uh to play
this type of structure with white but I
played those positions my whole Youth
too and I often lost them so I have
become biased against them in a way but
look at the latest move that is Justin
played Harry the H Pawn is thrown
forward that should be no surprise the
white Bishops are aiming in that
direction and now you're anticipating
well Arjun do you really want a castle
kingside where that pawn was just thrown
forward I'm not sure you do it looks
very dangerous so at least you're
putting that fear in arjun's heart and
he says well I'm not touching anything
on that side of the board let me throw
my Pawn forward on the queen side so
it's going to be interesting to see
where the Kings go from here wow H4 I
was not expecting that move but then
once again of course has to do
everything to create a mess on the board
he has to win this on demand so it is
the approach that is Guided by the math
situation and Argent takes no time at
all to respond to this well not the most
popular move in the position and
immediately plays on the other side of
the board now this is a very thematic
idea to take out your other Bishop you
want to fiance tattoo it on this long
diagonal it's where you want your Bishop
it is ideally placed Arjun stopping down
before he decides to Castle what Tanya
what a move he's has he Mouse lips
he's just played Kings F1 forgetting
that and castling is legal in chess but
I think his idea is to keep the Rook on
the h-file to attack this is just
revolutionary stuff Robert yeah it
almost looks like a mistake right can I
please put my H Pawn back and he says
well now that I've gone to H4 let's keep
it chugging along he goes to H5 and he's
just telling origin you are not castling
and if you do I am going to attack your
king so the question for Arjun and it's
actually quite a big one is do you stop
that pawn in its track it's gone far
enough he just answered my question as
soon as I uh released it he plays H6 and
you are going no further and he has a
rook lift so it's clear white is playing
for a win Tanya as you said it's because
the match situation
but going for it all costs often
backfires you need a solid setup a
strategy and I feel like he's just
playing for a win a little bit of
subjective Chess at the moment this King
F1 that was a shocker and one would want
to believe it's a mouse slip but once
you've made that H Bond move all the way
forward it could just be part of the
opening plan here for white you want to
now continue attacking on the king side
The Rook will eventually also land on G3
on the Open Fire Arjun meanwhile we try
to delay his castling as much as
possible because once you do that then
white gets a clear path and I think it's
going to be interesting to find out if
King to F1 the last move was that a
mouse slip or was it not cookies it's
also hard to tell with this camera I
mean
you have no idea what's going on yeah
definitely uh calling that some
revolutionary stuff earlier today Robert
you called the Arjun agent of chaos was
it and we do have a question for you um
uh in our twitch chat from dayuti asking
you what is the difference between the
playing styles of your cash and Arjun
it's funny because I'm reading the
question on screen it looks like the
origin has that's a compliment to me
like if I could be in the same sentence
as Arjun thank you very much
um what are their playing Styles I have
always felt that origin is quite a
restrained player as is I mean I do
think that there's quite a lot of
similarity between the two but I do feel
like Arjun he is shown in his most
successful tournaments that he will
punch you like he is ready to fight at
any moment I do feel like gukesh the
style we're seeing in this match is an
arjun's favorite I just think he is the
more aggressive player of the two so
typically likes a bit more of a calmer
start to the games whereas arjun's
always ready to fight
actually I should mention of single cash
play H4 at the kind of most surprising
times before I know that he said in
interviews he didn't work with a
computer at all until he was about 15 so
about a year and a half ago and then
when he started working with an engine
he started realizing pushing the H Pawn
in all of these Queen spawn openings it
isn't it is a concept and and uh I
remember in Greg gozins he was starting
to play H4 in every position in Vienna
games he was starting to push uh H4 and
uh he's doing it here doesn't feel
correct computer won't really approve
but uh it's certainly going to keep
arching on his toes and sometimes
especially in these really tense
pressure-filled situations all you need
to do is ask your opponent a new
question that they'd never faced before
and uh I must admit once I played a very
similar idea against Wesley so and after
the game Wesley was like what's up with
you you know King F1 is not good right I
was like yeah okay I didn't get an
attack and I lost I got mated but but uh
yeah if he if he pulls it off here go
catch them fairly and that's the worst
type type of kind of things to receive
words receives because it wasn't a nice
guy so if he's like asking you you know
you've done something wrong it's kind of
when I'm not angry I'm disappointed
exactly but then again if your cash goes
on and wins this game if he gets a big
attack against the black king we'll say
this was just genius from the get-go and
uh yeah you wouldn't have seen these
ideas these types of ideas with H4 King
F1 15 20 years ago but uh this is modern
Jazz yeah modern chess and especially
with the alpha zero coming in upon
advances the Harry the H bond is the new
star of the Chess World but I have to
say with this bishop move it is a
natural looking developing move you do
defend your Pawn on D4 but it also
invites the Black Knight to jump in and
attack that Bishop with the tempo not
just that what this move does is it
indicates the F6 Square for the black
Bishop to land on uh remember that
isolated Queen spawn that we were
talking about it does have the potential
to come under Fire once the bishop finds
it way to F6 so this looks like it could
be a difficult middle game for Archer
for gokish archon as a player loves the
initiative we always see him go for more
aggressive more attacking positions
whenever he has the option to create the
chaos he will take it with both hands
meanwhile gokish he's a more solid
player so I feel these kind of positions
like the ones where we have where we've
got no castling Kings marching up the
board pawns all over the place they
perhaps suit Arjun a little more than
gokish yeah you're taking sides Tanya
I'm impressed slowly but surely oh my
God Armageddon
and uh yeah just a solid queen move
there very sensible stuff getting ready
to bring the final piece to the party
that white Rook on A1 is going to slide
towards the center soon and with
isolated Queen's pawns uh in the
position watch out for a pawn break in
the center if white can ever
successfully throw his Central Pawn
forward play D5 open up lines especially
while the black king is in the center
then things will start to turn in his
favor
um I like this last move by gokash and I
have to say yesterday I was getting
Ralph my matter of a lot of credit in
his game against good cash because he
was just playing for a win he needed to
muddy the waters and in this one that's
exactly what gukesh has achieved so uh
from the perspective of needing a win
this is not just a solid position
nothing is symmetrical here chances for
both sides I think he's doing the right
thing even though kf1 was surprising now
they look at the position I'm surprised
by how much I like it for white because
at some moment there will be that Rook
on H3 it lifted up the board it could
slide one square over to attack the
Knight and the pawn behind it the D4
Pawn is pretty well defended for at
least for the time being and as you were
mentioning David if you're not looking
out for it that move d4 to D5 when you
have an isolated Pawn you always think
about pushing it forward and with that
black king in the center you have to
look out for the E file as well so I'm
nervous for the black king even though
objectively it looks fine or the eval
bar saying black is doing pretty well I
just see some problems for origin to
solve and it's not easy in a rapid time
control
wow and he's just castled into the eye
of the storm this is brave stuff again
from Arjun we saw him be adventurous
with this King in the last game but uh
wow he's really kind of waving the red
flag he's saying come at me and uh good
cash now surely he's going to switch his
Rook across and start playing towards
the enemy King I think what black is
relying on is that if you do make that
move you of course are not going to fall
back with your knight because then the H
Pawn is hanging but that F Bond and we
know Arjun he doesn't care about Pawn
advances in front of the king that F
Pawn will move forward not only
defending that key key Knight on G4 but
also blocking out White's Bishop on the
diagonal so I'm expecting the Knight on
G4 to stay there for a while yeah it's
actually surprisingly hard to get rid of
this piece it acts as a blocker just uh
controlling all of White's potential
activity so with this in mind maybe this
is not such an effective maneuver bring
the white Rook across right now how else
could uh White try to get this
attack go and Kickstart it and give it
some momentum I guess there's a standard
you slide your Rook over to D1 behind
you I said upon bring your Bishop back
to B1 at some point then line your
bishop and queen up on the light Square
diagonal try to threaten that Checkmate
black can always block that diagonal
with that pawn push F7 to F5 but that
creates other weaknesses namely the E6
Pawn so then that Bishop 1b1 can slide
to a new diagonal over to A2 and this is
maximum pressure on the black position
so we can see how black parries off one
thread at a time but then there are
maybe some underlying weaknesses that
will be difficult to defend yeah I like
it just uh slow and steady just bring
another piece into the game and you will
get attacking chances later I don't
think there's a need to start
calculating too much now once you see
that maybe Shifting The Rook across
Isn't So effective then you just okay
take your time out bring another piece
in save some time on the clock for later
good cache does have a minute or so
advantage on the clock and still very
promising position if you look at all
the pieces as well after this Rook move
all of them are so centralized for
whites these are kind of textbook
centralization pieces for white if
you're teaching a beginner how to place
their pieces in the opening you say look
at this Knight's in the center Bishops
next to them pointing at both sides of
the board yes the white king looks a bit
odd but it's almost as if it's castled
now and the white Rook isn't necessarily
worse placed here than it would be in
the center of the board so I'm still
looking very good I love this plan
Robert ice the more I look at it with
just dropping the bishop back keeping
the options open also hinting at uh
pushing with D5 it definitely gives
Arjun a lot to think about
uh if he goes for it
the reason that dukesh is taking his
time and I see he's finally made a
decision and made the move Bishop to F4
instead one of the plans that black has
that white needs to watch out for is
play on the other side of the board as
white has placed everything on the king
side eyeing that King the B4 break is a
resource that black always has to try
and get that counter play because if
there are trades the Knight will move
forward the bishop on B7 suddenly opens
up eyeing that Knight on F3 and the
reason that white has put that Bishop on
F4 is that he's taken a key square away
in Black's Camp Queen on C7 would be an
extremely strongly base placed Queen
because Imagine That Knight jumping onto
H2 uh David and maybe we can just Mark
the squares here once the bishop trades
off the Knight on F3 there are all these
forking ideas that become a reality so
Bishop F4 is actually a very strong
preemptive move taking away a key Square
from black screen
just to show that variation Knight H2 uh
that's uh some very effective winning
strategy for black I've got to say but
uh maybe there is a threat in the
position is this something to be careful
of I'm not sure we can go for it now if
black does initiate that idea that you
mentioned Tanya with B4 because suddenly
it looks like white is delivering mate
but the Black Knight can leap back act
as the hero and uh also you attack the
queen just in time uh I guess we have
prevented also uh this F5 break so now
we are threatening perhaps to shift the
Rook across if black does take a time
out now blacks Pawn push is not uh not
possible simply because this E6 Pawn
will drop off lots of variations we're
showing here but all very relevant to uh
the player's plans and I just want to
add that the bishop was protecting the
pawn on D4 but that's not necessary
because of tactics you see that if the
Black Knight Scoops off the pawn on D4
the Knight takes back and once the queen
swoops into the D4 square that Knight on
G4 is loose the queen will take it and
that Rook on H3 is doing very important
work protecting that light Square Bishop
all of White's pieces are offended black
would lose a piece and thus lose the
game so that pawn on D4 is defended
tactically and that's a huge moment for
agukesh to bring his Bishop out into the
open and I feel like with Arjun spending
this time here it's going to be
increasingly difficult because there
will be an attack you're not gonna lose
a piece in the moment but with Rook G3 a
new threat with of course Rook from A1
sliding into the action at any moment
Queen to E4 uh Pawn to D5 at any turn
you have to watch out for so many
different things that it's just not a
simple position and now that you're down
to six minutes that's where it starts
getting scary yeah wow I'm just gonna
say that H4 King F1 idea just a mock of
Genius a stamp of a really top quality
player they look like beginner moves but
he's making them look like part of a
master plan so not a must slip anymore
definitely not mouth slip definitely not
a mouse slip David I love this idea that
you're pointing out that now after this
last move white has opened up the queen
is eyeing that E6 spawns so Rook G3 is a
massive threat on the board and if
you're on the back foot in such a
position you're on the defense your king
is under Fire Rook G3 is a massive
threat I think black has to look for
ways of trying to trade off pieces here
to try and reduce the pressure somehow
and it looks like the only way to defend
such a position imagine even if Rook to
G3 wasn't coming in but you managed to
line up a battery on this diagonal or on
the b187 diagonal with the bishop and
the queen a meeting threat on H7 it can
get super dangerous and black has to
find a way to try and trade off as many
pieces as he can as quickly as he can
yeah which pieces would you be trying to
trade off here Queens Bishops
[Laughter]
but not pawns you want to keep all the
pawns because you got that isolated
queen I am super happy to keep all the
pawns on the board well that's really an
instructive point because uh it may seem
like we're joking around but that's what
black wants to leave white saddle with
an isolated Pawn in the end game that's
not what you want Jose Raul capablanca
but look at this position and say let me
get to that end game because then white
has this Pawn that's not easy to defend
if you use your major pieces to keep it
covered so Bishop D6 is step in the
right direction for black taking Tanya's
advice let's swap pieces uh get rid of
some of the attackers and the Knight on
G4 at any moment it can slide back to
the F6 Square so that's something that
you're gonna have to watch out for that
night Retreat it not only helps save the
black king but also starts putting
pressure on this H5 Pawn covering the D5
Square so I think that right now Arjun
is everything under control but I'm
keeping one of my four eyes on his clock
yeah he's down quite a lot now uh on
time and uh Tanya does that get your
stamp of approval Bishop D6 trying to
trade off these dot Square Bishops I was
I was thinking that I want to trade
Bishops I want to trade my pieces but I
couldn't find a way and the reason that
I wasn't sure about this move is because
of your idea of sliding in with the Rook
to G3 regardless yes the bishop on F4 is
hanging but so is the Knight and who
does this trade favor it's not so clear
in my mind Robert that after the Rook
attacks tonight
do you do you pick up the bishop and
give up the night and then lose a temple
on the way
it's getting really complicated it's
super complicated you have to calculate
everything now because yes you might
have to lose time retreating the bishop
I'm not sure exactly where you go but if
you step back with the bishop suddenly
there could be a threat we've mentioned
this checkmating pattern several times
now but you're creeping in along this
diagonal black can only block it at the
cost of material if you block it with
your Pawn then this Pawn drops this
still looks like an ongoing attack
against the black king and uh suddenly
tactics everywhere so this definitely
looks like the acid test of Black's last
move to slide the white Rook across
maybe it forces the Black Knight to go
back oh but I was going to say you're
allowing all sorts of Tricks maybe it's
just about okay there's no time for
white to go and take this Pawn trying to
use this pin because luckily the bishop
can capture this pinning piece the white
Rook so it's hanging together by a
thread for black but if it's hanging
together it's good news for Arjun
arrogacy and just goes to show that what
looks like a very simple move your
Bishop's sliding one square on the
diagonal there's so much more than meets
there there are many tactics in this
position Bishop D6 it can't move it's
just trying to trade off one of the way
to attackers and black had less space
with some of the minor pieces let's get
our Queen out connect our Rooks and then
that isolated Pawn on D4 can become a
long-term problem so leaving that F7
Pawn the go forward F5 at a critical
moment if the black queen slides up
especially it feels like the base of
Black's Position will be stronger and
that allows black to fend off the
threats and avoid the secondary ones
yeah looks like a great move for Arjun
and it's also forced to go cash to burn
most of his time Advantage just trying
to figure out how to proceed how to keep
the momentum going it's must win for
gukesh if he's gonna stay in the
tournament the losers in the losers
coach finals will be knocked out of the
air things monsters and the situation is
the same for Serana right now playing
against Wesley so Wesley he won the
first game today and Serana he has to
win this game too to take it to an
Armageddon I see the bar is roughly in
the middle in that game is there any
drama happening
still early days Serana has got a very
playable position but maybe not the type
of Advantage he would want or that he's
used to with the white pieces uh Wesley
so hard to beat on demand we've said it
before
strong struggle well see the loss of
zero games yesterday he won two title
Tuesdays and he played five games with
the car in Nakamura in Rapid and he drew
all five of those I mean the guy seems
Unstoppable he isn't a loser's bracket
because the draw he had the white pieces
it meant that a car was able to punch
his ticket to the winners final uh but I
mean Wesley so is playing unbelievable
chess right now yeah it's so unfair
actually
name him in the losers bracket with the
way he's playing yeah I like that
pankaya so unfair
so solid he is yeah and uh meanwhile wow
what a move the White Knight Landing in
the center of the board it can be
captured three different ways Arjun
reacts instantly he says no I'll let
your knight sit there and he pushes the
F Pawn
and the first question yeah is yes you
push the F Pawn but you leave behind
your E Pawn which is now a weakness
white can simply snap up the Knight on
G4 and hope to pick up the E6 Pawn with
a check you pick it up with check and I
guess black slides into the corner we
have won a pawn with white but suddenly
a few problems facing uh facing cash
here your knight is attacked this Pawn
is finally gonna drop the isolated Pawn
we've been talking about for a while
everything's happening with Tempo and
suddenly White's position is a bit loose
to me I think I would need 5-10 minutes
just to kind of try and figure out
what's going on just to kind of find my
bearings in this position but the
players of course don't have that luxury
you could also make an argument for
taking this Knight and then going in
with your White Queen you can make an
argument for I don't know throwing this
Pawn forward at some point or other
jumping in with the white knight so many
options but kukesh he's now down on time
and Arjun playing that last move this
last committal move instantly I think
that's a huge cycle logical blow
yeah F5 it's almost as if he's
calculated all these uh tactical
variations what is very very impressive
is how fast he played it despite the
whole board hanging what it does is one
thing's for sure pieces are getting
traded off and we've been talking about
this over and over again that the more
the pieces get traded off that D4 Pawn
will be a huge weakness and it looks
like that last move by gokish jumping in
with the knight at the center of the
board so tempting might have been
actually a huge mistake yeah evaluation
bar hates it we're not sure because it's
so complicated but we've got to trust
the computer in a position like this one
and I have to come origin the astronomer
because I feel like he takes a while in
the opening he's setting up his
telescope but when there are clouds and
complications there he sees through them
so this is unbelievable stuff from Arjun
Air Guys he's playing F5 when the E6
Pawn is hanging with check I mean this
is just really unreal just like Knight
takes C6 Knight takes G4 E6 follows the
check he has seen it all he is a
tactical Wizard and he is informed today
wow and she must have been loving his
position it did look very promising just
one or two moves ago suddenly it's pure
calculation is either going to be very
good this position for white or it's
going to be very bad nothing in between
and uh suddenly two minutes down on the
clock you have to be greedy you have to
go and grab pawns with the White Queen
in order to justify everything you've
just done but uh the fact that arjun's
blitzing playing every move instantly
he's going to be panicking doubt is
creeping in now Tanya are you fearing
for concussion this one I am he's
putting a lot a lot fresher arson's
putting a lot of Russia not just on the
position on the clock playing the
psychological game here as well making
moves fast and so far accurately the
problem it comes down in this position
is that yes you pick up the pawn with a
check but once the king sidesteps the
whole board for gukesh hangs you need to
make a decision with that Bishop on F4
your queen on E6 will be targeted with
the Rook on C6 so I think kokesh is
going to be super wary of actually going
into this line once after the king side
steps let's say you pick up the bishop
on D6 the black rook recaptures and
again White's position collapses the
queen is hanging the pawn is hanging
notice that Bishop on B7 eyeing that
pawn on G2 and it's actually White's
King that is under so much pressure no
material to call for and wow we have
this line but instead of trading the
bishop
kukesh went for the pawn push attacking
the rook and Arjun once again just
blitzes out the move just simply
sidesteps with the Rook keeping all the
threats on the board what a beast yeah
to be sir and uh they're playing very
very high quality chess we've got to say
uh no big swings in the evaluation bar
despite uh the fact it's so complicated
right now it'll be so easy to blunder I
like what kokesh has done he's pushed
this Pawn forward it's on a less
vulnerable Square now defended by whites
Knight it also blunts in this bishop but
the problem remains there's this awkward
tension between the black rook and the
White Queen and if you have to take a
time out to retreat start running away
black will at least restore the material
balance and uh Robert do you see any
chance here especially down to one
minute now for go cash I'm wondering if
we're gonna see a queen sacrifice just a
quick line here of the dark Shore Bishop
slides back one score to E3 hitting the
Rook on B6 the bishop goes up to C5
saying your Queen's under attack you
have to move that thing there are no
safe squares and white says okay I'll
take your Bishop you'll take my queen
I'll also get your Rook that's oh we
might see this bishop E3 hasn't played
that's Alaska compensation of a rook a
minor piece and a pawn for a queen that
is a lot of material with the past Pawn
both kings are kind of exposed this is
the type of position you need if you're
gookest you may be worse you may end up
losing the game but you have serious
winning chances so I think that gukesh
the biggest problem right now is his
clock if the times were reversed he
would have huge chances but Arjun has
been finding these tactics quickly I do
like gukesh's last move though yeah
incredible to make this decision to
actually give up the White Queen because
he's committed to it now but he made
this decision with one minute on his
clock and this black Rook is actually
trapped the only way to avoid that
variation would actually be to trade off
this bishop but suddenly after the White
Queen steps back takes this Knight
you're just a pawn down and I don't
think Arjun can really go for this the
black king are also weak on the light
squares long term so I think both sides
are pretty much committed to that
variation Robert starting with this
bishop move sliding forward and just to
show it one more time Bishop takes
Bishop giving up the White Queen but uh
yeah Rook bishop and pawn if we didn't
see the evaluation bar we would think
that white is may be doing very well
here but uh it still looks like dynamic
balance in this position in this crazy
wild position that's actually a stunning
line uh that Robert that you're pointing
out and Arjun slowing down because it's
also not easy to evaluate you have the
safe option of picking up the bishop
right now and not sacrificing the queen
but then you just end up in a slightly
worse position that Bishop on B7 as we
can see will remain Dead with that white
Pawn on D5 which is still alive and uh
it's going to completely favor gokish if
Arjun goes for this bishop trade but how
do you evaluate that position winning
that Queen but allowing a white Pawn on
E6 looks super dangerous just the fact
that Archer needed a draw in this game
and he went into these complications
just goes on to show how Brave these two
players are yeah if we reached this
position that we're looking at at the uh
on the analysis board right now then is
anyone's game anyone's game I would
probably prefer to have white I see the
evaluation bar off the sides and the
black is still better I would prefer to
have white because all of a sudden you
have more forces you're aiming at some
of uh the black weaknesses like the F5
Pawn The Rook is under attack uh that E6
Pawn it's not even clear that black will
be able to stop it so I'm just looking
at this position and I don't care what
the evaluation Bar says the players they
don't know it and I just think the
trajectory of the game has been an
arjun's favor all of a sudden gooka
strikes back and he's putting a
difficult decision in arjun's court and
I think he recognizes the importance of
this moment the magnitude and he may
take the bishop but he's not going to be
happy about it just saying you know what
I don't want your queen I'll be down to
pawn I can try to defend this I don't
like that he's spending so much time
here I feel like he's uncomfortable I
think he's going to go for this line
with Bishop C5
yeah he has to he's uh now down on the
clock and we mentioned he's an agent of
chaos uh Eric I see I think he has to
embrace that chaos now you can't just
maintain this position hope that it
Fizzles out towards a draw because this
one is just too wild and I would rather
go into that where it's a big mess take
my chances there then suffer a pawn down
and now no real time Advantage only a
few seconds and uh still a few seconds
increment for gokesh to rely upon so he
needs to go for it wow any of those
options he Retreats his Knight to the
center of the board he's giving up
material here he's a pawn down he's
giving up an exchange the black Rook the
white Bishop can snack on that one now
Feast on it he's trying to argue I guess
that the White Queen is trapped anyway
and the evaluation bar doesn't react
which it's just genius stuff I mean 95
was not even a move on our radar just
giving up that Rook on B6 which by the
way let's point that has been
voluntarily self-trapped he moved that
Rook all the way up to C6 and put it on
B6 and says come and take it and it all
relies on peace activity Knight E5 what
is this move Bishop takes Rook it takes
Bishop it's brilliant that is an
unbelievable find the White Queen is
entombed on E6 it looks like a great
square but either the black Bishop is
going to head back to its home and
attack the queen or The Rook will slide
in the Queen's path and attack it so
what a find yeah what a fight and now go
cash down to his last few seconds okay
he takes that black Rook he shifts his
own Rook out of the corner into the
center but the White Queen is gone she's
still going to have to sacrifice her own
life once that black light Square Bishop
slides back home as uh Robert mentions
there and uh I'm trying to do a quick
count here to figure out the material
balance here we go the queen is trapped
no way to save her you just have to take
this black knight in the center of the
boat now yeah it's gonna be Knight pawn
and Rook for the queen so the same
material imbalance but the pawn is on D5
and blockaded by Bishop rather than all
the way up where the Rook is on E6
that's a humongous difference uh
opposite color Bishops it usually favors
the side with the safer King both Kings
looking a bit vulnerable or the white
King has more forces around it but
eventually perhaps the black pieces will
line up so it's be for a good move by
origin opening up a second wing and I
like the way he's playing yeah I like
the way both players are playing uh this
is not just super high quality chess but
also both sides just going at each other
punch after punch after punch and kokesh
finally has to take a timeout play a
consolidating move he's going for this
black F Pawn it's very weak there but
he's also Shoring up the white king the
white king at some point will be given a
nice safe home white will push the G
Pawn forward at some point and slide it
to a light square but first
okay the black queen coming in how do we
stop her from delivering some nasty
checks the White Knight also Under Fire
but the nasty checks do they really
matter because a draw is not enough for
gokish right and after the bishop falls
back on E2 Bishop B4 you've got this
queen C1 big threat on the board you
can't really move your knight to any
other Square except fall back and now
Queenie one is a mate in one D5 Pawn is
hanging Ah that's uh the more important
well what's more important than the
maiden one but I think that's the key
detail here uh the white king you needed
to take your time out to give it a safe
square but now the pride and joy of your
position that Central Pawn has
disappeared and with it maybe White's
winning chances Suddenly It's hard to
imagine unless there's some uh sudden uh
kind of surprise attack for white so if
you maybe imagine the White Knight
getting to G6 unless that happens
Black's not going to be in trouble at
all in this game and look at what
arjun's doing he's completely dominating
that night that night is not getting out
of there anytime soon uh the black king
looking safe tucked away the white king
is a bit more open and I feel like white
just doesn't have the coordination of
the pieces you have three pieces uh so
two pieces for the queen a rook and a
knight but they're not working together
very well and I feel like black is
stabilized only needing a draw yeah and
uh another nasty Queen slide that the
black queen controls the diagonal that
the White Knight wants to use and wow
what a move developing his Knights
giving it up but if the Knight is
captured there will be a nasty skewer is
that a skewer is that a pin and uh okay
not allowing that white Rook back into
the game not taking the bait but has he
allowed gukesh back in this Pawn drops
now and uh we might well just see an end
game after Eric Garcia gives back the
queen nope he's given a check and
suddenly he's won a rook for the bishop
it's uh Knight bishop and Port now for a
queen this is a big material advantage
for black should be a fortress for white
potentially but a draw minimum we have a
result Wesley so has won also game two
in his match against Alexa Serrano that
means Serana oh he's knocked out Robert
what are your favorites well he'll be
okay he takes ten thousand dollars home
with him so I think he'll you know be
happy about that but it was a great
match for Wesley so I was keeping an eye
in the background and these players down
to their final seconds I mean he
couldn't get more exciting here in the
air things Masters and what do you think
does white have some chances here with
the material imbalance it's hard to
imagine I mean a queen for two pieces is
just really difficult but of course
gukesh is going to play this out till
the end and try and create something he
will Target that 8-6 pawn The Rook
jumping on to D6 uh trying to create a
threat I think he might I think he might
have chances here wow
it's easier to play with more pieces and
the queen is more valuable but Rook D6
being a huge threat and oh it looks like
he backtracked because if you went Rook
D6 the Knight was hanging over there so
a great move to keep chances alive he
wants to slide his Rook over I really do
think white has chances in this position
yeah it's definitely not over yet if the
Rooks disappear black is safe it should
be a draw but uh how long are you gonna
avoid it yeah good crash he has to dodge
that he did not slide across and now the
Knight wants to jump onto F5 and hit
that queen and the pawn The Rook moves
forward to defend the 8-6 pawn and watch
out for a fork now yeah so much
happening Arjun doing the great thing of
keeping his piece on the dark squares
away from the enemy Bishop so you see
the rook and the queen all of the last
piece on dark scores he's trying to
offer the trailer Rooks but that is what
guest point he's threading a rook all
the way up in the corner to pin the
queens of the king so Arden says no none
of that for you well and still a few
seconds each here white needs to get the
root to a more active Squad needs to get
the Knight back involved but uh at the
moment no way through black has set up a
defensive barrier it is amazing how
gakesh is fighting down a queen and he's
creating all these these incredible
threats both players on seconds at first
I thought white has no chances Robert
but it looks like location is showing
some amazing will and now the king joins
the attack as well again two games in a
row the king landed on G3 and uh despite
having no Queen I think we would all
take white here right
at least in the Blitz game I
love a queen give me a queen any day
I'll take black oh you are a queen
Thunder
meanwhile black is trying to get pieces
off the board still no way through now
Black's got pieces on dark squares white
pieces were all on light squares for
that moment and a nasty check kicking
away the white King The Black Queen Is
Gonna Come in behind at some point maybe
start delivering some checks maybe
that's the way to salvation but wow
there's a pin pin here Robert wait
tonight unable to move and I'm surprised
the black brought a pawn forward look
the king is out Knight G6 check is the
fourth I mean that King is helping in
the attack this is scary for black
where's that King going if it steps up
there's a the king might go up for white
as well you'd be really careful now well
who's meeting who look who's coming on
there's actually a mate and one on the
board is Rook D7 just to check man it
will be Checkmate that's a Checkmate
Queen will come to G3 giving a check but
no he offers a rook trade
this is getting really intense and white
needs to watch out for that check on G
E3 with that Queen easy to miss from the
other side of the board but it looks
like Arjun might have just survived all
the threats that gokish was creating
there we go the queen check does land as
he predicted Tanya white needs to take
out a time uh time to block that now
yeah he does have to place his pieces on
Awkward squares all of the pieces were
on the G file for a second but a pawn
has disappeared with it take the Rook
finish the game he does it that is
professional he needs just to draw he
gets out of any threats and what a game
by gokish what a fight by gokish wow and
uh Arjun he's going to secure the draw
next move Rook takes bishop and a knight
alone is not enough to deliver
is knocked out of the tournament Arjun
Eric icy makes it through to the losers
quarterfinals what a match between these
two I think Robert who's living on the
increment but that three second
increment that's added after every move
that came into play origin era garci he
used it to his benefit he is the junior
speeches Champion he beat Neil sarin in
that format so he's used to these quick
time patrols and he is a superstar how
fast is your Indian hard beating right
now Tanya I can't believe what we just
witnessed I mean that was just at a
whole whole different level also gokish
so impressive having no time on the
clock down a queen for Just Two Pieces
managed to create a mating attack with
his own King moving forward that was
just incredible just start to finish
both these players have so much to be
proud of today wow what okay even here
is today's learning points
[Music]
how to play for win at all costs good
cash in the opening surprised his
opponents Eric icy with some really
creative and some really clever play in
this position he shocked us all here all
the commentators by playing H4 what is
this doing you might ask he's simply
going to push his Pawn forward and make
it less attractive for the black king to
Castle on the king side his next move
another shock King to F1 putting the
King on a slightly odd square but uh
committing to lifting his Rook up the
board where as we saw in the game it did
prove to be a very strong piece it was a
crazy game of course many many twists
and turns later sacrificed his Queen but
uh Eric icy at the right moment was able
to lock things down by giving his own
Queen back I definitely recommend
playing through all of this game it's
well worth the study
[Music]
wow wow wow both matches on the losers
record today have finished two players
are knocked out kukash and Serana and
two players have made it through are you
guys see and Wesley so congratulations
Wesley
yeah thank you very much thank you yeah
finally I still have yeah I still have
one life left so
one thing I like about this format I
played this format before in the
American Cup last year
but it's nice because if you lose one
you you have to lose another but does it
feel a little bit unfair to be playing
on the losers bracket when you actually
haven't lost any games
yeah that's a good point yeah
unfortunately
uh Hikaru won the bid Yesterday by 16
seconds I think the match was very close
but unfortunately the last game
yesterday I didn't really get any
chances and then I look at the games
afterwards and hiker played really well
so big congratulations to him and uh
uh you know you win some you lose some
but I'm excited to see his upcoming
match against uh by Mr D I wish it'd be
more than four games but uh but that's
nice nevertheless yeah and Wesley we've
heard rumors that you're playing a lot
of online chess uh these days uh
obviously playing here in the air things
monsters also playing title Tuesday
yesterday winning that one as well yeah
yeah I found my friends ask why
Grandmasters playing title Tuesday but
you know it's practice it's a super
strong event it's so so difficult to win
but I took advantage Yesterday by the
fact that all the top Grandmasters
weren't playing like Hikaru or Magnus or
Fabiano they weren't there so yesterday
it was a little bit weaker but uh yeah
to win two title Tuesdays in one day if
it's totally unreal I think I've only
won
uh before yesterday I've only won two
titles Tuesdays in history
so it's really difficult but I've been
trying to get some practice games in I
think if you if you're gonna spar with
somebody might as well do it in a real
tournament setting uh and uh
also during tournaments you don't want
to
you don't want to tie your brain too
much you don't want to stretch it too
much
so before doing tournaments I would like
prepare or work on problem solving or
analyze my games
but these days I just you know played
with instead to try and relax and uh
yeah and it's nice I think this year is
going to be very exciting of course with
the urging of chess.com in chess 24. I
used to play in the chest 24th I do
before but there are not too many good
players there so I yeah it's nice and
then after this tournament I have a
classical tournament in Dusseldorf
coming up where Ian
is playing as well so that's going to be
a good practice as I said this year I'm
going to start to improve my classical
rating but it's nice to
to be able to participate in this online
event and I'm very grateful to be to be
part of the everything's Masters this
year yeah we're so excited to have you
here as well Wesley yeah and we'll see a
quick question you said you win some you
lose some yesterday you lost zero games
so what did you eat what were you doing
what was going on with you
yeah actually now that you
know
well I I I've been working a lot on my
chest uh
uh also I think the match format is
suitable for my style
and uh
yeah I mean I love I love playing chess
I spent you know hours per day doing it
but I think yesterday I was just playing
really well uh it's unfortunate I lost
to Hikaru but we'll try again start
again today also yesterday I played your
friend Daniel narditski in the last
round the afternoon
yeah and you want it
yeah I won it I was uh better and then I
was completely lost and then he landed a
rock for a night so you should ask him
about it that's a very fun game it was
another Italian that usually play
you're on a roll Wesley congratulations
on winning the match uh today and best
of luck tomorrow as well when you're
gonna play on the losers semi-finals
yeah play again tomorrow and uh it's
going to be an exciting match also today
and yeah thank you again guys for all
your hard work it must be really
difficult also doing commentating for
many hours a day
thank you for the kind words Wesley
thank you so much see you again tomorrow
and we're also joined by the other
winner on the loser record today Arjun
Eric icy congratulations
hey thank you we just had to take a deep
breath after that match against that was
intense what was it like for you
yeah I think board games were quite
intense the first game I he walked into
my place I knew until a day Queen feat
and and I didn't know look here but I
was pretty sure it's not a good move I
was fairly happy with my poetry but
Emmanuel very well until this night of
at 95th and one critical movement was
instead of playing instead of playing
Knight F4 I thought he could go Queen B
flat threatening night night
very strong
but in the game I thought I got good
control and in the end I kind of Blended
Knight Tech V6
he could take three points and sacrifice
the net and I think he had a good
position there but after that game went
my way I was very confident
Arjun what a match this was we loved
watching every bit of it to us it seemed
like there was so much going on now you
want to zero but
is it accurate to say that it doesn't
truly reflect how chaotic the games were
oh no it's actually one and a half half
Leslie and
yeah I think both the games were very
complicated especially the second one
could have gone either way at first I I
was thrown off by his head for working
as an idea but a bit later I realized it
makes a lot of sense and I was feeling
it but when he played 95 I was very
happy because after I think I was
encountered dude he he did manage to
propose some practical problems you took
the match in two games uh I have to ask
you Arjun in that game one when you were
going up the board with your king what
was going on in your mind were you at
all terrified about your king position
in that one what was that all about
but
then I will if he can just go G6 so it's
too much I would have probably dropped
back but I thought he should still try
that rather than going back 96.95
yeah we were thinking about that one
here in the studio as well wondering uh
whether you'd be brave enough to advance
the king to G4 but uh Arjun I won't say
congrats first of all but uh also we
heard there's a collection of teddy
bears behind you can you tell us the
story behind uh those ones
for some of them I got from WWF when I
made some donations and some of them
were whether I played with when I was a
kid
how cool so you have support while
playing in the air things monsters we
know you have huge Support also in India
a lot of fans are you noticing that with
all the fans now cheering you on
oh yes I am aware of it and especially
it was an old Indian matchup so
it must have been exciting for the fans
to follow as well also I have played
good cash quite a few times before and
it's always it's always nice to play
yeah what a matches was and you're
through to uh day four in the air things
monsters we wish you best of luck
tomorrow when you face Wesley so
tomorrow
thank you thank you for joining us Arjun
that was it for today's losers bracket
you guys we are now gonna get ready for
the winners bracket with the big winner
is final between the two big online
beasts Magnus Carlsen against Hikaru
Nakamura tomorrow in the loser is
semi-final Wesley so we'll face off
against Arjun Eric icy the winner of
that match will go through to the losers
final two phase the losers or the loser
of today's winners final the winner of
the winners final today will go straight
through to the Grand Final to be played
on Friday this is a big one Magnus
Carlsen against Hikaru Nakamura is
coming up very shortly what do you
expect from that one Robert fireworks as
always these two players since the
pandemic since online chess has exploded
they have given it their all all the way
back in 2020 through the past year when
I called Nakamura kind of took the edge
against Magnus Carlson of course the a
lifetime score heavily at Max's favor
but 2022 is a car nakamura's year really
it really was that we remember the fish
around the world championship last year
and also of course the speed chess champ
ship
do you think Magnus Carlsen is eager for
some revenge against Hikaru David
suddenly and here we see the scores in
the past 12 months
13 to eight
and a lot of these games came in the
speed test Championship that dramatic
final uh you know I was watching on the
edge of my seat in that when it came
down to the final few moves of the final
game but uh yeah it's hard to pick a
favorite I've got to say especially in
Rapid both of them extremely good both
of them just coasted to this point so
far and uh maybe Hikaru has a decent
shot at continuing his uh his good form
against Magnus oh definitely and we're
just finished with an extremely
entertaining match between gukesh and
Eric icy what kind of match can we
expect with these two with these two
playing Styles kind of I think they've
just set the tone this has been a great
warm-up what a match that was absolute
fireworks on the board Magnus has got a
score to settle as we've been talking
about what's happened in the previous
year and there was a time when Magnus
was dominant in their matchups uh he was
crushing Hikaru throughout and then
there's been this breakthrough that
Hikaru has had and it's there's been no
stopping him Magnus is looking for
Revenge today yeah you think so
absolutely all right it's getting close
the first game so in the winners final
it is best out of four rapid games if
they are tied then we will get another
one of those exciting armageddons and
this should be a tight one don't you
think David well paper is extremely
close it's extremely hard to uh separate
them they're both so good in the opening
they're both uh just end game Gods at
this point and in speed chess uh their
strengths really do shine through
remember this could be just part one of
the Rivalry in the air things Masters
because uh whoever loses today will get
another shot to qualify for the final
for a rematch so yeah I can't wait uh
let's get the popcorn out yes enjoy it
exactly and Robert we've seen them now
in two matches so far in the tournament
are they playing their best chess now
Magnus and Hikaru well I think Magnus
Carlsen should be happy that he lost a
game to Argentina guys because once you
get that sting and it shows you can
bounce back from it that's huge for your
confidence so I don't think Magnus has
been playing his best chess I think
Hikaru against Wesley does two very
solid players I think the best is yet to
come
yeah to come it's getting very close uh
the first game in their match Magnus
Carlsen will start out with the white
pieces what sort of opening should we
expect I'll go around the table what do
you think
cloud
s haven't seen that before between those
two we have um I'm gonna say the Italian
game
played out in that uh in that opening so
many times especially when Magnus is
white at least you can predict that
Hikaru for sure is going to set up in
that way and maybe Magnus will come
armed with a new idea what do you think
Tanya I think it really depends on what
happens in Game one we might even see a
lot of switch-ups as uh Magnus will go
forward if he starts with white pieces
might be an Italian might switch over to
the Cat Land depending on how things go
Hikaru also so hard to predict these two
players are masters of every opening uh
I think it's all going to come down to
what happens on the time scrambles Kaya
I'm predicting an Armageddon and I'd
love to see that happen oh I agree but
David sorry Robert we know Magnus he's
all about those psychological the
psychological warfare as well in chess
do you think he's gonna open with
something
dubious in this first game against
Hikaru I think he's no longer in
hikara's head so all those psychological
tricks may work against everybody else
Nakamura showed in 2022 and he can take
down Magnus Carlson whether it's in
Fisher random who has a speed Chess
Championship whether it's in any type of
event so I feel like for a hit Karu he's
no longer afraid that vanity has been
ripped off and so I think the magnets
just play his optimal chess yeah I do I
do have some inside information though
they should have been logged on now both
players but Magnus Carlson uh is uh I'm
isn't logged on yet
do you think that is on purpose David it
could be far away it is Magnus so we
know he's usually late I think we've
just been thrown off because he's been
on time for the last couple of days but
uh yeah maybe a hint of Mind Games there
but uh there's someone I just want to
add to that point earlier that there's
so much respect between these two now
and uh I just think they're gonna go all
out they have to play their best
openings that's the only way they're
going to win this match but is that a
problem in online chess Robert that
clocks don't start uh in over the board
chess you're often uh penalized if
you're if you're not by the board when
the game is supposed to start in online
chess uh the clock hasn't started until
you're there is that a problem uh I
don't know if it's a problem but the
chess.com can always take some time off
their clocks if they're late but uh
maybe it's also an issue that you don't
have a set starting time because these
last two matches could have gone to
Armageddon which means there's some
buffer uh some time to work it out but
we see a car Nakamura on screen I'm not
sure if he's talking to chat uh telling
them about all the takes takes taken
he's gonna do but either way hakari he
looks ready for this match he doesn't
look too happy that Magnus isn't ready
yet I think we saw hikaruda shaking his
head he's not happy with what's going on
right now yeah you think so like he's a
little bit upset with Magnus keeping him
waiting understandably it's a big match
and we can see him with those hand
gestures not sure what's going on what's
stopping Magnus from logging on but
definitely Magnus needs to get there on
time Kaya you've got to do that when
there is a big game waiting to happen
I'm gonna send him a text I'm gonna tell
Magnus uh where are you wait so you're
just bragging that you have his personal
number okay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is now logging on to get ready we know
uh minus 12 is situated in Toronto he is
visiting his uh chess Bros his friends
uh Eric Hansen and Avon Hamilton uh
you think what do you think those days
are like with the miners visiting is it
all about the chances Paris I think I
have the bigger question is what are the
nights like exactly exactly what do you
guys think
um I've seen some Instagram stories of
public information but they have been
out and about in Toronto a little bit
but uh yeah who knows maybe just bullet
marathons all nights and uh tea parties
here and there I think we can confirm
that yeah all right well we are waiting
for Magnus Carlsen to arrive for the
huge match today this is the winners
final in the air things monster is best
out of four rapid games if they are tied
Magnus cross 90 card Nakamura it will be
decided in Armageddon they both played
Armageddon yesterday to win their
matches
look at Hikaru waiting for Magnus he
definitely looks a little bit annoyed
Hikaru Nakamura oh how do we see a smile
well I think Magnus is logging in and
Hikaru and he's getting ready to play it
is kind of unnerving when you're just
sitting at a physical border online just
waiting for your opponent to get set but
I don't think Hikaru is too amused yeah
yeah it's also his background there's
such a different setup from where we
normally see Hikaru play from uh there's
a lot going on there yeah he is Hikaru
usually plays from an office right like
a streaming office not really his home
yeah I think he it mixes and matches
depending on his mood but we know he's
been going through a lot we spoke to him
yesterday after his match and so of
course we wish him the best and I think
for Magnus Carlson he wishes him the
worst on the chessboard but of course
it's been a big occasion uh for a hikar
a lot going on in his life yeah is this
a big moment for those two players as
well David Magnus and hikar when they
face yourself yeah there's so much so
much pride attached and they know that
kind of uh yeah whoever wins this match
by the public will be viewed as the best
rapid player in the world and uh yeah I
think neither side wants to relinquish
uh that's that quite kind of uh mental
battle right now so
um yeah especially for Hikaru uh having
had this last year I think he can relax
a bit more he doesn't uh allow Magnus to
live in his mind as he was saying
Robertson
um it did feel like a big breakthrough
but uh yeah in terms of the fans there's
definitely a big split and uh I think
neither player wants to let them down
yeah waiting four miners to arrive for
this big game we do have some questions
coming in from you guys and keep them
coming either in the twitch chat or on
Twitter using hashtag chess Champs uh
skunk Spiegel has asked on Twitter what
are the commentators favorite openings
leading up to the opening
well I like to start with the Queen's
Pawn uh-huh with the white pieces so I
enjoy that strategic positional fight
that arises from it and with the the
black pieces it really just depends on
what my opponent plays but the king
spawn it is if I get the opportunity
with the black pieces okay but on the
board in this tournament I would love to
see a bomb Club
tired and not planned but when I do play
I love playing the hippo and it's one of
those do as I say not as I do openings
where instead of taking control of the
center you just put all your pieces on
the second Rank and your Pawns in the
third and then you you know go from
there am I not mistaken isn't that your
favorite one hello David I'm on record
saying it's one of my favorites that's
why we get along so well I know I'm just
like an English version of you but uh
yeah also shout out to Ginger Jam who's
done a chessboard course on the
hippopotamus defense yeah
um well if our country's the hippo I'll
be boring I'll say the C3 Sicilians the
elephants are silly me too
yeah what's going on here
do we know about how about Magnus and
Hikaru do they have favorite openings
good question
I think Magnus played the hippo a few
times uh during the Champion's chest
though where he just
puts all his pawns on the third Rank and
then develops really slowly and he often
does that when he's just looking for a
game you know it's not long theoretical
lines and you just kind of take it super
slow it develops solely I've seen him
employ that as well have you guys been
training together uh no comments anyway
right guys I think it's time he's left
us waiting too long why should I text
Magnus oh
see you guys in the twitch chat or on
Twitter have any suggestions yeah I
think a trivia question I mean he did
come to trivia uh last week so I feel
like you know what you're gonna have a
tough trivia question to answer you're
like where are you you teamed up with
him didn't you yeah we're on the same
team we uh you know did quite well it
was a fun time so I think you should hit
him with a tough trivia question okay
I'll just say hurry up
what's the time
well an update if you are just uh now
joining us we are waiting for Magnus
Carlsen to arrive the winners final
should have started a long time ago
actually uh first game between Magnus
Carls and anti car and Nakamura in the
big Winners final match and there he is
finally Magnus Carlsen ready in that
room in the chesborough house in Toronto
he's gonna start out with the white
pieces against his biggest online rival
he car in Nakamura it is best out of
four games to decide the match if they
are tied it will be decided and
Armageddon tie breaks who goes straight
through to the Grand Final in the air
things monsters this is a big match and
Magnus has the white piece as you can
see Hikaru getting ready as well what's
going through their head right now
for Hikaru frustration navigations he
wants to get the game going for Magnus
uh maybe just picking an opening I don't
think it's anything more than that right
now
we can see uh oh there we go it started
this is the winner is final and it's the
ready opening uh White bringing the
night out on the first move also one of
my favorites I should have called that
it looks so clever but uh the reti a
very flexible move only later depending
on what Hikaru does right now will
Magnus decide which Pawn to push and uh
Hikaru here usually either occupies the
center or place copycat here we go G5 so
how will Magnus react G3 very much in
the vein of the reti you could have
transposed to a queen's Pawn opening
there you could have chosen a bunch of
different lines but this is something
that both players have fast experience
in
and now will Magnus Castle is King
allowing black to occupy the center with
two pawns Black's next move for nope
okay instead Magnus allows a symmetrical
position on the board what do we think
of this
and I think Magnus is keeping it
flexible with the c Pawn he might decide
to move it forward two squares or one
square I might just keep it there for a
while and that's going to be an
important decision will will which will
determine the characteristic of the
middle game at some point I am expecting
him to actually go C4 and he does it and
wow Hikaru immediately snaps up the pawn
yeah still very well known stuff and
here
um usually black moves one of the two c
pawns there we go uh C5 and the whole
Center might just be obliterated all of
the central pawns getting traded off and
a symmetrical end game and I was looking
at this one recently there are some
ideas for why to keep the game going but
they will involve a little bit of risk
at least strategically often you might
be ended uh you might be stuck with an
isolated Pawn or two if you want to take
risks to win
this position very solid stuff from both
sides especially Hikaru here and we've
got a fan of Magnus on the screen here
we see that is such a cute photo
to our champion
yeah no that is always great to hear
from the fans here and also this
position as David was uh kind of
indicating that it's one where at first
glance not too much has happened black
took a pawn White's gonna get it back
but White's Knight gets a little bit
more active so this Knight that was
sitting at home jumped out up the board
and we'll capture that upon on C4 so I
feel like White's a little bit uh
quicker to the punch black is very solid
we'll have a symmetrical Pawn structure
and it seems that Magnus is the I would
still say the first person caught by
surprise but a car did think back on
move one you know to consider his reply
but now Magnus it's clear he was not
anticipating a card to play this line
yeah but throughout the world
championship in 2021 Magnus was free
kind of experimenting freestanding with
these uh G3 systems fee and Kettering
that white Bishop on G2 and that they
could all ever transpose to this type of
position so surely Magnus has studied
this surely he has an idea or two up his
sleeve it's surprising to me at least
that he's burnt almost two minutes of
his clock on this very well known very
theoretical position uh usually here
white does capture the pawn that has
just moved at least in the uh at the
higher levels I know Vladimir kramnik
has had success with that move but as
Robert says you can also recapture a
pawn with a white knight lots of choice
here
and in fact a more popular choice here
is to recapture the C4 Pawn with the
Knight bringing it to the center but yes
the second most popular move is to pick
up the other Pawn on C5 but that would
just mean that all Central pawns are
eventually going to be dissolved I
wonder if Magnus is looking at a third
option which is to keep the tension on
the board but for now just defend that
default Pawn by advancing that e-pawn
one step ahead but I have to tell you
there's just one game in the database
that I have in front of me so that's
definitely a very rare move yeah it
feels like these two are the main
options either taking this Pawn or as
you guys mentioned just capturing with
the Knight I think uh you can kind of
play that position on autopilot even if
your knowledge isn't quite there even if
you haven't studied it in too much
detail because the positions are quite
simplified but uh yeah strange the same
thing three minutes now wow attack for
Magnus down to 12 minutes in this
position which is definitely not new for
him I am surprised what's going on with
him yeah the more he thinks the more I'm
inclined to say he's going to okay he
does take this Pawn eventually uh I was
going to predict something wrong so I'm
glad he got there first but uh yep
Knight takes porn and now black has a
few moves as far as I'm aware one of
them is to hit this Knight with Bishop
you can also just capture this Pawn in
the center
and maybe other Alternatives as well he
does indeed hit the knights gaining some
time to develop and uh very balanced so
far the reason why these lines are
tricky though is because there's this
tension between the D4 and the C5 Pawn
so at some moment if you're not looking
out for it white can capture that pawn
and you may not get it back so that's
what this position is coming down to at
the moment and if you see Max's last
move jumping his Knight into the center
of the board unleashing that Bishop in
front of his King as it slices across
the diagonal towards the black queen
side that puts some immediate threat so
I'm looking at this position and I'm
wondering for a car you know how much
more preparation does he have here he is
starting to think but it's the type of
thinking he's looking the side I believe
he's trying to remember his variations
he's not on his own just yet and that's
also because it's an important position
they David you were about to say
something no I was going to back up what
Robert said normally when he looks to
the left I think he's trying to recall
something if he's looking to the right
he's very unsure uh it's as if he's
trying to work stuff out but yeah I'm
not as good as Danny wrench as uh kind
of reading the many faces of Hikaru
that's an interesting tell that you just
pointed out but I think it's also
important for Hikaru to slow down right
now because there are concrete threats
in the position we see with magnus's
last move of jumping the Knight up the
board he's cleared the path for his own
Bishop on G2 watch out for that pawn on
B7 and again Robert Woody was saying
that very often the center tension can
go in White's favor for example let's
say if black does that with the queen to
see it or to C7 defending that pawn on
B7 it does result in white capturing the
C5 pawn and you don't have time to
recapture instead Hikaru knows that the
strongest piece in magnus's Camp is that
Bishop on G2 Throwing Fire Down the
board challenges it immediately the good
news for Hikaru is that right now white
count Advanced at Central epon all the
way up the square because the Knight and
the bishop would attack it instead
Magnus goes on to pick up the C5 Pawn
there's work to be done by Hikaru to win
that back yeah it looks like a clip one
advantage for uh Magnus right now but
Hikaru just looking up working something
out calculating recalling who knows but
uh he's going to try and find ways of
getting this one back for example you
could start with the bishop trade but
now big questions do you trade off the
Queens do you leave the Queens on the
board uh to be honest I know I don't
know the answer uh in this position I
don't know the most accurate way for
black to equalize but all I remember is
that it should be possible to win the
pawn back at some point yeah I think a
critical thing though is even if you do
get the pawn back just go one move
deeper if the Black Knight comes out to
D7 and we trade Knights on that square a
white can flick in this move Pawn to C6
and you can have that pawn you're going
to even up the material but look at the
resulting Pawn structure these are
isolated pawns on the queen side which
means they may be ripe targets for white
pieces to go after it's not the biggest
advantage in the world but at this high
level these small pluses that's all you
may need to put pressure on your
opponent and then try to win the game
yeah and I think this is a dream for
Magnus uh this will be an opening
achievement for him certainly if he can
break the black structure and have
something to play against long term you
just need to keep the game alive as long
as possible if you can Magnus hasn't
gone for this yet he first swaps the
Queens he captured the black queen on d8
and only then took back the bishop so uh
similar ideas
store potentially if the Black Knight
does try to go for the pool now trade
off and as Robert says you couldn't now
step this Pawn forward break the
structure and hope for a tiny little at
least symbolic Advantage but uh it's up
to Hikaru what's he gonna go for how is
he going to restore the material balance
all right this is uh the first game uh
in the winner is final after Today's
Show at 1pm Pacific time in the US
there's gonna be an ask me anything with
The Grandmaster Sam Shanklin on the
chess.com Discord Channel if you log on
there you can ask Samsung anything
basically but he's gonna focus on his
new chessable course on the Neo Catalan
is that a favorite of you guys played it
many times yeah yeah so don't miss your
chance to uh to answer to ask questions
to one of the games the very best
Grandmaster Samsung Clinton 1pm Pacific
time
yeah I think we'll all log on later yeah
I need some tips on my openings yeah we
think we can get his preparation he's
renowned for his opening Theory so uh if
we could say hey can you please send us
a file he has to answer but he doesn't
have to say yes right yeah that's true I
think the answers are resounding no
it was also on magnus's theme for one of
the world championship matches I think
the 2016 one it was against karaoke and
that Sam wasn't magnus's team that
sounds right yes so you know that's
great experience for him I mean he's
renowned as an opening theoretician and
those are the type of people you want in
your training camps to work on specific
openings uh so Sam he won the 2018 U.S
Championship he had such a great year to
cross 2700 become one of the highest
rated players in the world he's been a
Mainstay of the US Olympic team so Sam
shank go to somebody if you don't know
who he is Google's your friend and then
we'll look at his chess games some great
ones there played on the Champions chess
tour as well uh Sam Shanklin
you know I'm looking at the screen and
we've got this epic rivalry right what's
grown to become the biggest rivalry of
modern online chess two of the best
players here fighting each other
but we also have two streamers fighting
each other
we're we're actually looking at uh well
I don't know two of the most popular
chess streamers currently and that's
kind of funny in my head yeah Magnus
these days ever since he's relinquished
the classical title he's taken to
streaming a bit more he's playing more
online events and
um yeah it's refreshing to I've been up
very late watching him sometimes uh when
he while he has these massive Blitz
marathons on Chester we're gonna have an
IMA of our own hair so David who do you
think is a better streamer that's my AMA
question to you okay I picked sides
between Eric I see a good cash but I'm
not picking sites but a streamer in
terms of entertainment or chess
wow you're just with me on a spot but
equally good and what streaming or chess
both oh I'm a big fan I've been watching
Hikaru for years now so uh he is more
experienced in the streaming that's for
sure yeah
and one of the most popular ones of
course yeah a humongous audience you
know his viewership is Sky High so uh
he's really helped chess become
increasingly popular definitely I think
his contribution has been immense and
what's been really spectacular about it
is that he's managed to maintain his
chest strength and even better himself
while streaming which he often calls his
first profession how are you the world's
best player when you're also a top
streamer yeah that's incredible stuff
yeah and it's also he's kind of the
model for young players just the work
rate the hours he puts in with streaming
and with studying chess playing chess
everything it's as if he's committed his
whole life to the game and uh I think
anyone who wants to reach the kind of
upper echelons of any sport needs to
look at him as an example it's just
fantastic I was so impressed uh
following the the world Fisher random
World Championship
he was playing these super long days
playing some fantastic chess and then
just immediately afterwards logging on
streaming doing the doing so much work
yeah and now look at him in Boss mode
just that pose just crossing his arms
like yes I'm gonna win that pawn back
I'm gonna lock this one down with the
draw yeah
you're Landing right now and also his
performance in 22 in the Grand Prix
qualifying for that
just an amazing yeah and even the
candidates if he had not lost the dingly
ran in the final round he might be
facing off against the under partnership
for the world championship so there were
so many good moments for akara Nakamura
he returns to his streaming and that's a
you know what he enjoys but I not sure
he loves the position he has right now I
know he went in Boss mode a little
moment ago he crossed his arms but now
he's leaning in and diving in to the
complexities of this position and we see
Magnus he's on the clock he plays Bishop
E3 defending the C5 pawn and it kind of
reminds me in a way of the game between
originara Garcia and Magnus Carlsen of
course different Pawn structure
different scenario but white is up a
pawn and clinging to that extra Pawn
black needs to prove he can get it back
I do believe that Hikaru is going to
bring his Knight his undeveloped night
out to attack it but Magnus always has
something up his sleeve well the one
thing he has to be careful about is not
having the move C6 up his sleeve because
there's such a nasty trick in the
position we been talking about this
resource that white has when the pawn is
attacked you advance it on the board but
be careful watch out the bee Pawn will
advance two steps hit that Knight on C4
which is a key defender of that Central
Knight on E5 and this is going to be an
absolute disaster for white yeah
suddenly one of your Knights is lost
either this Central One or the it's mate
over here it's fellow Knights and this
would be a huge blunder of course we
don't expect to see Magnus fall into
this but that does beg the question how
else to defend your Pawn if you can't
move it forward without losing a knight
how do you keep it on the board if the
pawn drops equality should just fizzle
out towards the drawer so do you step
your knight back I'm struggling to see
uh ideas to keep that pawn on the board
there's also them upon the B4 which
defends your C5 Pawn but gives up the
pawn on the Square but after Knight
takes the Rook slides one square over
hits the Knight and the pawn behind it
and active Rooks are so important in
these kind of end games where maybe even
black equalizes in terms of the material
but the activity should leave white with
at least a slight Advantage so I think
that you're kind of have several choices
here for Magnus he's trying to work out
which one gives him the best chances
whether it's retreating the Knight
initially or pushing this Pawn
sacrificing it and opening up the B line
yeah this would be uh really creative
but also potentially very strong I'm not
sure whether Nakamura had envisaged that
one a couple of moves ago to push this
Pawn forward the problem with dropping
the Knight back to defend this Pawn is
that now one of the black Rooks might
simply centralize and still an issue
with this Pawn uh still some stuff to
work out for Hikaru Nakamura but first
Magnus must decide Retreat the Knight
play it safe or potentially push this
Pawn riskier but higher potential
Rewards
I think this is going to Showcase how
ambitious Magnus is on his next move if
he does advance that Bond he's making
his intentions very clear it might be an
ending the Queens might have been
swapped off but I'm still looking at the
initiative here or a safer approach
would be to fall back with the knight uh
I think Hikaru is hoping that Magnus
does go for the night Retreat to defend
it because B4
it looks like things are going to get
very heated after the trades of the
night picking up the pawn The Rook
coming on the open file and David you
can defend that Knight on B4 if you can
just have that on the board because we
might be seeing this and let's say you
pick up the night the pawn The Rook
comes on the open file hitting that
Knight if you fall back you lose the B7
Pawn for remove you can still hang in
there push that a pawn all the way up to
A5 but it doesn't really help does it
because white can also continue putting
pressure on that night with the move A3
yeah kicking it away and if the Knight
has to move for Retreats then we do
gobble up this Pawn reason reinstate
this extra opponent Advantage yes we
might be left with a bit of an odd Pawn
structure after the bishop is recaptured
we have to recapture with the port now
the knights have to defend each other
but white does have a free pass Pawn to
start pushing now White's Rook is on the
seventh rank this Rook which was
previously passive has suddenly opened
up and uh yeah it definitely looks like
this turns in White's favor
um these are very natural moves it's a
few moves down the line but it it does
begin with white taking this decision he
does it it's on the board he goes for
the more ambitious approach where he
might end up with less upon but he'll
have that seep on which will start
advancing down the board wow that is
making intentions very clear shots fired
yeah shots fired in Hikaru just for a
moment frowning pausing and does he have
a solution up his sleeve he didn't
expect it right that was like what just
happened there of all the moves that I
was considering with the night Retreat
maybe the pawn push things of that
nature B4 hits him and he's like oh
that's possible and it might just be
good and now you have to kind of reset
as a chess player when you are caught
off guard when a surprise hits you you
need to start thinking objectively
regain your composure and he's looking
at these variations he knows he can
gobble up that pawn but once the white
Rook slides over and tries to land on
the B7 Square removing that pawn in the
process it's going to be too much
activity to deal with I don't think it's
comfortable for hikara but he doesn't
just have to take this Pawn on B4 he can
slide his Rook up to the center of the
board hitting the Knight on E5 as well
so he has his options but it's clear to
me that he was not expecting the move
Pawn to be four yeah that's a clever
move there Robert uh Rook to D5 just uh
utilizing this pin hitting the white
knight in the center of the board and it
cannot really move uh this would induce
a weakening move potentially for white
you have to step your Pawn forward I
guess to defend it and suddenly the
question remains can you now go in and
take this Pawn uh these are the things
going through hikaru's mind right now
it's two three move tactics here and
there a little bit of calculation you
need something now because if white gets
one more move to just create a pawn
chain for example if black wastes time
if you just get one more move connect
three here and uh this Black Knight is
just sat on a terrible Square on the
side of the board white has it an extra
Pawn advantage of course and Magnus he's
going to win this game you cannot allow
this at any cost so now is the moment
you have to make a big decision and I
expect tikara to go into the tank for
three four minutes because it is that
that tense you need to find a good
solution to this last move and then I
can bring up a question from the twitch
chat to you uh David uh the fans have
really been loving your story on the
Pikachu the big reveal that you are a
Pokemon fan and uh Kent lovegren is
asking what's your most memorable live
commentary moment
not to do with Pokemon
I should confess I always dreamed of
being a PM not a GM a Pokemon Master
anyway enough of that my most memorable
commentary moment
um in terms of the games we've
commentated on it might have been Magnus
pretty much busting out of his shirt
when he beat uh when he beat Wesley
Stone the massive comeback I think it
was a couple of seasons ago on the tour
yeah um if it's not necessarily to do
with the games we're watching then
beating the Magnus app oh that was back
to Stage 10 yeah getting my revenge
after he crushed me the first time and
uh yeah that's probably the highlight it
definitely wasn't dressing up as a
Teletubby that was maybe the low light
of my commentary career but uh no it's
been a ride it's been a journey and I've
loved every moment yeah it's been
fantastic to have you in the studio
David and it's so nice to now I have two
new members in the studio as well Tanya
and Robert joining the Oslo Studio to
follow the action of the third season in
the Champions chess tour and already on
day three in the 2023 season we have
this dream battle between ikar and
Nakamura and Magnus Carlsen who's
getting the best start here and it might
not be the only time that we see two of
them together and that's all thanks to
the Double Elimination bracket uh Kaya
your question about who we're seeing
have a good start I think Magnus is
happy about the position that he's
gotten with this last move he's posed
some real questions here uh to Hikaru
but Hikaru is so good at adapting at
this shifts yes he wasn't expecting this
Pawn Advance he might have
underestimated it but we often think of
Hikaru as this aggressive attacking
player but one of his biggest chess
Trends and quality is how resourceful he
is and how resilient he is when faced
with a with a question with a problem
situation a challenge he knows how to
take apart was and then just give it his
best and adapt immediately and that is
why he is one of the world's best
players in these formats I see him
reaching out for his Mouse he is about
to make a move he is about to take a
decision he has burnt two minutes and he
picks up the pawn he goes for for the
line which is the most direct one uh and
A5 on the board we were talking about
this expecting Magnus to continue
attacking that night to open up the
b-file for The Rook yeah but when we
were analyzing this it looked very
promising for white Robert I'm uh
surprised I've got to say maybe there
were more solid options available uh
he's definitely made a committed
decision here Hikaru it's all based on
retreating his Knight now and not giving
white the time to go and grab this Pawn
on B7 there's tension with the Knights
but the pawn structure just looks really
bad really weak for black clear
Advantage for white you have your the
first Rook into the action he just leaps
forward with Rook to B6 putting pressure
on the C6 pawn and if your best move as
black is to defend your Pawn you're
using a very valuable piece to defend
the least valuable Pawn but the issue is
you give up that pawn white has a clear
passer so I just feel like uh Magnus
he's attacking the C6 Pawn with his Rook
the A5 Pawn is also attacked uh with his
Knight and all of White's pawns are
defended for the time being clear
Advantage for Magnus Carlsen a Hikaru
spent about four minutes to play Knight
takes Pawn a few turns ago and it's
clear that Magnus is the upper hand yeah
Magnus definitely has the upper hand
just to prove your point here Robert if
you do have to take time out plant The
Rook on a really ugly Square then
White's other root canal into the into
The Fray at some point we can switch
Focus maybe to the seventh rank uh for
example this move you're threatening a
night jump a night fork and it just
looks extremely strong and the top
players they never choose passive
defense unless they really have to and a
really instructive move there very
strong move potentially from Hikaru
Nakamura uh he's going on the counter
attack he plants his Bishop in the
center challenging whites Bishops
control over its own C pawn and uh this
is a counter if White NOW gets greedy
and does take this Pawn then I'm trying
to figure out exactly what he has in
store but I'm expecting acting
potentially nitrate and now the black
root can start jumping in getting active
maybe the Black Knight jumps in to go
for this Pawn
still looks like white is in the
driver's seat are pulling up at least
for now Magnus not risking anything but
Hikaru he's going to try and defend
actively that's always the more
promising approach to see the evaluation
bar jump just as I suggest this move so
maybe it was uh this one instead and
still manageable for black not lost yet
but you are pawned down at least for now
active defense and the guy was showing
the part this analysis about the
position that we have right now I think
it's exactly what Hikaru is hoping for
because notice that E2 Pawn is a
weakness then light on C3 super strong
and let's say you make a move like King
to F3 you know kings are supposed to be
active in the end game this will
actually be exactly what black is hoping
for The Rook will slide down to see it
offer a trade of Rooks the C5 bond is
undefendable and black solves all
problems in the position so a really
nice active approach there by Hikaru to
solve his problems yeah suddenly White
had all those active pieces but they've
all been traded off yes white was a pawn
up but if you look at what remains black
has an active black has an active Knight
and white is left with two passive
pieces so yeah the players are so
sensitive to that very impressive from
Hikaru but stylistically this is up
Magnus Carlson's wheelhouse he loves
grind them out and games where he's
slightly better Hikaru Nakamura is an
amazingly resourceful Defender but
that's typically when tactics are at
play Nobody enjoys playing a passive end
game or a pawn down end game so I think
that Magnus whether or not he wins this
game he should be very happy with how
it's gone and he is spending time here
after the bishop captured the bishop on
E3 which means he might take with his
Pawn he might double isolate his Pawns
in the sound of the board to keep his
Knight on C4 active the Knight where it
currently sits hits that black Pawn on
A5 so Magnus thinking here I believe he
may very well take that Bishop with his
Pawn it's tempting it's very attempting
you also open up the white Rook on F1
you mentioned that Magnus loves grind
them out end games we even did a whole
chessable course on those and I learned
so much from just the technique just
that mentality of Magnus he's just happy
to torture his opponents he's a sadist
at us just love sitting there thinking
okay I'm a pawn up you do the hard work
you suffer just to get a draw and I
think that's what he's trying to do in
this game he's saying to Hikaru no
winning chances for you very one-sided
in terms of winning chances maybe you
make a draw if you play really well but
if not uh then I'll have some chances
and there we see the Rook trade did
happen and whoa Lincoln you missed it uh
all the Rooks are off the board we did
see a little transition there White's
extra Pawn has disappeared but the white
king is extremely active uh night end
games we often say they're very similar
to King and porn end games you just
imagine the knights are off the board
and that's how you evaluate the position
if you're winning without the knights
off the board you're usually winning
with the Knight still on because they
balance each other out but can that
white king run towards the queen side
now pick off that lone black pawn equal
material is so deceptive here it's all
about that King activity you're talking
about the main aim to try and get that
game closer to the queen side barn and
win it and then it'll be game over the
one move that comes to my mind is F4
black has just played E5 to take away
this D5 Foursquare from white skin to
advance to the center towards the pond
but right now Magnus has the option to
challenge that E5 Pawn advancing his own
F Pawn he chooses another path he goes
Knight to D6 uh clearing up and he
perhaps wants to go Knight E4 offering a
trade absolutely brilliant Knight D6 is
showing the vision it takes to win at
the highest level he wants to enter the
king and pawn end game which will be
winning despite the initially equal
material because White's King is more
active after the Knight swaps on e4
which you don't want to do you see the
evil Bargo Sky High because the king
takes the King goes up to D5 and it can
walk on over to the queen side to win
this A4 Pawn that outside pass Pawn will
win the day for the white pieces so
Knight D6 that's on a move that was on
my radar but as soon as Magnus played
I'm like oh this guy he's devious he
wants both to bring his Knight to E4 and
to allow his King to slide back to D2
without black getting the E4 Square for
his own night yeah so one of the ideas
has been prevented black does stop the
white knight from dropping back to force
a trade and I think the second idea
might come in action now Robert marching
the king across no Magnus goes back with
his Knight first what a maneuver losing
time but he has loosened up the black
structure and now this Pawn is attacked
if it steps forward yes you've connected
four but you've allowed the white king
into the black half of the board and uh
suddenly it will advance it might even
come the whole way around the long way
around to try and to pick off this Pawn
also if this Pawn disappears white will
win that's almost guaranteed Knights are
so bad at stopping the A and H pawns the
Rooks pawns because they can only defend
from one side they don't have another
flank to defend from instead Hikaru of
course couldn't allow the white king to
get active he dropped back to a really
passive Square for his Knight but now
simple path for the king but mag has
been the king of precision he's not sure
do I want to bring my king to D3 or back
to D2 this may seem like it's the same
idea you're bringing the king to the
Queen's head but the king up on D3
allows a night check maybe you don't
want to allow that Knight back into the
game uh it's still going to be good for
white but that is what Magnus is
calculating he knows he has the upper
hand here he knows that probably he
shouldn't even be winning in this end
game he sees the forest through the
trees and he's looking how to get that a
pawn but he wants to make sure that
hikar has no chances in return yeah I'm
very surprised I've got to say that
Hikaru looks so poker faced on the
camera because I would be terrified here
for black looks like one-way traffic
again just a simple path for the white
King's Simple Plan and it's a distant
dream at the moment to try and trade off
all the pawns and survive uh just by
giving up your knight getting rid of
that final white porn I don't see any
way to save this one to salvage this
game long term Magnus has a ticked under
two minutes on the clock another
question from the twitch chat from Dr
mikterstein Robert who has more to prove
in this match Magnus it's the best
according to him but Hikaru has beaten
him a lot last year Magnus never has
anything to prove and I'm not saying
that her car does but the question
should never be about what does magazine
approve he is the best player in history
in my opinion so you know does he need
to prove that he's still going to be the
best for years to come maybe some would
argue that but I really don't feel like
Magnus needs to prove anything because
he is the best player in chess all right
even if he lost in the speed Chess
Championship to Hikaru if you lost
as well I don't think he would like it
he doesn't enjoy it but proving
something and enjoying it two different
things but I get the question right
because Magnus he has suffered many
defeats against a car in the previous
year over their careers of course Magnus
has a dominant score against everybody
and in particular Hikaru In classical
chess if there's lopsite as it gets but
a car is proven that he's over that hump
that psychological barrier he could give
Magnus the challenge like nobody else
can and Magnus he is looking to win this
game one because he knows that Hikaru
will struggle to get back to the match
if he can land the first blow and do you
guys think no Magnus will win this first
game
looks like it he's played a Flawless end
game amazing technique there the Magnus
touch as they call it in the end game
you were talking about Precision king of
precision the King has moved to the
precise Square not even allowing the
tiniest counter play to Black to come in
with the check with the Knight the king
is going to move along the dark squares
put pressure on that a pawn and we see
Hikaru looking into nothingness but it's
not going to help him right now well
that was deeply depressing look into
nothingness I I feel for him now that is
the position on the board and he tries
to advance his own King so the idea is
to get that King all the way to D5 so
that you can try and put pressure on
White's night but the Knight can just
fall back with a check uh it looks like
this is going to be an uphill task for
Hikaru to defend this one yeah one
minute against two minutes so some Hope
on the clock for Hikaru if he can hustle
slightly give Magna some difficult
questions to answer maybe initiate a
race later on because races you need
time to work out you have to go step by
step see who's quicker but at the moment
definitely objectively strong position
for white I would say that if Magnus
hadn't won the world rapid and Blitz
titles then maybe something to prove but
uh thanks to those victories in uh at
the end of December I would say yeah
he's pretty relaxed and he knows uh he's
still the guy to beat but as a as a
triple world champion you kind of have
little to prove to the world
uh Fisher
randomly's got that one we are we are
seeing the two world champions in this
screen right now Magnus Carlsen In
classical rapid and Blitz Hikaru in
Fisher random yeah I mean while one step
away from taking that black apron
creating his own past Pawn no way to
stop it for Hikaru Nakamura as uh Tanya
mentioned maybe the best bet is to land
the black king into the center but the
White Knight drops back with the check
and it's inevitable black will be a pawn
down you just have to create counter
play you have to create some confusion
maybe boxing the white king when it does
land uh on the corner uh on the side of
the board there we go uh the king does
move we see a quick Knight check where
to go with the black king we've got to
move forward you can't go backwards
anymore because white is just gonna
swoop up that a pawn for nothing and
Hikaru does it what his idea is David he
wants to actually go even ahead trying
to Target those King side pawns so let's
say white does pick up the A4 Pawn
Hikaru is relying on the counter play
with the King stepping one more step and
then another and then trying to pick up
the pawns but I have to say it looks
like it's going to be too slow that a
pawn as yasa says baby and it's going to
decide the game yeah it's a race this
Pawn is going to run it's really hard to
imagine this Black Knight stopping it
but uh Magnus didn't want to calculate
that one yet he gives himself the option
to repeat moves there's three second
increment at the moment so he dropped
his Knight back with the check forcing
the black king back and now we might see
him just repeat one more time why not
gain a few more seconds on the clock and
uh okay first he doesn't want to repeat
in this way first he just uh reinforces
the fact that he can take this Pawn
anytime he wants he gives uh the option
of a knight check first but the
evaluation bar drops and he surprised
the car with that one hikara was like
wait a second that gives me a chance and
because her car could push his own pawns
with his King being a menace towards
those white pawns F5 to F4 pushed that
pawn forward he can then go after the
other pawns with his King instead looks
like a car stepped forward with his
Knight he protects his Pawn on A4 with
his Knight I think that there will be
some kind of inevitable uh loss of that
pawn but that knight from C5 will aim
towards the white pawns at 94 and I
think that maybe Magnus he kind of
delayed it a little bit too long but
it's because of his clock he is down
under 10 seconds remaining five now four
he needs to make a move and he needs to
make it fast he does go for the move F3
I think he has made it a little tricky
for himself here and not clear how he's
actually going to pick up the A4 Pawn
anymore and it um might it might just be
fine for Hikaru now yeah suddenly these
Pawn pushes gonna happen I'm not sure
which one you push first you can make an
argument for both but suddenly it
definitely looks like the race has
started and Magnus gave Hikaru a bit of
ground there no way that he's going to
win this Pawn in the next two three
moves it will take time and hecaro has
that luxury to start pushing pawns so
definitely some drawing chances maybe
Magnus letting it slip he didn't lose on
time he has a few seconds left but he's
cutting it fine he's cutting it close he
drops back his King it's the wrong
direction suddenly chances for Hikaru
suddenly this Black Knight can try and
get into the center go for these white
pawns exactly David because take a look
at the geometry and the pawn structure
once the E2 Pawn is attacked it can't
move forward the F3 Pawn is weak but
inside Hikaru continues marching down
the board with his own pawns we've got a
pawn star happening here and it's just
an absolute mess who is playing for a
win but it's a bullet brawl because
icaro he's down under 10 seconds himself
now under five he's gonna make a move
and he is going to what's he gonna do
here I think he's gonna move his Knight
he does back to B3 but look at magnus's
move in return he's going after that
pawn on A4 neither side has lost on time
it's just a race at this point the a
pawn that one is distant but black stole
upon on the king side so there's an H
Pawn versus an a pawn both sides have
their chances with minimal time in the
clock yeah and uh Hikaru hit trying to
end this game with the draw by trading
off everything that black knight is
trapped but you can break it out of its
prison just about you're just in time
and there we go a bunch of porn trades
happened and the Black Knight did find a
safe Square this one is going to fizzle
out towards the draw but a massive
missed opportunity for Magnus Carson no
material but then a pawn I mean it
should be a draw with best play but with
no time on the clock that's a scary Pawn
to deal with and that's white car to
take my Central Pawn yeah you're gonna
go up a pawn temporarily but the king
will take care of the a pawn the Black
Knight Will hop into F5 to sacrifice
itself for the G pawn and that should be
enough for the draw yeah and uh Hikaru
looks ready to get out of there he looks
like he's solved the pro problem knows
it's a draw but still some work to do
because why tonight has actually come to
the defense and if Black's King moves
forward to attack that night the a pawn
will start advancing so you don't have
the luxury and look at Hikaru you can
see from his expression that he is in
panic mode right now he wasn't expecting
that yes seconds brilliant play by
Magnus because the king cannot step
forward for black because then the pawn
runs to the other side and that means
that the king for white defends the
g-pawn and will go up the board probably
King F4 now bring your king up to G5 and
wait you can't afford to trade Knights
for a car so his Knight's going kind of
in the wrong direction he's gonna try
and hit the white king with his uh white
knight story with the black king I think
that's the idea he wants to make sure
the Black Knight defends the a pawn and
there we see it and I think even on
seconds Hikaru found the precise defense
and this is what it is the guy is so
resourceful and so good at this stuff
and just adapting to these positions
impressive play the night will sacrifice
but it's still not over the black King's
so far away you still have to race
across to the side of the board uh to
the king side now to stop that white G
Pawn of course Magnus it's going to be
hard to Advance his own Pawn because the
Black Knight Will threaten to give
itself up at every opportunity you have
to bully that black knight away kick it
away but if Hikaru puts the Knight on a
safe Square it should still be fine
yeah I would still be terrified here but
Hikaru looks like he's got it under
wraps he's still in control should still
draw this game not enough material white
Pawn isn't far enough Advanced I have to
say flawlessly done there by Hikaru he
gets the king in time to defend his own
Knight which is stopping the pawn from
advancing now and it looks like he's got
everything under control gives a check
just not allowing white to advance or
offer a night trade amazing play by a
car Nakamura he has this under control
this game for sure will be a draw
there's no way the pawn progresses about
the Knight sacrificing itself for that
pawn but for Karu to go left and right
and back and forth and to find a way
towards this half point that was amazing
by Nakamura gotta save it's a repetition
uh not quite Magnus has triangulated his
King he's got the same position we've
had twice already but this time it's
black back to move so how does Hikaru
Nakamura wait in this position White's
not actually threatening anything the
white Pawn cannot step forward because
the Black Knight Will capture it take it
off the board but uh okay he moves his
Knight and how do you get that white
pawn it must be so frustrating Hikaru
knows he's about to make a draw and
finally we see it wow finally next move
is guaranteed that white Pawn disappears
ah he runs off Hikaru Nakamura in five
minutes game two will start the first
one is a draw Magnus Carlson doesn't
look entirely happy he had the white
pieces in this game and Hikaru will have
the white pieces in game two starting in
five minutes Magnus Carl's not sitting
there looking over this game a missed
opportunity you said David what happened
yeah it looks like Magnus because of the
clock was reluctant to start a race
which would have been in his favor
instead he waited for one move too long
he tried to finesse it and uh the moment
passed and the wind Slipped Away it
started in this position we said the
black king was getting active he was
getting ready to jump towards those
white pawns if for example we start by
capturing upon on the side of the board
the black king could start advancing but
Magnus if he'd had two minutes on his
clock he would have had the time to work
out that he is winning he could move his
King out of the way yes the black king
can come in but it's simply too slow the
white Pawn can step forward now the king
can take this Pawn but at the right
moment you will go and kick this Knight
away with the white king and you'll have
a safe run through to promotion Magnus
missed this job this opportunity if we
go back and uh whoops not to this
position we did eventually see her King
and Knight versus King it was a draw
foreign
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
70 of the time and I think if you learn
these lines that very easily could be 75
or 80 for you
foreign
ERS final has started game one is over
game two will start in only a few
minutes we're gonna take a look at the
puzzle that Ivanka has brought with her
today but uh if you're not a subscriber
on Twitch here is a twitch break
[Music]
the action has started with the winners
final uh Magnus keeping Hikaru waiting
there for a long time I know I mean I
personally would have been very annoyed
and it's going to be very interesting
now to see how Hikaru handles this I
mean it's very good that he saved it
because boy that was very difficult I'm
very impressed but uh picara is one of
the most creative most resourceful
players around especially online and uh
talking about creative and resourceful
yeah well I think possible the puzzle
yeah I mean I see a lot of people really
getting into it oh cool and they've come
up with part of the solution but the
it's super super interesting because
this is this this is the study it's
white to move and uh everyone has
actually spotted the trick
actually gets deeper because you have to
remember black has two pawns they can't
promote so that's a bit of a giveaway
and that adds a little like another
facet to the pole study you you
announced that saying this puzzle it
basically has a lot of twists and turns
it does it does it does and people have
spotted the main trick okay everyone is
very good on that one but uh they're
still another level to be discovered
it's almost like an Easter egg it's
forgiving and we're gonna reward someone
who uh solves the puzzle especially if
you uh give us a creative answer maybe
with a picture a selfie with yourself
solving it together with friends and
family someone will get an air things
device signed by Magnus Carlsen so
tweets your answer to the puzzle using
the hashtag chess Champs alright well
game two is coming off what you expect
from Hikaru now I think he's going to go
into boss mode he's going to actually
put pressure on Magnus he's going to say
Hey you had the advantage on that game
but now I have the white pieces it's my
turn to have the fun
I like it game two is coming up very
shortly
oh there we go
it's final go
bitious approach where he might end up
with a less a pawn but he'll have that
seep on which will start advancing down
the board wow that is making intentions
very clear shots fired
all right Hikaru Nakamura getting ready
with the white pieces do you think
Robert he already has the plan ready for
all those white games or kind of
openings he's gonna play hard to say
because yesterday against Wesley so he
didn't really get much of anything in
fact the fourth and final game before
Armageddon he forced the draw so we
haven't seen his opening preparation at
least not from yesterday's action and he
should be happy about surviving that but
Magnus obtained an advantage so he
should be happy as well and of course
the last time these two played a match
in the speed Chess Championship Hikaru
won that one uh it was just epic this
much what was it that made Hikaru win it
how did he win it Magnus was just off
form in the early going and the car
played brilliantly so that is a mismatch
in the early stages Magnus came back he
came roaring back even tied the match
but you see on that final clip there
Magnus did not have enough time it was a
clog was running against him Hikaru was
able to survive long enough in this last
game to win the match by one point but I
think I heard Magnus after saying after
that he he enjoyed playing the match
yeah Magnus loves his love challenge I
think he's tired of just crushing
everybody and he wants to fight against
the very best and he knows Hikaru is the
very best when it comes to online
speeches yeah he he's embracing it yes
that's true yeah coming up now this is
game two Hikaru with the white pieces
what do you expect from this game Tanya
uh just what we saw in game one went on
to show the kind of fighting Spirit the
two have come with one thing that stood
out for me in that speed Chess
Championship which Hikaru won was the
strategy that Hikaru had from the start
about really letting that game time run
low there was a lot of criticism about
it but Magnus respected that at the end
and I think it made so much sense
because it really came down to that so
both players know that they need to make
the most of every single small aspect of
the game and that's the kind of fight
that we saw in the previous one it was
an end game but it went down to the wire
it went down to absolutely both of them
giving it everything but I think Magnus
is more disappointed with that and
Hikaru is relieved to get a draw yeah
definitely some time trouble in that
first game today it is 15 minutes plus
three seconds increment after each move
in the air things monsters and then the
Champions Chester Hikaru Nakamura now
getting ready first game was a draw
three games to go to the side the winner
is final if they are tied it will be
decided in Armageddon Hikaru thinking
hard here what will be his opening in
this game with the white pieces one E4
I'll say another record
so no b3s did you say the Hikaru against
Magnuson might avoid doing that
um maybe I'm not sure
I think I'll go D4 gets back to school
is always fun b3i would that be very
surprising if Hikaru did that B3 yes I
think it would be hugely reserves that
for Blitz Games more than rapid games
because even in the chess.com Global
Championship uh he was playing against
Grand Master uh shorter from uh Chile
and he was in trouble after playing B3
so you know that's not an opening that
you really want to play in the highest
level
what will it be he's leaning forward
zikara Nakamura is game two now about to
start here we go yes
and uh it is another ready opening uh
playing copycat this is exactly the
strategy Magnus used in the last game so
yeah psychological warfare has begun
Magnus doesn't go for the approach that
Hikaru used in the previous game he also
featuring ketus but he gets ready to
think until his Queen side Bishop the
light Square Bishops on the long
diagonal will be facing off against each
other this often transposes to the
Queen's Indian defense or other branches
of that opening but uh Hikaru pausing
now white does have options you don't
necessarily need to rush to develop your
Bishop first you occupy the center and
that's what Hikaru is going for now
Magnus did famously lose a game in the
Queen's Indian defense against Anish
giri in at the Tata steel Masters just
uh very recently so again different
branch of that opening but uh he won't
have fond memories there so Hikaru may
be trying to remind him of those ghosts
what do you think of this Tanya the one
big difference there was that Magnus to
take out his Bishop to one step ahead on
A6 instead of B7 it was slightly a
different structure but a theoretical
battle that was which Anish was just
just a beast in that game I mean he
played it flawlessly and won it and
Magnus decides this time to place his
Bishop differently on the long diagonal
so definitely going to be a slow game
and we're going to see a proper Queen's
Indian but that could be a difference
Magnus can't decide to fans out on the
other side as well and he does that
instead of the move of moving that
kingspawn one step ahead which would be
the Queen's Indian defense he goes for
this one this is sort of like the hippo
right yeah almost if Black's night was
maybe placed on a slightly different
square like hesitated from castling uh
this early he did have this exact
position against Arjun eregasti in the
final round of the Tata steel Masters
Magnus Carlson and their Arjun pushed
forward one of the white Central pawns
the game became very locked up very
tense and Magnus eventually
outmaneuvered his young opponent but now
Hikaru is thinking for sure he's seen
this position before he's just trying to
pick a line he's trying to choose
something that will throw Magnus off
balance and uh Robert who do you think
this opening is going to favor
stylistically it's kind of a dodgy
opening right you're just like saying
let's not go into preparation but what
black is really waiting for is that
Queen side night to develop because as
soon as that Knight leaves B1 the Black
Knight on F6 hops into the center to the
E4 Square that's what Magnus is aiming
for start trading off some pieces
because White's pawns are better they're
more advanced they're taking control of
important squares and we saw that Hikaru
slit his Rook to E1 E4 not available yet
but as soon as white develops that
queenside Knight that Black Knight Will
hop in to the E4 Square yeah bit of a
waiting game neither side wanting to
commit those uh commit to those plans
commit their pieces yet and any trades
do help black so okay the bishop comes
out I once had this exact position uh
pretty much myself and uh I was on the
black side I found it really difficult I
was very cramped I was playing against
the young Chinese Superstar and yeah
eventually I just couldn't deal with a
space disadvantage for black I just
really disliked the fact I had no Pawn
breaks I had no plan so interesting
strategy from Hikaru not initiating any
direct contact between the enemy Army
between the two sides here but uh yeah
very much a slow maneuvering waiting
game Space is what black is lacking in
these openings and there are two
approaches to try to neutralize that one
could be that you Advanced the pawn in
front of the queen just one step ahead
and he does that and what black
eventually wants to do is try and get an
E5 break as well so the Knight will come
to D7 The Rook will move to the center
of the board on E8 and either the C Pawn
will advance to squares forward or the E
Pawn goes to E5 and then you start
asking white questions about what you
want to do with those Central bonds yep
very flexible and you're right it does
resemble a hippo black just wallows in
his first three ranks weights weights
weights and then we'll be ready to
pounce later when the prey comes too
close and the reason I believe that it's
called a hippo is because if we look at
the pawn formation it kind of reminds
you a little bit of a hippo just peeping
out of water does it
in New York City I don't really hang out
with too many hippos happen but uh yeah
I guess that could be why it's called
that
only only explanation
is named after an animal in New York
City the the orangutan ah yeah I think
what's that New York Zoo someone went
down to the zoo
someone needs to research this Magnus
told me the story once we literally uh
somewhere in Norway we went on a little
trip and we went to the zoo we had to
take a detour to go and check out the
orangutan just so he could tell me the
story and look at it but uh I can't
remember sorry Magnus
but there is an opening called the
orangutan that is one B4 it's also
called the Polish opening sometimes but
uh one before yeah
and this one is a different breed of
animal this one uh White will get the
space advantage in the next few moves
there's already a threat small
positional threats of pushing forward in
the center I don't think you can wallow
in the water for too long as black
because suddenly white does get the
three pawns here and uh you will suffer
long term with your pieces nowhere to
put black pieces while you face such a
strong Pawn Center so I expect Magnus
now to lash out to try and break the
center perhaps with a move Tanya
mentioned okay no I was going to say
maybe he's straight bikes with the move
C5 just trying to break down white
structure but he brings his Knight out
in front of the encountered Bishop very
very rare type of move what is the uh
what is the idea after this Pawn pushes
forward maybe it's a tactical one yeah I
think this might even move his Knight
just backwards he might just say Let Me
Go Knight back from F6 to D7 uh it's
another night and open up the dark
Square Bishop because E4 is a committal
move even though it's a good choice look
at those three Pawns in a row the D4
Square becomes one that black can Target
and then there's no white Pawn that can
help cover that actually happens in many
queens Pond openings where you give
white the space but if you push all the
way up to D5 let's say to protect your
Pawn by moving off the attack Square
then that Bishop on G7 is a monster
slicing across the board so it's a big
decision for Hikaru you know he's been
playing for E4 magnets allowing him to
do it and now that the opportunity has
come to fruition he's like do I really
want to push that pawn forward I'm not
sure I trusted and Magnus saying come on
let's go I'm ready for it really clever
strategy normally in the hippo in the
hippopotamus defense you get the Black
Knights on these two squares here
they're much more active they're already
on that very nice post so very flexible
here Magnus is ready to counter with one
of these Pawn strikes in the center if
given time if given the opportunity so
uh yeah if you don't push now for white
I think Hikaru should and most likely
will push this Pawn because it's the
most ambitious but if you don't if you
take a timeout for example move your
queen then black will be able maybe to
go for the same plan Robert mentioned
there to just drop the Knight back put
some pressure on this pawn and then
strike in the center with E5 this bishop
actually it looks like a London system
but it's misplaced in this Pawn
structure because it doesn't have any
good squares to retreat to and uh yeah
Magnus really creative
solution there to the opening problem it
looks like he's cramped but very very
solid and Hikaru burning time to try and
break down this hippo defense all right
the winner of the winner is final will
go through to play the Grand Final in
the air things Masters on Friday the
loser will play the losers final
tomorrow and we do have a question on
Twitter from Trio
um and I'll ask this to you Robert
because you're so in control of the
regulations what happens if the winner
amongst Hikaru and Magnus lose in the
Grand Final versus the winner from the
losers bracket I got the answer for you
so that match the first match would be a
four game match and if the previously
unbeaten person loses then it means your
second match of two games so today we're
kind of in the winners bracket until
that winner loses and then we get a
two-game finality uh it would be six
games minimum on that day and maybe with
Armageddon even more wow so a grand
final reset to be played if the player
from the winner final loose so that is
basically how double elimination work
you can lose one match and still win the
whole thing but the second you lose a
second match it is over
these two still haven't lost a match in
the air things monsters but one of them
will lose the match today either in the
rapid portion with four games or an
Armageddon they are tied so far this is
game two any car did make his move yeah
and a slightly superficial night jump
this white knight is not well placed at
all on this Square on B3 uh Robert's
mentioned in the past that Knights are
often dominated by enemy pawns if
there's two gaps two empty squares
between them this white knight now is
dominated by the black Pawn on B6
nowhere forward to jump but he's just
trying to control the center just
creating some squares maybe for the
White Queen to jump forward to and I
guess that Knight will just be happy to
retreat uh in a few moments time
meanwhile Magnus good air quality good
position uh can you back it up
one of the things that the knight jump
on B3 does invite from Magnus is the a
pawn advancing down the board A5 A4
really targeting it so that's something
that white needs to keep in mind but
meanwhile Magnus continues with the idea
and the plan that we've been talking
about trying to get that E5 break in
because that's really how you want to
challenge White's position in the center
by the way guys we were talking about
the orangutan and I couldn't stop myself
but actually looking up what the story
was because David you're right uh it did
come up and I think um it's a very
interesting one and I couldn't remember
so I was what was it and it was a
tournament in New York back in 1924 whoa
and it was the legendary Grandmaster
tartakova who was going to play against
maroxy and before that before that game
there was a trip to the zoo the New York
zoo I think the Bronx Zoo maybe and the
players went there and Legend has it
that Tata cover was trying to think of
what he wants to play against as
opponent he was watching the animals and
then he says in his interview or it came
out later that it was an orangutan who
advised him to go one before in his next
game really and that's how it got named
the orangutan one before wow how cool
maybe some help is needed in that
situation of you know we're talking to
the orangutans uh yeah that's uh maybe
not the best look for the best chess
players but it's cool opening and Magnus
Carlson has played it um he has put it
in actually the Champions chess tour in
the past not a good opening but one that
is quite fun so from 1924. the Bronx Zoo
right where it was found 100 year
anniversary yeah we need to celebrate
that let's all go to the zoo yes yes
let's do it yeah and nowadays modern
place they choose their openings in
different ways they check the computer
they ask their seconds yeah no trips to
dizzy but 1924 is that considered an A
quite new opening
interesting
that's a mind puzzle yeah I guess when
you tell us the viewers everything's
named when were they created probably
before it's like what is the newest the
most modern chess opening oh
that's necessary yeah we set it up in
front of us uh here Tanya
um The Carlson variation of the Sicilian
that I saw Levy Rosman was recommending
in his uh chessboard course that's
pretty new four or five years old
hmm I feel like it wasn't just let me
recommending it then a niche kind of
said oh farming views by mentioning
magnus's name and then each posted the
chessable course where it says the
Carlson variation so there was some
funny barbs back and forth between those
two uh but you know speaking of people
who go out of hikara Nakamura Magnus
Carlsen finally a Magnus has tried to
strike in the center with Pawn to E5
there is a ton of tension and something
about that Knight that's on B3 we were
criticizing it because it's dominated by
Black's pawns my coach always taught me
that nights on the B3 B6 G3 and G6
Square so the equivalent squares uh the
knights third square that they they get
stuck there for a long time they often
stay there for far too long and they're
easily dominated so I just did not like
the look of it when it was played I
don't like the look of it now black has
the bishop pair and is opening up the
board so I'm really liking magnet's
start to this game here in the second of
the match I feel like hikara has not
obtained any opening advantage and he's
also down on the clock yeah and Hikaru
himself actually in interviews during
the world rapid uh sorry the world
official random Championship he was
saying that a common mistake that even
top Grandmasters make is they put their
Knights on these squares in Fisher
random chess he said no no you should
never do this unless you really have to
because Knights get dominated by pawns
like this the Knight has to spend three
or four moves finding a better circuit
and now he's gone against his own advice
he's put his Knight on a pretty terrible
Square the rest of his position the rest
of the white position is fine it's solid
but you don't have an easy answer to
this uh tension in the center if you
step forward you only block your
remaining bishop and after the Black
Knight moves you can move it anywhere
pretty much even if you go back home to
relocate it the Knight has an active
Square this bishop is dead for now no
Pawn breaks for white you're just a bit
stuck waiting as black slowly improves
his position and if you open things as
uh yeah as we've discussed this only
helps the bishop pair black here for
example can recapture with the queen and
uh there's some nice threats along this
diagonal I'm kind of struggling here to
find a solution for white maybe you can
jump into the center with the Knight you
hit the queen but what next the queen
moves and maybe you relocate the White
Knight over to these uh nice juicy
outposts so these holes in the black
camp but still from there what next
eventually you have to solve this
tension in the center and it's not clear
how you should do that I look at the
position I see that black has managed to
get that Central Break in with E5 and
also Advance the a bond threatening A4
actually winning that D4 Pawn already
and it looks like the hippo has come out
of the water it's no more everything on
the third rank the pieces have moved
forward the space problem so far looks a
lot more solid for black and I think
David your plan of rerouting the Knight
to C3 makes a lot of sense because the
one drawback of these pawn moves has
been the weakness on the light squares
so imagine if White Knight did get into
C3 you can look at jumping on to D5 B5
hitting that C7 Pawn everything is under
control but you might to calculate what
actually happens after A4 the good news
is that you can fall back with the
Knight
and D4 is not exactly hanging I see the
eval bar doesn't approve but I just
wanted to make a point here that black
actually cannot pick up the D4 Pawn
because notice the bishop and G2
actually pinning that Knight on C6 to
that Bishop on B7 yeah and Hikaru is
gone for a slightly different version of
what we're just showing he's first
traded office set of central pawns and
now he's landed his Knight in I'm
expecting the Knight to drop back there
we go and next move the Knight Will land
on a really nice Square however
the rest of his position doesn't make a
great impression especially this Knight
still stuck on B3 blacks Rooks have easy
access if black can ever push this Pawn
forward and open up his Bishop maybe
even now I was about to say ever is now
because you push that pawn off the board
to E4 uh this is a big problem for white
only black has a dark Square Bishop that
Bishop is wide open on G7 if you take on
e4 with your knight the bishop says
hello to that pawn on B2 you can just
grab that and then White's Pawn
structure is clearly worse Black
controls all of the vital squares in the
position and that A5 Pawn will continue
pushing at some point so that seems off
the table and you can't take on e4 with
your Bishop because tactically that
immediately fails and because Bishop can
take the Knight on C3 and your light
squares are horrible even if you don't
lose material you are going to probably
a checkmated so this is a nightmare of a
position and Magnus plays E4 he does not
hold back and he's a lead on the clock
and a huge advantage on the board yeah
this uh is really blocking down uh
locking down even this white Bishop
terrible piece now there's holes in the
white Camp Magnus puts his Queen on a
Central Square he's just going to
centralize his Rook he's going to
support his Pawn in the center and
White's position is in Ruins it's
suddenly turned in the space of two or
three moves we kind of hinted that the
momentum was turning in Black's favor
but I would never have imagined that
this is the position we would see on the
board from this opening suddenly
everything's gone in Black's favor I'm
loving I'm loving Black's position I
mean with the queen and the bishop lined
up and very importantly as you pointed
out Robert White has nothing no piece
that can actually ever challenge that
Bishop on G7 which is the key to Black's
position B2 Pawn is such a big weakness
and I'm struggling to find a way for
white to actually defend it except to
defend it with his Rook but that doesn't
really help I mean Rook B1 is an ugly
move that you don't want to make you
don't want to make your position so
passive black is already threatening to
push the a pawn not just that black can
also offer a night trade with that
knight from C6 jumping to B4 opening up
the a file if you decide to trade the
knights if not the Knight lands on D3
and is super happy it looks like with
the black pieces Magnus is putting a lot
of pressure on and I have to say so far
in the match the opening battles have
been won by Magnus with the white pieces
in the previous game as well as this one
it looks like uh Hikaru has been on the
defense right out of the opening yeah
right to see hikarus alone the clocks
sorry that Robert uh five minutes
against nine I've never seen him this
far down on rapid chess
um definitely in magnus's favor
everything right now and he does it he
goes for the idea that oh I was
mentioning earlier Robert of of opening
up that a file with a trade you get rid
of White's only active Knight and yes
you've doubled the the B pawns but look
at that a pawn the B4 Pawn is a huge
strength in Black's Camp it is taking so
much space so many squares from White
and now White's Rook on A1 is just
forever stuck defending that A2 Pawn The
Rook on D2 is stack defending the B2
pawn it just and what is the Knight on
B3 doing it looks like it's got no
future at all yeah you can give this
white knight three or four moves maybe
if it comes around here and here and
here bang into the center but of course
this is a luxury that Magnus will not
allow and uh I'm struggling to look for
moves so I'm struggling to find ideas
here for white I feel like the only idea
I can find is me pushing the a pawn for
white because otherwise your pieces are
stuck he makes the move of was it his
move or yours his move sorry oh wow
Bishop H3 but it's because he doesn't
have ideas in the position so he's like
let me just move my Bishop over here
maybe it can slide all the way up to D7
it's a one move threat it doesn't
actually amount to much but any other
moves look like they had damage to
White's position so I do when all said
doesn't like the move I just don't see
what's next
and we talked of hippos earlier now it's
white who's cramped locked in their
first three ranks suddenly black can uh
for example maybe not now but over the
next few moves just push this Pawn
forward relocate this bishop at will and
start coming around start attacking
pawns still white Bishop now completely
disconnected from the rest of its pieces
and this Knight needs to spend three or
four moves relocating uh you mentioned
Robert that uh at some point Hikaru
could potentially push a pawn for it
just to release some tension to try and
trade off a set of Rooks trade off some
pieces I think you'll have to go for
this at some point but uh yeah arranging
it successfully is the first problem
even if you do push it you will be left
with some isolated I love magnus's move
he just brought his Bishop up one square
in the diagonal because he wants to
slide a rook to d8 at the right moment
he needs The Bishop's defense because
the queen and the white Rook line up so
he's just trying to trade off some of
the pieces and hit car says I cannot
wait any longer if the Rooks are gonna
get traded the B2 Pawn will be lost so
he pushes his Pawn to A3 but now black
can simply capture that pawn on A3 and
shatter the White Queen Side Pawn
structure we've seen this many times
throughout the air things Masters when
you have separated pawns like this they
become easy targets because the Pawn's
best friend is another Pawn look at
Black's Pawn structure on B6 and C5 you
have to somehow get to the B6 Pawn not
easy to do whereas white pawns both of
them are loose so that means there are
two Targets and you're gonna have to
take your time defending them both yep
easy to get at them easy to start
attacking them these pawns and that's
not just a short-term feature that's
going to endure until the end of the
game so Hikaru who's doing he's doing
what he needs to do he's trying to trade
off pieces he's trying to gain some
level of activity but uh it shouldn't be
enough with accurate play and uh wow
okay he's traded a set of Pawns and
recaptured with his own Pawn I forgot
this was possible I've got to say I
thought this Rook would be attacked in
some variations but the White Knight
does a good job defensively so far and
uh it does feel like the time to start
trading off pieces starts bringing the
rook in even if all the heavy pieces
disappear the Rooks the Queen's the two
Bishops there for black would guarantee
a long-term advantage and Magnus does it
with his other more accurate and there's
a cool move that black can think about
playing at some point you typically
think the Rook went to date to exchange
Rooks it may sit on the D3 square right
in front of the enemy Rook because if
you're not careful and you just start
taking the material once the E4 Pawn is
gone that Bishop opens up in the longest
diagonal there could be some checkmating
threat so be careful about that that's
my favorite thing in chess or one of
them I don't know if it's my exact
favorite when you stop one square short
of expectations I think it's really
awesome really cool idea I've got to say
Robert just uh jumping into the heart of
White's position just shattering that
Hut and opening up lines for your
Bishops I think the reason that uh
Hikaru decided to trade with Bonds on A3
is so that the Rook from A1 can actually
jump over to the B file we've been
screaming about the only weakness in
magnus's position is that B6 spawn you
want to start targeting it and create
your own counter play as quickly as
possible Rook B1 is an idea in the air
thirsty says I'm gonna stop Robert's
idea Bishop to D7 a big blunder because
you can just slide the queen back and
once the queen goes back to E7 The Rook
on A1 is under attack the bishop on D7
is loose if that Rook moves somewhere
careless then the A3 Pawn is going to be
captured I think you're actually just
losing material on the spot
wow he doesn't react Magnus he's trying
to hustle Hikaru on the clock your right
robber actually the bishop jumps in
kicking this Rook away suddenly the
bishop it's protecting is doomed
I think he could have won material he
would have
banked this game basically he would have
guaranteed a material win but Magnus
missed the moment instead of retreating
his Queen opening up his Bishop against
this Rook he simply parked his King on a
slightly better Square decent move but
is it still available
is the idea still on oh maybe it's
different this time because when the
queen Retreats the white rep couldn't
use this Square preventing the intrusion
uh the invasion of the black Bishop
because now suddenly this Pawn is
defended the moment has passed and
Hikaru is still suffering but not lost
yet and it doesn't look like Magnus has
realized that's a good thing yeah I
don't think either player have realized
just the moment of mutual blindness as
we mentioned uh on previous days and
yeah as Robert says it's a good thing
otherwise Magnus would be beating
himself up and he'd be dwelling in the
past not in the present moment wow
tactics like that happen all the time
but they're so hard to spot in Rapid
chest Blitz chess in a classical game
you kind of sit there for two or three
minutes you sip your tea you realize
that your opponent's done something a
bit uh a bit careless a bit loose but uh
yeah in class in Rapid chess it's so
hard to kind of stop and force yourself
to calculate but look at her car now
he's popping his head he looks super
confident suddenly he looks happier than
he used to at least he has one active
piece that bishop and the pawn is still
alive everything's defended so far also
he has made progress on the clock now
Magnus just has a two minute lead which
isn't as much as it was and Magnus
opening up another front this is super
this is what shows the idea of the last
move King to G7 also we're getting that
a back rank for the Rook to slide over
over to the H file when required for an
attack it's not just on one flank that
Magnus wants to play he wants to play
all over the board H4 coming in and just
imagine David H4 you trade the pawns you
put your Rook on the H file you double
up with your queen on the H file and
you're then already threatening to
Checkmate the black king and this was
the idea behind magnus's last move we
were talking about winning material
Magnus is going for her carous King here
yeah you make it sound simple Tanya
maybe Checkmate is guaranteed isn't it
it's making it look simple yeah he is
and the reason why is because white can
hardly do anything yes you've taken care
of your a pawn weakness your Bishop
looks active then what a Black's plan
does look pretty straightforward and if
you stop that pawn on H5 with pushing
your own Pawn to H4 you know that G6 to
G5 is coming at some point I'm not sure
right now but you're blasting open the
white king side and White's pieces are
all over the place Black's pieces are
quite harmonious so I would be very
worried very reluctant to play the move
H4 and look at hikaru's clock by the way
he is down to nearly two minutes magna's
still at five and a half minutes yes he
played a little bit too quickly but
bring his King up to G7 that was
attacked the Magnus of course is capable
of finding but now after the move H4 you
you can see all eyes I'm pushing forward
on the king side for Magnus Carlson yeah
it's about arranging that break setting
up that break opening lines towards the
white king Magnus needs to take three or
four prep moves just to get ready for
that but he will be looking in that
direction for sure and uh you're right
Robert hard to imagine what white is
actually trying to do next maybe White's
rook in the corner will at least shift
off that long diagonal that dark Square
diagonal where it is a clear Target but
uh first Magnus has moved to make and
five minutes against two and a half you
would assume that he's able to set some
serious problems here for Hikaru if he
doesn't win this game Magnus Carlsen
he'll look at the first two as massive
missed opportunities and suddenly the
rest of the match uh today will at least
feel like a second life for Hikaru
Nakamura and uh yeah first Magnus I'm
expecting him to move a rook maybe to
slide the black queen back the Bishops
are a bit stuck right now you need to
get them working you need to give them a
job to do some Magnus how does he
activate his pieces at the moment that
white Bishop on D7 it's like a plug it's
holding the floodgates it's uh stopping
blacks pieces from pouring forward so he
does switch Focus Tanya he makes his
intention super clear and I think once
again that move King to G7 is super
telling he has a tunnel vision right now
he's going for the king side attack he
doesn't care about the material I see
that if Alba doesn't like it and says
that Magnus has missed an opportunity
but this is asking so many critical
questions to Hikaru Hikaru doesn't even
pause he says this is my moment to
create counter play on The Queen side
opens up trying to change the Dynamics
of the position trying to create his own
counter Play Because notice that how if
there's a trade the C5 Pawn will be weak
and Magnus immediately switches back and
that signals that he did not like what
he just did in the previous move yeah uh
really weird and really rare to see a
player make a move the opponent plays
some seemingly useful and then go back
just giving the opponent two moves for
free but Magnus is arguing that now
there's extra tension now those pawns on
the queen side are looking at each other
that the tactics what might uh well just
work out in Black's favor and it looks
like they might if white is greedy right
now let's jump in and see what happens
if white simply plays the most natural
move and captures a pawn unfortunately
this Rook is now attacked three times
Rook takes rook and uh due to the
battery along this diagonal Queen takes
Knight is available so this point is
actually pinned and if you can't solve
the tension I was going to say move out
of it and no longer a pin this white
Rook is off the a file it's also staring
down so if Pawn takes porn now would be
met by a night jump I'm not sure which
direction the Knight goes in it can
capture one of these two pawns and
suddenly this loose piece would fall off
yes you can win the White Knight but you
lose your bishop and suddenly no more
Advantage maybe fighting for equality
here suddenly Magnus Carlsen and uh
Hikaru is taking his chance amazing
defense by akaro but it all started when
man things did not pounce he went King
to G7 it was a good looking move trying
to bring his Rook to the H file but it
wasn't in the spirit of the position it
was a little bit slow and now all of a
sudden nicara says you give me that
second lease on this position I am going
to make the most of it there's problems
on the B6 Square behind it the bishop 1
B7 as we're talking about and I'm not
sure I see a good move besides capturing
on A5 because you don't a lot want a lot
of white to take on B6 everything is
defended in White's camp and we
typically talk about the bishop pair
being an advantage that Bishop on B7
it's staring into its own Pawn on e4 so
if we get a series of Trades it could be
black who is worse and the Knight
hopping around causing black some
problems yeah he slides back with his
Queen what's the idea then if this Pawn
is captured oh there's some nice tactics
maybe it's the same idea that he
actually missed earlier Magnus I think
he spotted that this bishop move is a
threat he missed this earlier he could
have actually won the game pretty much
on the spot but uh now of course uh
Hikaru has realized that this is the
threat and he prevents that after the
queen jumps back he got his Bishop out
of Dodge he reached it to a nice safe
Square now this bishop move is simply
achieving nothing we would just see a
rook trade so everything coming off the
board maybe on the D file Rook takes
Rook is available for example but uh
Hikaru he's definitely survived the
worst and the clocks are leveling up
balancing out and that seems like the
narrative so far in the match Magnus
getting these advantageous positions out
of the opening provoking weaknesses from
white but when that moments come he's
sort of not taken that super important
decision to go for the kill at that time
he's also playing on hikaru's clock but
now that's leveling up a little bit and
Hikaru being super resourceful in his
defense and this is truly one of his
biggest Trends I think the entire
Outlook that Hikaru is only an attack
and an aggressive player is a little
dated now his uh USB in chess is just
how difficult it makes he makes for the
opponent to actually win a better
position he does everything to make sure
that doesn't happen and it looks like
he's level the game one more time yeah
and the top players they are evolving
their style all the time and uh Hikaru
you're right when he burst onto the
scene uh when he was making his way up
through the ranks he was known for you
know the king's Indian attacking
masterpieces checkmating the opponent
but uh in recent years it's all about
strategy all about end games all about
uh kind of locking things down and uh
defending very very tenaciously and uh
yeah he's incredibly hard to beat he
takes his chances when they come still
great calculator great tactician but uh
yeah Miss chance and again for Magnus
Carson and he's Frozen he's not moved
for ages now down to one minute yeah
we've had less time than her car he was
leading by about four minutes on the
clock and now he's down to under one
minute is Magnus Carlson and I think
it's because he's regretting the
situation like how did I go from having
such an awesome position to this where
we might just liquidate and if Max isn't
careful and he gets in time trouble
Hikaru will make him pay so he's trade
off a pair of Rooks he can't take the
pawn A5 but now the queen and the Knight
team up on that square I think we're
just seeing a bunch of trades in Black
is no longer better yeah Black's no
longer better you actually start to fear
for Magnus both on the clock and on the
board White's King is super safe right
now the black king looks pretty safe but
if a white Rook ever gets to the seventh
rank there will be targets and now a
huge threat after that pawn trade that
black light Square Bishop it's got to
move and you don't have so many great
squares which is why first Magnus
attacks the queen so that he can then
move the bishop and the White Queen
doesn't land on the center of the board
so big question here for Hikaru where he
switches up with the queen well he's got
a lot of pleasant choices he could move
it to C2 eyeing that E4 Pawn as well he
could move it to the open file and it
looks like suddenly the ball is in
hikaru's court he's completely in
control of the position look at Magnus
he now seems very annoyed
yeah he's uh flustered he's realizing
that things are turning Hikaru with such
a Time Advantage is going to turn the
screw he's going to try and put some
pressure on no chance the hikar is just
trying to lock this down and go for a
draw now he realizes uh the initiative
is on his side he's the one creating
threats and not so easy this type of
position for let's play although if
hikar runs all the way over to the queen
side don't forget about this Pawn push
in front of magnus's King he could still
push that pawn for it and expose the
white king that doesn't have too many
Defenders so both sides have to look
across the board not get tunnel vision
and I do think that that's why hikar was
thinking at the moment he doesn't want
to bring his Queen over to A2 because of
those ideas and amazes you know Bishop
sacrifice at some moment if you're
really feeling adventurous but the point
is that car needs to be careful right
now he is ahead on the clock but Magnus
is a beast in all time controls
including bullet he's not going to flag
and he's going to keep posing problems
yeah the question now is which piece is
worse this Knight on the rim or this
bishop locked in in the corner behind
its own Pawn they kind of balance each
other out but long term you've got to
ask yourself that and uh wow he does go
to the edge of the board Hikaru that
feels like the wrong direction remember
we don't want the queen too far divorced
from her King because that will spell
trouble if the opponent can attack you
uh no Defenders now around that white
king and uh is this the moment for
Magnus to go for it to push this Pawn
break open the king side he says no he
shuffles his coin across preventing any
uh Knight jumps into his camp and Hikaru
looks very very excited bringing his
Queen in now I think Magnus has to start
going for it before it's too late it
feels like things are turning and look
at this he's actually lined up the queen
and the bishop and is eyeing that G3
Bond David there could be a potential
sacrifice on G3 now white has to watch
out for yeah big move if you can land
that sacrifice and get the black queen
into the position uh White takes a step
back now it's less attractive doesn't
come with track but uh Magnus now trying
to lock this game down he's forcing all
the trades on the b-file we'll see an
end game and uh here we go it's Bishop
Bishops against Bishop Knight but end
games can be very difficult for white
because at some moment black will be F6
and G5 and try to Spring free an outside
pass Pawn so for now it may seem level
the eval bar is telling us as that's the
case but the Knight can be corralled by
the Bishops and then at some point you'd
like to go for a pass Pawn on the king
side so I think if your car you want to
trade some pieces if you could trade the
Knight for the light score Bishop
immediately the game is a draw opposite
called Bishops even if it costs you a
pawn so that's why Magnus he's just
causing hikara some problems he's going
after this Pawn C4 maybe he'll kick the
knight at some point his King can March
forward yep let's go back to the players
uh Hikaru looks ready to get out of
there will they wow I think they just
agreed to a draw and it did look as
Robert predicted like a set of Bishops
were coming off the board no more
winning chances uh so results after a
half full game wow does that mean that
Hikaru offered a draw in this position
it looks that way I think the Bishops
were about to come off and uh Magnus
looking through the game now I think
he's about to realize that he missed a
win or missed a very very strong
opportunity and there we go shakes his
head computer confirms it to him wow
this is definitely that moment that he
realizes that it was a big opportunity
when he played that king move and that
would have really turned the tide in his
favor he looks very disappointed right
now with what has happened and it's the
second game in a row remember he's
missed two big big opportunities and
within one move Hikaru is fine and
guides it to safety and that can be so
frustrating David very frustrating he
needs to get over that needs to forget
that he's actually outplayed Hikaru for
phases of these first two games uh still
everything to be decided yeah and they
now have 10 minutes before game three
magnets will have the white pieces in
that game and in this one where was that
Mr chanson missed opportunities David
yeah it was just the one move it was
very very temporary but uh Magnus did
miss the moment he replied instantly and
uh he did regret it as we saw on the
camera a moment ago it it was here that
Hikaru played a bit of a careless move
he brought his Bishop in this is uh
tempting it's very understandable very
human you want to block the defile this
bishop is very annoying to get rid of
for black but Magnus missed that just
this one moment he could slide his Queen
back hitting this white rook in the
corner and suddenly nowhere good to run
for this white Rook if you run across
the board preventing a move will show in
a moment then suddenly you just drop a
pawn the blackfrook will happily take
this Pawn
material advantage and a winning
position instead if you defend this Pawn
if you keep it defended then Bishop to
C3 does pose a big problem for this
white Rook suddenly this white Rook is
tied down it doesn't have too many
squares to go to and this bishop will be
lost for example if it tries to come up
the board then you can overwhelm this
bishop due to a pin on the default
guaranteed to win material at least a
rook for Bishop and Magnus would have
guided this to Victory
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
air things is the presenting partner for
this tournament and
out of great air quality but you're not
a subscriber on Twitch here is a twitch
break
[Music]
I'm joined in the studio by Adam from
everything so it's the presenting
partner for the tournament and has been
a great friend of the Champions chess
tour from the very beginning I mean what
is it about air things and chests that
just goes so great together good
question
um
air things is a Norwegian tech company
I'm working with the kind of racing the
awareness out in the world around the
importance of good air quality and with
Magnus Carlsen being Norwegian and the
world's best chess player it was really
for us just a perfect partnership to be
used to to really bring the message out
there yeah
air pollution bad air quality and
um what do we know about the effect of
bad air quality to the brain
so air quality is extremely important
for our cognitive performance I guess
everyone has experienced sky and sitting
at work or being at school starting to
feel a bit drowsy getting that TV studio
and most likely this is due to poor
indirect quality aha so uh for cognitive
functions it's really CO2 not so carbon
dioxide and particulate matter which we
are showing live from some of our
partners ambassadors which is the most
important factors when it comes to
cognitive problems yeah and and chess
being a sport where you're just so
depending on having a fresh brain it
must be the perfect example of having
the importance of having good indoor air
quality yeah and that's what we're
seeing throughout the everything's
Masters now that some I mean like take
Magnus as an example
he started out with really high CO2
levels which is kind of unusual for him
his last year he played with green
levels throughout the whole tournament
um but when he now moved to Canada
usually plays in Oslo he started out the
tournament with some red levels and he
did some blunders in the third game
yesterday with high CO2 levels which is
kind of unusual
I think we have an example to actually
show that okay so
red levels for Magnus Carlsen has
everything's device showing this in the
start and then he opens a window and it
turns green yes and we have seen that
several times now I mean so this is from
Monday
uh oh this is actually from from Tuesday
after a blundered in the third third
game so so he blundered the air quality
was bad yeah he opens the window takes
the fresh air it's re-energized and
ready for the next game wow and it
actually helps that is fantastic and we
do see a bunch of symbols on this screen
as well I've actually seen in both the
twitch chat and on Twitter a bunch of
viewers wondering what does all these
symbols mean
so the first one is CO2 so that's carbon
dioxide so we breathe in oxygen and we
breathe out CO2 so poorly ventilated
space increase then you get increased
CO2 levels so humidity is the amount of
humidity in the air
um Can Read really irritations in your
throat or other factors then it's
particular matter which Stefan talked
about yesterday
which is pollution basically and then
it's temperature erroneous temperature
VOC is chemicals in the air and then you
have radon so radon gas leading leading
cause for lung cancer for the
non-smokers and then it's barometric
pressure
all right so all of these uh symbols all
of this uh
ways of measuring air quality
um how much are we learning about air
quality over the last few years with
also air things and how important it is
with also after the pandemic so many
people uh you know having home office
and sitting in their homes just how
important it is sitting at home
um is seen that a lot of people are
sitting at home with extremely poor air
quality but now it's also people getting
back to work and they don't want to get
back to work if the virus risks or the
risk of viruses spread is also high so
we're using our sensors to really
make people comfortable and confident
that they can get back to work and it's
safe yeah and we do see actually
magnesium all since the air quality
sitting in Canada he has had some missed
opportunities today it's not perfect his
air quality and we actually you
mentioned Stefan a professor that we had
on the show yesterday who explained to
us that uh doing a study they found that
the chances of making blunders in chess
Rose by 26 when players had really bad
air quality have you guys and
everything's been surprised by these
finds
uh yeah yeah we've been surprised that
they're so um so strong correlation
between the particulate levels and um
and being able making blunders and chess
um and you can see that now from among
this is numbers he was up at 11 and
Stefan talked about if you cross 10 you
increase his chances with 26 percent uh
or making a nervous move so I think even
Magnus needs to crank up his airplane
purifier now and basically so if you get
an error things device uh you realize
you have better bad air quality you do
some changes you can actually decrease
your chances of making blunders for
example in chess by quite a lot of
percent
yeah and there is both well proven that
CO2 and particulate matter are really
impacting your chances of making the the
Right Moves yeah in chess and if you
don't have an air things device at home
but you want to get one well now is the
perfect uh time because there is a
special offer during the air things
Masters yeah so we'd have a hundred
dollars off on our way plus
um it and it has to be said that it was
yesterday there was so much traffic to
the side but we it was similar happened
to us that happened to chess.com in
January the site went down but I can
assure everyone decided is now open for
business fantastic airthings.com
uh both air things and chest is just so
popular right now uh so the site is
going crazy but go in there and get your
air things device to monitor air quality
in your home and we did ask a bunch of
the top players what is important for
them to perform in online chess
what kind of conditions do you rely on
to perform an online chess well you need
very good air quality huh and speaking
of which I probably need an update on
the on the air things device I really
try to keep it super relaxed day
generally I would wake up a little bit
later really go for a long walk that's
what I would do during those online
tournaments I've become very
very conscious of the air quality uh
like whenever like I'm playing online if
it's a tournament or another tournament
like if I start to feel like my head is
not
really clear and then very often I can
just look at the device and I say oh
that's why it's mostly about taking rest
because you have to be fresh
now it's a little bit preparing and yeah
for me it was sticking I was trying to
adapt even before the tournament trying
to get to the schedule and that
definitely helped I mean for me this is
the most important I think just having
the time to you know prepare and just to
get in the right mood sometimes I would
start really badly in the first day and
then make the adjustments and then come
back plenty of exercise
need good sleep but also online you need
a very good internet connection need a
good mouth and
a lot of practice a lot of training and
all those little things add up together
how cool to hear that also the players
are paying attention to having good air
quality it's important when playing in
the Champions Chester when often they
will be sitting at home Magnus Carlsen
is in Canada Hikaru Nakamura is uh
sitting somewhere with his family this
is game three they are tied after the
first two games and the winner is final
minus with the white pieces here we go
yep Magnus with the white pieces
switching up the openings no more ready
opening now it's well a bit of a
surprise the BOGO Indian black giving a
check early on in Hikaru smiling is this
a uh surprise he's prepared or is this
uh is he smiling for other reasons it's
unclear what do we think of this one
Robert well hakara does he said it's
many times he does like to look at the
call the video call to see his
opponent's reaction so I don't think
this was expected from Magnus so I think
Hikaru he gives a little bit of a laugh
he's doing it for the audience he said
yesterday he does some things for the
content uh but you know from a chess
perspective this must be uncomfortable
from Magnus Carlson he spoiled his
advantage in the first game with the
white pieces it was never maybe easily
winning but he was in an end game where
he could have won a pawn in game two he
missed a clear opportunity that we saw
on camera he was upset when he went over
the game uh in analysis so I feel like
for Magnus he's looking at this game as
a not a must win but as one he needs to
press his car in and A3 this is topical
yeah and uh just for a moment Magnus was
laughing as well someone even popped in
in the background and Magnus like shoot
them away so I think you're right Robert
he's the both of them keeping an eye on
the video call and something was
happening but uh Magnus would definitely
want to put pressure on with the white
pieces and
um this one I've always thought was a
bit controversial this opening it has a
decent reputation for black solid enough
but maybe objectively slightly uh dodgy
because black does have doubled b-pawns
at least did but now after this last
porn trade white has one porn Island a
massive pawns that can connect can link
up and start advancing down the board
black has two point Islands they're
separated the A and B Pawns our uh yeah
there's a there's an island there's a
how do you say this I'm trying to think
of geography classes with this little
kind of gap between these two islands
but uh yeah I either way it's uh not
ideal for black the structure yeah I
would agree with you and it's
interesting because Hikaru is the one
who sprung this well sort of a surprise
for Magnus going for the BOGO Indian but
this is so thematic breaking with that a
pawn opening up the a file keeping your
Pawn Island intact but breaking up black
spawn structure and the A7 Pawn is often
Under Fire now the move B6 that has been
made by Hikaru it of course is a
development on the B7 Square for the
bishop but a lot of times in the middle
game we'll see Hikaru also trying to
push that a pawn to A5 uh to keep it
defended so that the Rook can get free
and uh interesting decision there but
Hikaru has also taken a little time
deciding with the trade so I was
slightly surprised with that with him
not blitzinger his moves as fast as I
was expecting yeah maybe he was
surprised by the early A3 Push by Magnus
but it made perfect sense he's just
freeing up his B1 Knight that pawn on B4
was an absolute pest I like the one Pawn
Island that you're mentioning David so I
think that for Magnus he can just use
Simple development and for Karu because
he has the split pawns right the
multiple Islands he's just gonna have to
figure out what to do will he strike
forward with D7 to D5 that feels like a
very tempting move to claim space but
that Rook on A3 is particularly active
and you may see white double up Rooks
eventually along the a-file once you
Castle yeah even line up the queen in
the corner on this a file to go for
targets um yeah very flexible it's early
days no forcing lines here but who
understands the structures this position
better I think that would be the
question white has now just castled and
we are now in the middle game
yeah it definitely feels like Magnus
Carlson has been the one putting the
pressure on dictating the pace of the
games but uh Hikaru here can he somehow
find a structure that doesn't allow
Magnus that type of uh enjoyment that
type of activity that he's had so far
it's all about action today and it's
also a little bit about Pokemon yeah
because we've sorry guys my fault we now
know David is a huge Pokemon fan a
question to you David from bag Senpai on
Twitter
to which GMS would you relate to first
generation starters in Pokemon Bulbasaur
Charmander and Squirtle squirrel
I would say who breeds fire and uh
Alexis Shiro yeah Lexi shirov would be
Charmander nice breathing fire all over
the board
um who's water maybe who Cara Nakamura
just uh he's such a great defender he
would put that fire out and uh Bulbasaur
who's uh more Earthly who's more I need
help here Wesley so maybe Wesley so yeah
yeah very Earthly guy very uh likable
yeah can of course evolve into a beast
if he wants to be but it doesn't
necessarily need to in order to attack
the opponents that's a good description
so we have it Bulbasaur Wesley so
Mora
I'm just glad that I wasn't called a
Pokemon I feel like I was giving other
names so that he wouldn't turn me you're
like a little Bulbasaur over there I
always thought Snorlax was my uh spirit
animal just to sleep all the time yeah I
always liked Psyduck oh yeah
you could do this all day
meanwhile Magnus has jumped in with his
Knights uh really creative move I guess
he's at least hinting that he's going to
offer a bunch of exchanges a bunch of
Trades because he does have the more
harmonious porn structure long-term
white is doing very well as we mentioned
and if this Knight is kicked away it can
happily step back and challenge that
Black Knight on B4 on The Outpost uh so
interesting move how will Hikaru react I
don't think he needs to commit anything
now he doesn't doesn't necessarily need
to uh Kick That Knight back it will
Retreat sooner or later
well the plans that black has in this
position is upon Advance you either want
to challenge White's Center moving that
Queen's pawn two steps ahead and asking
why to take a decision or go ahead with
what I what I had mentioned earlier
David advancing that A7 Pawn to A5 so
just make sure that that Knight on B4 is
super defended and now your idea of
bringing back the Knight to D3 you can
very often just leave that night on B4
and you don't even care you can just
slide your Rook all the way to see it
and that's a nice trick because you're
hitting the C4 pawn and it white now
trades on B4 big blunder ends up with a
fork of the rook and the night yeah big
mistake here and the game will turn in
Black's favor so what is Hikari gonna
choose this one the more look at it the
more I like it Tanya uh just kind of
keeping options open I don't think you
should rush to kick away this Knight
because you might push your pawn two
squares forward later instead and white
wants to retreat anyway as part of the
plan to evict this piece from his half
and uh yeah either way it feels like you
need to get organized maybe push a pawn
maybe just bring the queen forward open
up a line for your Rooks to connect to
swing over to the C file feels like
that's where the Rooks belong but he
does go for your move he goes for it and
I like it and this is a very thematic
idea in the BOGO Indian where you really
want to take advantage of that B4 Square
it's really the only compensation that
you've created of separating your bonds
of creating these weakened Bond Islands
so A5 played keeping that flexibility
with the Queen's Pawn you might go to D6
you might go to D5 depending on what
magnus's approach will be I think this
game three is also a lot about
psychology right now because Magnus is
definitely feeling that slight
frustration of not having converted
these two advantageous positions going
into game three he realizes that Hikaru
is up to the task of defending this
match his resourcefulness his resilience
is on point in this one and it can kind
of create this frustration within so is
it going to be a more Angry magnet or is
he just going to you know be it's fine I
created my chances it means I'm the one
who is the better player today what do
you think is going on in his mind right
now he looks a little bored and that's
because the position is completely
locked up so there's no Pawn tension no
trades being offered and he's just
trying to kind of map out the future of
the position that Rook that took the
pawn on A3 right now at some point I
think it should slide back I've seen
this in variations of this nature where
it's done its job it captured upon it
kept White's Pawn structure intact let's
bring it back home at the right moment
but then what like I just see little
moves here and there that B2 Pawn can
slide up one square good for you you
protect everything what is the active
plan I think that's what Magnus really
wanted out of game three he's kind of
like Zapdos he wants to control the
electricity on the board sometimes his
hair also looks like uh you know he I
could say that because my hair often
looks like that but he is just trying to
control the State of Affairs in the
chessboard and right now it just seems
like Hikaru surprised him and now is
playing very energetic chess himself
yeah do either of you guys play the BOGO
Indian yourselves that's one opening
I've never touched actually is black I
mean a lot with white and I do
I do Indian I
white spawn structures so intact and it
feels like even this move A5 like you
were talking about it gives activity it
also creates weaknesses in Black scam uh
watch out for that B5 Square the White
Knight can jump on to B5 at the right
moment I kind of like playing against
the BOGO end there but I have to make
sure that my opponent does not Hikaru
normally good advice avoided Curry
in these tournaments he's a beast and uh
yeah Magnus now thinking he's been
thinking for a while still nothing too
drastic on the clock but uh it's certain
that uh he'll be watching out for his
air quality there we see looking very
healthy uh no excuses if things do go
wrong it definitely feels like uh I
don't know I'm gonna use soccer as an
analogy but uh he's had two penalty
kicks and the goalies saved them both
times and her car has saved them both
and yes the frustration doesn't tend to
affect Magnus he's very good at bouncing
back but if he doesn't win this game if
he doesn't even create any real chances
then he won't feel great uh facing
Hikaru with black in the final game of
the day
and uh who do you think would be the
favorite in Armageddon that's a good
question I mean I hope we get that I
think we all want to see this match
really go down the line to an Armageddon
and witness that it's so hard to pick a
favorite against Magnus and Hikari these
are undoubtedly the world's best players
in speeches I mean we're talking about
the top two they're on in A League of
Their Own so David a hard call and I
don't know who's going to be a favorite
I'll tell you one thing though
I think a car is a better Flagger
that is true yeah with my boyfriend yeah
hikar has the better Mouse speed I would
say in those critical moments and he
just has played I think just the most
online chess so that's his biggest
Advantage but uh when there are fewer
games that favors a car because Magnus
is the stronger player of the two with
the longer time control there's not much
separating them but Magnus is the
stronger so I think that if we get to
Armageddon that means that it's kind of
like a toss-up at that point and we also
don't know who how low they're going to
bid because Wesley was like oh gosh I
should have bid lower than a car who
went nine minutes and 28 seconds what if
they both been like nine minutes this
time I don't think they'll dip below
that just because it's too little time
to work with but I can't call a favorite
because uh Magnus is refusing to even
make a move right now do you think
Hikaru would dare to go as low as he did
yesterday against Wesley when he bid 9
28 no I think that Wesley is very solid
and so you sort of can anticipate a
style from him Magnus as we've already
seen in game one and game two he already
built a lead on the clock in game two
and missed the chance in game one he had
the advantage so if a car didn't have
the time he did that game would have
gone magnus's way so I just don't think
I see either player really dipping below
10 minutes which is what Magnus said
yesterday yeah and it did seem that
Hikaru had more of a tactic in his
bidding he was sort of calculating how
low he can go Magnus a little bit more
random maybe when I think he bid 10
minutes and one second yeah like this
half does have a track record of not
really reading the rules not really
thinking ahead
um there was this famous case in Norway
chess where he didn't know the time
controlling he just let his clock run
down because he thought he was going to
get extra time he didn't he lost the
game so it definitely felt like Magnus
as he said in the interview thinking on
the Fly just uh picking up a random
number and uh going with it but yeah I
it feels like Hikaru would have plotted
uh plotted ahead planned something and
he will know his limits where he's uh
happy with I think it's going to be a
big fight to get the black pieces okay
both of them are gonna want it they'll
have to strike a balance between their
bed not to go too low on the clock as
well for getting those black pieces so
it's going to be interesting to see
their strategy right now I'm confused
about magnus's strategy in this one
though he's fallen back with the Knight
he's offering a night trade so clearly
the strongest piece in Black's Camp is
that night on B4 makes a lot of sense
but I have to say it feels a bit strange
to me this last move David Knight 282
yeah it does feel like an awkward Square
um if those nights are traded off then
okay it's done a job it's eliminated
that black knight but you're not
necessarily guaranteed to trade off that
night and maybe this White Knight on 80
will A2 will be sat there a couple of
moves longer and will be a bit awkward
to reroute and very often I'm sorry go
on no no I was there ending there I just
really like the move that we saw on the
board and and what I was wanting to just
bring up is that black doesn't need to
take a decision with that Knight on B4
very often because you can just leave it
there a trade there might look like wait
a second you're creating double bonds
but actually you're getting so much
counter play on that a file it opens up
your Rook or your queen will March down
the board and it just looks like black
gets enough compensation for the
weakness the apparent weakness with
these two pawns and that's what he's
done with this last move D6 just hitting
that other Knight I like hikaru's
approach so far in this game yeah it
feels like he's playing very well and
built up a time Advantage Robert earlier
and you said Magnus was refusing to move
and again uh after maybe the most
natural move for black uh he spent what
was that four minutes or so on this
night Retreat black replies hitting a
knight and he's back in the tank back
thinking he just doesn't have a clear
plan but I think in the long term what
he wants is let's say the Knight just
drops back to F3 we swap Knights on A2
really quickly I think that he wants
like B4 at the right moment and this
leave black saddled with an isolated B
Pawn so it's a bit of a long story but
he just wants to start trading pawns at
the right moment and say your your
remaining Pawn that's the weakness white
only has that one one Pond Island still
thank you David you did a great job of
putting the position I wanted on the
board and so black will have to defend
that pawn with pieces whereas White's
pollen structure is very healthy so
magnets he tends to look for these small
advantages and that's I think what he's
envisioning hikar is like no you're not
getting anything of the sword I'm not
going to allow you to have an advantage
for 20 moves 30 moves and pressure me I
think that eckhart's done a great job
out of the gates in game three yep
definitely and uh Magnus just has to
bite the bullet and Retreat maybe to
this Square maybe he goes back the other
way but either way he has to make a move
you can't afford to go three and a half
minutes down against Hikaru it's uh
backfired before he's missed
opportunities and we're actually going
to see the whole line that you mentioned
there Tanya Knight takes Knight on the
board I'm assuming black takes back this
way you could actually make an argument
for taking the other night potentially
Hikaru has paused so he's doing some
calculation but okay let's say black
goes down this line the most logical and
most natural we'll see a trade of Brooks
we'll see a trade of knights and after
dropping back I just love jump in with
the black queen and also let's point out
David that in fact white has to fall
back to F3 you can't even go to D3 to
put pressure on the B4 Pawn because you
can easily lose the G2 Pawn then with
the queen and the bishop lined up so an
easy Miss there but of course Magnus
will drop the Knight down to F3 and then
this is what we were talking about the
activity on the a file but let me ask a
question do you think that hikar
actually wants an imbalance so if he has
the option to get these double isolated
pawns but the activity or he can just
you know just start taking on E5 and
trading off some pieces what do you
think he's gonna aim for very good
question because actually uh this one
initially I thought was a more risky
Choice the more I look at it it's uh at
least forcing white if white wants to
keep some attention to drop back and we
could see a trade and it's very very
balanced suddenly both sides have uh two
Pawn Islands suddenly white has these
almost hanging pawns and easy access for
example if the black queen moves for the
Rooks to centralize you're right Robert
maybe this one if he's feeling safe
he'll go for this but the Rook on A3
would be happy yes
forklift they saw the uh the future with
that one but look what happened I mean
Tanya's line is on the board and all of
a sudden hikar's Queen is deep in enemy
territory but what about those double
isolated pawns that's the big question
yeah Tanya doing a little dance here
because you saw what was it five moves
into the future good work there five
moves each uh impressive stuff so double
isolated pawns for black but is it
enough Magnus now trying to offer a
queen trade without the queen so it's
gonna be much harder to Target those two
black pawns but uh I guess the Black
Wing was too active and needed to do
something about her needed to kick her
out yeah and now the Rook comes into the
a file as well and black is going to
have control of that you've got to watch
out for that B2 weakness it just looks
like this is the first game in the match
where Hikaru is not worse out of the
opening and in fact Magnus might have to
be slightly careful in this one
definitely it's all about momentum all
about the clock as well in Rapid chess
and those two seem to favor Hikaru right
now I love what Black's done with this
position gotta say easily his best game
thus far yes he showed some great
defensive resources some skill under
duress but he's kind of controlled this
game from the start and now he controls
the only open file on the board and
that's why we like Black's position that
said if he doesn't make use of the open
file imagine the queen and the Rooks
they're gone off the board that's how
black gets in trouble because some of
those end games without major pieces
that means that the pawns will be under
some threat and black does not have
anything to counter with so Knight D2
takes away the E4 square a good start
but I could see hikara just trading
Queens on B1 slamming The Rook down on
A2 after that and saying to Magnus all
right I'm gonna be the active one here
you'll have to prove that you could fed
me off yeah you can trade off these
Rooks as you say Robert just jump in
with the Rook this night I don't mind
where it's placed right now but it's
miles away from ever attacking this Pawn
this pattern with kind of on the
diagonal one square between them Knights
takes so far to jump around and uh go
for these weaknesses so it definitely
feels like your car is not in any
trouble you could also make an argument
for maybe trading off and now going for
a nitrate jumping in with the Black
Knight if the knights disappear as well
no danger at all these pawns are in dark
squares can never be hit by white Bishop
very smart here where'd he goes done he
starts with Knight E4 that is so precise
uh David because this doesn't give white
the option to get away with the Knight
to B3 the line that we were looking at
with the queen traits and let's just
bring that up because it's so
instructive this moment if you do the
same thing after trading off and B1 you
jump with your knight to E4 now Magnus
can move away can avoid that nitrate
with Knight to B3 eventually he'll also
push out black snide from E4 by
advancing that F Pawn The Rook can come
to A1 if your Rook lands on A2 you'll
have to move knight from B3 to C1
kicking it out also heading to D3
attacking that pawn on B4 so a lot of
Knight jumps sale which is why hey Carl
and this is just class I have to say to
start with the move Knight E4 and at
first it looks like wait a second there
are two pieces attacking it but what
black wants to do is that if you do
capture an E4 now he's going to pick up
the queen and then pick up the Knight he
solves the problem of the nitrate
because in on our live boat as we can
see white did not have the option to
escape with the Knight on B3 this is
precise play Hikaru Nakamura is on a
farm today yeah that's what separates
the top players from the rest of us
those little move order tricks those
little details that most of us are just
oblivious of we don't see them but the
top players they see these details they
uh make sure they're accurate on every
turn Magnus did avoid the queen trade
but uh once the knights come off the
board I don't really see any trouble
here for black for example you can just
slide the queen back you're defending
your Pawn The Rook might come in and uh
whose Pawn is weaker maybe it's actually
this white Pawn on B2 it's very hard to
evict The Black Queen but uh yeah
what else do you do if you're Magnus
Carson you have to agree to this
position and your Karu has a simple plan
can I try to be a prophet for a second
what if Bishop D1 here Queen takes C4
Bishop E2 we see a repetition like is
that possible somehow it is and also
let's point now you can't actually go to
D5 after that trying to threaten a mate
that David because big trouble here the
bishop jumps into F3 and watch out for
that Bishop on B7 yeah it feels like all
the arrows go on the long diagonal and
uh here white turns it in his favor
um so wow Robert that could well be
happening on the board and uh we should
point out that's in this position if you
don't have anywhere good to go with the
queen then simply this Pawn will drop
off so if you go back white repeats and
a little dance between the bishop and
queen could be a very logical end to
this game and I think Magnus will be
glad to get out of here actually in this
position Hikaru maybe has spotted that
and we'll be looking for more if he
wants to play on
what an intense match between these two
yeah we seem to say that all the time
because it genuinely is so close I've
never really see one-sided games uh
between these two it's just uh blue for
blue matching each other this is why we
love watching them play because we know
that we're in for a treat they're just
never disappoint the fans whether it's
rapid games or their Blitz even if it
goes into Armageddon we know that it's
gonna be Fighting Chess regardless of
the result we've seen two draws but the
result has not been reflective of the
kind of game that we've had it's been
big fights in the first two games and
this one is the first one where Magnus
is on the back foot wow and Roberts you
need to buy a lottery ticket you've just
predicted everything we do reach that
position and we might be about to see a
draw wow you are profit clip it ship it
the draw by repetition is about to be
agreed and that means we still have a
tied match Hikaru Nakamura with the
upper hand in game three he probably had
more chances than Magnus did but a draw
is the fair result and yeah I'll take
that one did you do this uh you know I
do love commenting with Daniel nerdinsky
and he's the prophet but I'm trying to
take his title from him I actually
remember this one time at the speed
Chess Championship when you know what
I'm gonna be talking about what I'm
talking about Robert just said which was
a blunder in one it just dropped the
feast and it was a blind side from him
but again the panditri and Magnus made
that exact same number at that exact
same moment it was the craziest stuff
that I've seen
just unbelievable yeah we're going to
the lottery ticket after this yeah and
it is a draw Hikari is out of there he's
off for a break off to refresh himself
and uh Magnus just checking over this
game figuring out where he missed an
opportunity where he went wrong the
answer is he didn't miss anything it was
just a very balanced draw three draws in
this match so
looking over this he is struggling to
find a way to beat tikaru Nakamura
there's going to be one more rapid game
in this match it's starting in a little
less than five minutes now Hikaru
Nakamura will have the white pieces if
we have a winner in that game that will
be the winner of the winners final the
one who makes it through to the Grand
Final if it is a draw then this match
will be decided in Armageddon is there
anything in this game that we should
take a look at David
um let's try let's try it okay nice it
was uh it was really instructive how
Hikaru just hovered off all the pieces
and kept a measure of control throughout
we mentioned in this position he had a
choice he could have captured this white
knight and uh maybe imbalanced it
slightly kept the game alive kept the
Queens Rooks on the board but he said no
he calculated very accurately that these
doubled bee pawns were well compensated
for uh by his dynamism his peace
activity we saw the Rooks leave the
board magnus's Knight had to step out of
the attack and this queen move every
move from here till the end was very
accurate from both sides we saw an offer
of a queen trade Hikaru said no not for
you I'm uh opening well conquering this
open file and after a few moves again
this really precise move order that
Tanya mentioned dropping the Knight into
E4 far more accurate than any Queen
trade than any Rook trade and uh The
Logical end of the game was this one a
little dance between the bishop and
queen the queen has nowhere to go other
than to take this Pawn if it wants to
defend B4 and uh that status quo
continues for the remaining moves a
repetition to end the game but a federal
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
the action continues uh very shortly
we're gonna dig it into all the action
happening in the air things monsters if
you're not the subscriber on Twitch
though here is a twitch break
[Music]
action between Hikaru Nakamura and
Magnus Carlson and the winners final
here in division two remember there is
also division two and division three in
the air things monsters
you're looking at that as well Ivanka
what's happening especially in division
two where we know the winner of division
two qualifies for division one and event
two yeah when it comes to the winners
brackets then uh Fabi Carona and also Yu
Yang Yi they will be facing off against
each other right in the winners final
and the most interesting piece of news
is actually in the losers bracket there
it's quite spectacular
Vladimir kremlic is having the time of
his life because first of all he took
out Jan napomniachi wow there you go
very convincing school and then he also
took up Matthias Bloom balm so he will
also be playing again tomorrow so
Vladimir kramnik former world champion
he is uh
playing some good chess in division two
and could go all the way could go I know
and we can't wait for that actually wow
wow so that's division two we're keeping
a close eye on that as well everyone but
isn't happening between nicar and
Nakamura and Magnus Carlsen one rapid
game to go they are tied what do you
expect from that final rapid battle
shall I give you my unpopular opinion
yeah yeah okay well I I think the
players will agree a quick draw do you
yes because Hikaru has track record you
know yesterday against Wesley so he
agreed a very quick draw it was that
famous Berlin draw and he just wanted to
get to the Armageddon and the two
actually did the same in 2021 when they
faced offic against each other and the
score was level Hikaru Magnus happy to
take it to Armageddon
and even if a quick draws is uh you know
unpopular opinion Armageddon between
these two would simply be fantastic I
would be insane wouldn't it would just
be absolutely red hot
um I like the panel I'm actually
completely undecided who is the better
player because hicario Magnus are just
the players who were just in the League
of Their Own no one else matches them
and I have to agree with Tanya if it
comes down to the clock I do feel that
Hikaru is the one who possibly could
flag Magnus all right more action to
come in this one game four between
Magnus and Hikaru is coming up very
shortly
this is game three they are tied after
the first two games and the winner is
final
I think we do we reach that position and
see a draw the draw by repetition is
about to be agreed and that means we
still have a tied match
we certainly do it is tied three draws
but a lot of entertainment between
Magnus and Hikari so far today one more
rapid game
to go Hikaru with the white pieces in
this one and here we go if we have a
winner in this game that will be the
winner of the winners final if it is a
draw then Armageddon is coming off you
guys what will happen here we go here we
go and do we have two profits in the
studio will your Banker be correct it is
the Spanish opening will Magnus reply
with the Berlin and uh will that draw
happen on the board Magnus is pausing if
he doesn't bring out the Black Knight on
the king side now we're guaranteed a
game this one uh is not going to fizzle
out anytime soon uh Magnus here is going
for his favorite uh reply to the Spanish
opening he often allows the martial
attack he goes for the martial attack
it's a Gambit here and uh Hikari smiled
what do we think that smile was about
still a well-known theoretical position
white has won a pawn it's one of those
disadvantages of playing in the World
Chess Championship everybody studies
your games everybody studies your
openings and here Hikaru says all right
let's go into this well-trodden path we
see that black is now threatening a
check on H2 the bishop and the queen
line up it's not quite Checkmate but it
will not be good for white to allow so
this often is met by the pawn in front
of the king pushing forward to blunt
that Bishop's axis towards the king side
but in these types of positions we saw
Peter leco and Vladimir krumnik they
played this in their world championship
match very famously uh it's a dynamic
position black has given up a pawn but
gets a ton of activity and some attacks
against the white king yeah and it's
strange to see Hikaru post to think I
thought it was automatic that you pushed
that point in front of your king one
square the G Pawn to block the attack to
gain some time against the black queen
Hikaru must be uh contemplating his
moves after that white does have a bunch
of options some are more testing than
others some just fizzle out towards
equality some you might be a pulling up
but black will have long-term strategic
and maybe even Dynamic compensation uh
but uh hiko reflecting that just uh
picking his poison uh choosing which
line to go for
there is only one line you have to make
the move G3 because after H3 that's a
super soft spot and there are often
sacrifices that happen with which Bishop
takes H3 so you don't want to allow that
uh equally surprised that he hasn't
played G3 yet but Hikaru is definitely
looking ahead right now the Marshall has
taken him by surprise now this is the
last rapid game between these two and a
result would mean that one advances one
goes to the loser's bracket how much
risk are each of them willing to take in
this game and my feeling would be not
too much but magnus's opening going with
the Marshall does imply that he's ready
for a fight and not going for those
opening drawers Berlin draws these
options that he has which I think a guy
would have been happy to go with and we
do have a move G3 Queen H3 on the board
yeah I don't know Tanya these days the
top players they play the Marshall for a
draw it's known to be very solid despite
the fact you've sacrificed a pawn white
has this extra pawn and often we see for
example the White Queen come over and
offer a trade later on the Queens might
disappear and uh there are lines such as
this one where the White Queen steps
back and at some point black just takes
back the pawn we go down to an end game
and you can test the opponent there but
it will be a draw there are many other
popular moves in this current position
uh bringing the white Rook forward was
very popular when I was younger uh
sliding The Rook across potentially to
hit this queen to evict it from the
white camp and uh of course other
options available too that's a Hikaru
thinking if you want to fight in this
position rookie 4 is the main move with
this idea to go Rook to H4 is what you
really want to do in this position and
then one of the replies that black has
is to already fall back with the queen
to F5 here which is the most popular
response if Hikaru chooses to go with
the other idea that you mentioned Queen
to F3 it would imply that he is playing
it well very practically and doesn't
want to take too many chances so if
Queen after he's on the board we know
what Hikaru is happy with yeah he's
pausing though it's uh strange it's
confusing Robert it's really surprising
given that he played E4 went into
Spanish it's not the first time he's
ever seen the Marshall so he's probably
trying to remember his variation this is
a dangerous opening let's say the White
Queen slides up to F3 trying to
safeguard the king and the bishop comes
into G4 to attack the Queen the queen
slides back we're down to pawn we are
not trading Queens the queen goes back
to H5 and suddenly their threads like
Bishop going into F3 or the H3 the white
king does not feel very safe and that's
why Hikaru brings his Rook up to E4 uh
he finally makes a move and look at
Magnus he quickly responds with Knight
F6 challenging that Rook on its place
and The Rook slides to H4 the queen runs
away and now that Rook is really oddly
placed G7 to G5 push pushing that pawn
in front of your king can be an option
in some positions that Rook is almost
trapped over there the white king
doesn't have many Defenders I worry for
Hikaru but I also feel like he is
remembering his preparation he's not in
completely new territory yeah it depends
on his mindset as well if he was coming
into this game Thinking okay safety
first let's just lock this down maybe
even make a quick draw then he does need
to switch things up now he does need to
switch away from that and at least play
the most principled moves you're not
gonna see this game uh end in a draw
anytime soon there's no Safety First
approach now he steps his Pawn forward
getting ready to retreat along this
diagonal with his Bishop very very
cunning move but uh yeah it depends on
Hikaru it looks like he's composed
himself after a few minutes doing the
right thing just pausing maybe taking a
deep breath and now it's a completely
different type of game I'm still curious
whether this is opening preparation or a
bit of a bluff but either way it seems a
decent try for white still a pawn up
pressure on Magnus Carlsen to justify
that sacrifice well D4 the last move by
Hikaru is not the most common move in
this position what usually continues
with the development of the knight from
B1 to D2 and the D3 Pawn
helps that Knight to land on that
Central E4 Square so D4 is definitely
going to take Magnus by a little bit of
a surprise and he'll have to try and
think how he wants to counter this
threat of the bishop moving back that
you pointed at and then that Knight
eventually Landing up on e4 remember
that white is upon up the more pieces
that get traded it does suit Hikaru and
that's what he wants to do he wants to
try and trade off as many pieces as
possible to make sure that the main
compensation that black has which is an
attack peace activity as we can see that
Bishop on D6 the queen is out a rook
will land on the open file on E8 it does
get neutralized you need to trade pieces
here with with white yeah very sensible
move and Magnus pausing you would think
that as part of his world championship
preparation he studied this a few times
or at least this variation he's gone in
depth with engines with coaches uh I
know the Marshall Gambit was his main
repertoire in 2016 against karyakin
who's his main repertoire last year
against janapongishi and uh yeah it's
ought to see Hikaru or surprise him so
early Magnus and Jan Gustafson who is a
martial expert has also been in magnus's
team for so many years so all that
knowledge that Magnus has off the
Marshall definitely comes uh from Jan as
well so shout out to Yan it's one of
those situations though where Magnus
might have forgotten more than I've ever
learned you know he's in a position now
that is tricky he's down upon his
compensation is on the light squares and
against the white king but upon is upon
us they say and if he's not careful he
may not find full compensation
sufficient compensation for the
materials and I think that's what Magnus
is trying to figure out is uh can he try
to open up his light Square Bishop maybe
on the A8 H1 diagonal all the way across
the board he and keto that piece or will
he slide oh I didn't even get to finish
my Ascend he does slide The Rook to E8
as Tanya was suggesting trying to use
the open file to his Advantage but I'm
starting to see how the players are
reacting after the initial opening stage
and I have to think that Hikaru should
be the happier of the two right now and
where do you move with that Queen uh
David it's a big question Bishop C2 I
really like that move that you suggested
The Rook is already on H4 eyeing that
it's seven square so always be wary of
that yes you have a knight which is
defending it right now but you need to
watch out for threats against it after
Bishop C2 do you put the queen on the
centralized D5 square is that what
Magnus wants yeah let's let's uh let's
give Magnus the opportunity to answer
because I'm not sure either I only see
two safe squares or maybe three safe
squares for that black queen not many uh
squares to retreat to and let's jump in
to try and figure out what he's about to
do as we see his awesome air quality
still very healthy stuff okay he makes
the decision before we can get there he
does land it in the center are we gonna
see a repetition again are we gonna see
Bishop B3 Queen F5 Bishop C2 it is
happening it is happening Robert said it
it has to are we heading to Armageddon
we are heading home again
Robert The Profit
well miss Rhymes there we have it it wow
another draw between Magnus and Hikaru
for draws and that means the Winner's
final will be decided in armor get on
between the two online bosses Hikaru and
Magnus we have to be excited about that
Robert yeah I think Magnus can be
excited because he's sort of thinking
for a while there it felt like the
pressure was on especially considering
game three did not go his way despite
the draw so Magnus heads to Armageddon
of course all the fans say free chess
let's go and Magnus is still sitting by
the computer do you think he is now
starting to make some tactics Tanya to
find out what he's gonna bid he is
thinking about that big bid I think it
really comes down to both players
wanting the black pieces uh but what
time how much time are they willing to
sacrifice to really get that is the big
question I think this last game made it
pretty clear that both didn't want to
take too much risk with so much at stake
and said you know what let's just uh get
that Armageddon going let's not forget
we've got two streamers fighting against
each other do it for the content yeah uh
Robert you're the expert on all
regulations what will happen now with
the bidding okay the players will bid
they will submit a number and the side
that has the higher number of the two
gets 15 minutes as their base time and
the side with the lower number gets that
amount of time will likely choose the
black pieces and get draw odds if the
game ends in a draw that means the
player with the black pieces moves on to
the Grand Final all right so David
what's your expectations what will be
the bids who will bid the the lowest
time it's going to be a serious bidding
war actually Hikaru he I think half
jokingly yesterday in his interview said
he might go very low against Magnus
because he's desperate to get black
um so I think he's going to go around
the nine uh nine and a half minute Mark
just like yesterday all right it will be
revealed shortly you guys Armageddon is
coming up the action continues in the
winners final
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chest but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck okay kind of
square to place the dog
[Music]
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the coins King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it I think this works oh
that's a horrible blunder oh my God I
just blundered so I have to move
something else first then dark and
Knight will take my king this is the
best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is a fast time winning
duck chest That's so exciting oh no no
no no no no slip no no no no no no I won
and duck chess champion give me those
points baby
quack quack so much fun happening on
chess.com if you're not a subscriber on
chesscom uh twitch then here is the
twitch break
foreign
[Music]
how could it be anything other than
Armageddon right do you think they're
both looking forward to that yeah I
reckon that Hikaru has probably thought
about it quite deeply he's come with a
game plan and uh we'll see you know what
he has in store especially when it comes
to the time bits yeah you uh brought
with you an awesome puzzle for the
viewers today Ivanka and it's time to
reveal the answer yeah I have to say to
everyone I mean what an amazing try
everyone actually got into it and they
solved quite a bit of it but uh very few
people solved the whole puzzle because
as I mentioned there are loads and
twists and turns okay so it looks like a
straight up Pawn race it's white to move
white pushes the Deep pawn and there you
go one step forward black does the same
or of course and now here was the
pitfall the pitfall was you must not
promote to a queen because if you
promote there the the pawn will actually
promote as well to a queen and then this
is the crunch point that once the queen
comes to give check and you think hey
this is going to be an easy win the king
is going to protect the queen but the
answer is no the king can actually
capture the pawn on B3 and after Queen
takes Queen it is the dreaded stale mate
so this was a big twist number one so
you could not promote to a queen so
let's go back to this position and so in
this one loads of people got this one
right it was a very neat idea that you
promote to a bishop
and then the whole point is that after
the pawn does promote to a queen you can
give that check in safety and the King
takes Pawn isn't that scary because this
bishop takes Queen no cell mate for you
today and uh but then there was another
twist so let's go back and this is where
I feel like this is like part one and
then there's part two because after D7
it wasn't actually compulsory for black
to go running with the a pawn he could
actually trap and play King takes pawn
and uh if you were to promote to a queen
that would also be a big because after
porn moves to A2 and the queen comes out
to just defend against their promotion
of that pawn black would promote
anywhere anyway and after Queen takes
Queen stalemate once more
so
here it is
and this is so so cool in this
particular position white promotes to a
rook so we've had like the bishop under
promotion now we've got the Rook under
promotion and now the coolest line here
is if the black king steps forward to A2
this is so nice and then the race begins
so David is going to put those boots and
then the Rook Gets behind the pawn and
here it comes porn promotes Rook takes
queen king takes work
white actually runs with the pawn
nothing for it and here comes the final
promotion promotion to a queen
I know we've had the bishop we've had
the rook and now we've got the queen and
then the whole point once black promotes
to a queen oh dear
Queen comes to C2 and it is Czech made
and this is the kind of puzzle that
gives you a Big Thrill when you solve it
you get this kind of ah Eureka moment
you share it with your friends and it's
just a fantastic study by vitelli
kovalenko fantastic wow what a puzzle
that was difficult twists and turns and
we do have a winner of someone solving
this puzzle that will get a signed
everything's device signed by Magnus
Carlsen and who is the winner the winner
is GG solving this very difficult puzzle
I have to say with so many twists and
turns congratulations on everything's
device is coming for you Magnus Carlsen
he's gonna need some good air quality
right now because Armageddon is coming
up and it's a big year for Magnus
Carlson he says 2023 will be a lot about
online chess
if you could list your three goals that
you pulled to achieve in 2023. Magnus
Carlson is looking ahead to yet another
year with exciting chess but first let's
go back to 2022. I would say on the
board it was mostly Pretty good overall
I think it was one of my better years
but off the board it was turbulent times
first Magnus announced he would give up
his classical world championship title
and then there was a big Scandal when he
accused Hans Neiman of cheating causing
Neiman to sue Carlson what was all of
that like no it's uh comes with you know
experience that I'm able to to focus
pretty well even though things are are
happening around me and having a lot of
strength tournaments to play is always
so nice distraction from everything else
he definitely seemed focused at the
board as the 32 year old finished the
Year by winning back the rapid and Blitz
world championship titles was relief a
part of what you felt there heading into
a year where you will give away your
your classical title the timing is
perfect like if there was one time that
I really that I really wanted those
titles with me now yeah it just gave me
gaming joy and like still when I I think
about it
makes me smile uh it was a really great
moment
the world's best chess player wants more
of in 2023
you know to play and have fun
I feel like that's true more than in a
long time especially now that
I have these rapid Blitz World titles
now I can just collect some have fun I
think I look at it at least sometimes a
little more philosophically let me
borrow that you know if I have a bad
event I have a bad event then I'll head
back in the next one
number one is to win a game with 1v3
okay and second is to have fun and the
third one is to win the game from
-10 position that's for the tour
cool right Magnus Carlsen with some nice
goals for 2023. I love the minus 10
position yeah yeah that would be fun to
watch yeah the other two I think he's
accomplished so maybe now it's time for
resolution number three all right well
Armageddon is coming up
and let's reveal the bids from Hikaru
and Magnus look at that Hikaru has been
eight minutes and 59 seconds beaten by
one second Magnus Carlsen spinning eight
minutes and 58 seconds and this is
hikaru's reaction when that bid came in
Magnus has chosen to play of course with
the black pieces Hikaru will have 15
minutes with the white pieces he has to
win it Hikaru Nakamura Magnus Carlsen
with eight minutes and 58 seconds needs
a draw to win the match I can't believe
what we just saw winning the bid by one
second and this just shows how well the
two players know each other we've got
liftoff and how much they wanted the
black piece is bidding that low Robert
and I completely understand From
magnus's perspective because he wasn't
put under so much pressure when he had
the black pieces so he's saying I don't
feel like I am worse I don't feel like
I'm gonna lose give me those draws wow
what's your reaction David uh I'm a bit
shocked I'm a bit gobsmacked having less
than nine minutes against Hikaru
Nakamura having a six minute deficit and
the black pieces it's not going to be
easy it is Magnus of course but I think
we'll see some serious flagging if
Hikaru can't win on the position which
is quite likely quite possible we've had
four draws the one thing's for sure that
this one is going to be a result so
Hikaru has to win on demand he's got the
white pieces he's up on the clock by a
big margin Magnus Carlton needs just to
draw and the moment you say that
sentence is kind of hard to believe it's
hard to believe that you can fight this
but you can see what hikar is doing he's
playing a very closed position because
he wants to do what David is suggesting
he wants to be a dirty Flagger he wants
to win on the clock not on the board I
mean you look at the position black has
everything under control what Hikaru is
relying on his lead on the clock he just
wants to keep the position as ambiguous
as possible yep no trades no exchanges
no clarification of the position he's
just trying to force Magnus to go into
the tank at some point which is
guaranteed to happen and only later
maybe put him under pressure on the
board or make him uh kind of force him
into those difficult decisions worse
comes to the West win on time but uh I
mentioned earlier as well Hikaru the
first iteration of Hikaru Nakamura when
he was young King's Indian player on the
attack and he's got the same position
with the white piece and it wasn't just
that it was also hikaranakamura flagging
the bots on ICC because he would close
the position and make a million moves
then upon move and things like that to
beat the boss on the internet chess club
so here in this game uh he's not a bot
he's only human but he plays like about
most time Magus Carlson only eight
minutes on the clock no piece have been
traded no bonds have been traded as well
so super closed position here uh David
you said worst case scenario flag I
think that's the best case scenario here
when you're in the Armageddon when
you're up on the clock you've got to
play the clock as much as the position
and look at Hikaru this is when he's
gonna make Magnus thing Harry the H Pawn
goes up the board G4 coming in next yeah
and uh White's light squared Bishop
which is a problem piece can also
activate there we go on a nicer diagonal
now for Hikaru he knows these inside
these ideas inside out he's been playing
these ideas since he was a kid yes with
reverse colors normally he's on the
black side but it's the exact same Pawn
structure Magnus he's got a promising
position he's got more space black has a
really nice Pawn chain in the center but
what do you do with it maybe less
instinctive here uh Black's plans and
he's burning time the time differential
here is increasing if anything in
hikari's favor this is really worrying
times for Magnus I've got to say but
trades help and so he just brings his
Knight in contact with the White Knight
on C4 he can swap off those Knights he
can bring his Queen up try to trade the
light Square Bishops and as the position
becomes simpler and simpler then Magnus
can find moves and what he really wants
to do is trade trade trade because if he
can force a draw somehow or get a
neutral position he'll go for that the
problem is if we get King and Rook vs
king and Rook which is an obvious draw
Hikaru Nakamura will try to flag him so
Magnus he needs to keep his eye on the
clock he can just play quickly every
single turn
you've been talking about that white
Bishop on H3 one plan that black has to
follow up with the trades would be to
move the queen ahead and then to defend
that Bishop coming to E6 but look at
this the position has blown open hikao
says now is the time I try I strike in
the center F4 that is one committal
decision by Hikaru yeah I'm surprised
he's gone for it so quickly Hikaru
because finally there is a trade finally
Black's drop here uh or at least the
next few moves have become clearer they
have become more obvious and yes the
evaluation bar shoots up on white side
but he needs to back it up on the board
now Hikaru can't just rely on the clock
there is a threat Black's Queen black
star Square Bishop are lining up against
the white F Pawn so do you just Step the
White Queen forward do you bring that to
a safer Square maybe white is the one
now attacking on uh on the king side the
black king is on this G file what's King
at some point we'll take a timeout
Shuffle to the corner and realign his
Rooks but it's not the king that uses
the corner it's the Knight one flexible
move everything in the night bring up an
analysis where I think there was a
pretty critical moment here for Hikaru
he decides to step backwards but I think
he could have sacked sacrificed upon
going E5 and after Pawn takes Pawn F5
this is a thematic Pawn sacrifice you
throw your knight to E4 you control all
of the squares in the position and you
have an attack I don't know if it would
have worked out it does involve
sacrifices of material but a current set
drops is my back top four yeah and he
uses that phrase rotate the knights he's
definitely done that here it's not clear
the Knight is necessarily better placed
on the G3 square but it does hint at
jumping in later Magnus has to watch out
uh for the same idea that Robert
mentioned still on tap later but also a
night job even a sacrifice later to open
things up first he'll bring his Bishop
to a better Square bring his Queen to a
better Square line up keep the tension
and force Magnus uh to make difficult
decisions I I'm not sure who I prefer
here to be honest but I do like White's
position in general at least the chances
of a longer game it just feels like it's
easier to play with white the moves that
you're suggesting are appearing on the
board David he takes the queen out
expecting the bishop to come out the
Rook to come out here better square and
at some point Hikaru will strike down
the board with H5 uh you have to make
sure your own King is safe first
meanwhile Magnus just waiting for that
break as well getting all his pieces
ready for what we're anticipating on the
board because once all the pieces come
to the center of the board Magnus also
will be ready to answer that break yeah
it's uh building up to its uh its
breaking point it's climax this game and
uh it's up to Hikaru how to initiate the
plan how do you prepare these Pawn
breaks that are imminent well the good
news is he wants to initiate something
to win the game but he can win on the
clock so if Magnus doesn't do anything
to initiate some trades then hikar can
Shuffle forever before throwing the pawn
forward I feel like this position is
actually quite difficult for Magnus
taking into account he has so much less
time so Hikaru he's spending his time
wisely right now he still remains about
four and a half minutes ahead I think
he'll slide his Bishop out develop his
Rook things of that nature and only
strike at the critical moment because he
wants to keep digging into Magnus
remaining clock yep it looks looks
almost automatic just bring the bishop
out throw the move back to Magnus but
Hikaru he has frozen he has gone into
the tank not moving quite yet and uh
okay four minute difference now between
the two players time Advantage
disappearing slightly but uh still a
very very relevant Factor uh Magnus
playing very quickly he's trying to
avoid any calculation it's clear so far
Magnus just playing intuitive moves just
solid moves but not really challenging
the white up yet well there's one
weakness that I see in hikaru's position
and that is the C2 Pawn which can be
targeted with the jump from with that
knight from C6 coming on to B4 and that
is perhaps what Hikaru is trying to look
at how dangerous is that once you take
out that Bishop because you really don't
want to trade the bishop for the night
he just first sidesteps with that King
to H1 really hinting at that move H5
right now which will make Magnus uh go
into a bit of a think because he needs
to be prepared to respond with that
Magnus immediately plays to move Bishop
E6 we've been talking about the
importance of trade in this position he
is afraid of the attack a little bit the
best way to respond to this to this is
to trade off your opponent's pieces I
like this approach actually Bishop to E6
yeah it makes a lot of sense it does
depend on whether white can trade off
those Bishops and then stepping uh step
forward with his pawns I'm not sure why
it's ready especially while the dark
squared Bishop sleeps while that rook in
the corner is still not participating
but uh yeah in general following the
strategy both players we called it
before they have come to the game with a
plan white keeping the tension black
Magnus trying to trade off pieces trying
to reduce the tension try to at least
make his game a lot easier to play in a
six minute lead on the clock has been
shrinking and shrinking now it's below
three minutes so Magnus Carlson is doing
a fantastic job of cutting into that
lead on the clock and he's playing great
chess he is sturdy and strong now white
will need to start launching pawns
forward the Bishops are staring at you a
card doesn't want to trade but if he
backs up that gives Magnus the hand at
the initiative so I think that hikar
recognizes the danger that his position
is in not just the match situation but
his actual position that if he does step
back he feels like it's going to allow
Magnus to take control and Hikaru making
faces he's not too happy he has been
playing a couple of very tentative moves
just shuffling that King into the corner
didn't feel like it helped his position
too much now he has to start making
concrete decisions actually put pressure
on Magnus on the board now is the moment
uh if you do start stepping backward
everything it will be too late
especially now it's only two minutes in
it and yeah turning in magnus's favor
perhaps it's getting more and more level
on the clock and Magnus that looking
very relaxed with this last move and
understandably so it just suddenly seems
as if the pressure has diluted imagine
if the light squared Bishops were to
come off at some point black can
actually strike those Central pawns with
his own f-bond coming to F5 again it
comes down to him having bought his
Rooks already to the party they're all
ready for the central break black will
be the one who will have control of this
F and the E file Magnus looking good on
the position I think he's done
everything right to neutralize White's
initiative and Hikaru Big Thing by him
it's what over a minute over two minutes
already very long think only one minute
in it now and if you don't trade off
these pieces which does guide Magnus
closer to that draw if you Retreat then
I think it's bad news suddenly Black's
Queen for example can move you can
jumping in with your Bishop maybe even
Tanya's idea of playing this F sorry
this F5 break will become very relevant
black can open it on his own terms but
uh let's go back Tanya you predicted the
future this time and uh this is the
current position F5 on the board trying
to open up lines for Black's pieces
David I love Black's position we've been
talking about how ideally the Rooks are
placed and take a look at this now after
F5 I don't see a way in which white can
actually open the center that looks like
it would be great for black if Hikaru
decides to trade you take it with the
pawn the G file is open the queen can
swing from C7 to G7 at the right time
you can double up on the E5 it looks
like white might have to make the
decision to push that E Pawn and he does
it it's E5 the bishop on E7 and now this
H4 weakness suddenly appears out of
nowhere yeah uh he's at least hinting
that he might trade off these set of
Pawns now and maybe shift the white Rook
across towards that black king still
enough pieces left to create an attack
for Hikaru Nakamura but he needs to do
it quickly now he needs to rely on his
Instinct stop being in your own head
stop calculating you just got to go for
it now if someone liked the position
actually for a car because closing it
down it may make it difficult for Magnus
to find quick moves and then take our
could play for her that is why mags took
this Pawn on H5 that is a huge decision
by him because it opens up his own King
but look at the white king in the corner
now that's exposed there's a rook on E6
ready to slide over to the H6 where if
that Knight captures on H5 you may lose
that piece if it gets pinned so black
can start taking control of the G and H
files and that's why Hikaru says no no
no no you can keep that pawn there sort
of an umbrella for my king I'm bringing
the Rook to the G file first I want to
play Rook G2 Rook A1 to G1 maybe bring a
rook to H2 as well bring all the pieces
to the party before you start taking a
pawn that is double and isolated and
Hikaru was really surprised by magnus's
decision to break his own structure to
take this Pawn now long term actually
black is the one suffering with all
these isolated pawns here and uh it's
definitely time to follow the players
and as they make these quick decisions
it's a question to Magnus how do you
consolidate how do you set up a
defensive wall the black king white
rocks are coming for it and okay he
chooses to slide his Rook across and
these are exactly the kind of positions
where the eval bar is so deceptive don't
believe it I mean look at the chaos on
the board Black's King side is
absolutely destroyed that pawn on F5
h587 all of them are weak currently
black was a pawn up I was gonna say is
but Hikaru snaps up that H5 pawn and
that's a big blunder yes because there's
a tactic I mean I would not have seen it
without the evaluation where when Knight
takes Pawn on E5 that is a game changer
because once the pawn takes the Knight
on the Square the queen slides up one
with check and then the Rook slides from
G6 to hick no matter what white does
he's gonna lose his Queen so if Magnus
Carlsen spots Knight takes E5 it turns
the tides in his favor and I think he's
looking at the way he's looking at this
position and he's kind of in a little
bit of disbelief Knight takes E5 is a
huge oversight by Karma Nakamura oh he
doesn't find it he moves his Knight away
same threat but it would have been more
effective to catch reporting the process
you would have been winning on the spot
another missed opportunity not the first
time we've said that today by Magnus
Carlsen he brings his Knight the other
way so this threat is still on on the
cards Queen check followed by The Rook
shifting Hikaru still needs to defend
tenaciously to avoid that one but uh wow
there's missing shots again that would
have been game over on the spot because
you create the exact same track but on
the way you win a key Central Pawn night
before well it still hits the C2 pawn
and you have this massive threat is
Magnus going to end up with an extra
Pawn even though it's not the amazing E5
bond with the c21 yeah and uh suddenly
Hikaru is trying to jump into his
computer screen shaking his head he
knows this one is still difficult still
the same threat on the board maybe he's
realized he dodged a bullet there but uh
isn't Black's F5 Bond hanging random
question it is well I can go and take
that pawn okay he doesn't Hikaru
Nakamura is stepping back that move
shows uh that he really is nervous he
does allow black to grab a pawn now Max
support up it's a little bit deep but I
think he didn't take the pawn of five
there might have been a draw by
repetition had he done that I don't know
if we have time to show it but that's
probably why he took a step back he
knows objectively maybe it's not the
right choice but he needs to win this
game and uh often in Armageddon chess
let's show that Robert just while we
were there Knight takes porn you can
bully your opponent with the thoughts of
a repetition uh how do we get there we
give a check I guess and then sacrifice
The Rook on F5 and then go Rook H6 check
and that's King on H2 is In Harm's Way
it can only go up to G3 in the position
and ideas with Bishop H4 check or Rook
G6 uh maybe I guess that was the wrong
one but the problem is this white king
is in huge danger yeah simply the King
has to go back if the King goes the
other way then you drop the bishop in
with the deadly check uh so the King has
to move another check and another check
and no way out it would have been a draw
so Hikaru that's why he was shaking his
head it was very deep stuff there
instead he had to give up a pawn this is
the current position uh Black's position
hasn't changed too much except you've
gobbled up this YouTube Pawn so long
term you're doing very well and we were
a little critical about Magnus missing
Knight E5 and now I'm just wondering if
this was part of the bigger plan that he
knew that Knight F5 he had calculated
his way through knowing that it ends in
a repetition he ends up with an extra
point and while we've got a lot of
Trades that have happened that cannot be
good news for Hikaru can't be good news
the Queens are off the board as well
things are disappearing there is a one
minute difference in it right now but
Magnus should be able to Hoover for the
pieces at least lock down for a draw
with his remaining time did see him
react though maybe realizing he has
missed an opportunity in this game but
he only needs a draw Magnus to win the
match he's now two pawns up but he has
let the white rook in that white Rook is
active now on the seventh rank is going
to start gobbling up some pawns Magnus
has he lost control suddenly Hikaru he's
hustling he's just trying to pose
difficult questions to his opponent that
Knight on D3 though I think is helping
Magnus out because that Rook would love
just take off that pawn next to it on A7
but the Knight would jump to B2 it can't
go there right now because the Rook is
aiming back at the square so I think
that he's going to use his Knight and
just mop up some of the white pawns and
the one minute difference this happens
in regular Blitz Games that's the good
news for Magnus it's stressful right now
with so much on the line but you get
down a minute on the clock all the time
in Blitz over the board and uh on
chess.com so I feel like for Magnus here
I mean he's at home because he knows his
position is good yeah and it's less than
a minute now in it uh no increment no
nowadays over the board increment is the
norm but uh this one is a race to the
Finish it's sudden death and uh okay
Hikaru you gotta move you've got to make
a decision if you can't go and take that
black a pawn maybe push the white a pawn
just hint that you're gonna promote it
later okay we see a trade of knights
getting rid of the very strong black
knight but every piece that disappears
from the board every trade guides Magnus
closer to that draw he's still two pawns
up remember and uh the evaluation bar
still in the middle can Magnus guide
this one to safety still big questions
to be answered okay he does put his Pawn
on a safe square but it's not going to
be safe for too long once Rook will go
after it eventually there we go and
what do you guys think predictions now
this this is stuff and it does look like
the clock is almost level both players
are under four minutes takara's got an
extra minute on the clock now just look
at how calm they are and that is what is
so amazing for me to watch because you
know this is pressure expectations all
eyes on Magnus and Hikaru right now
under pressure and expectation everyone
chokes but these guys are really
bringing their A-game Hikaru making
decisions that keeps the game going and
that's the key to this Armageddon look
at him just pursuing that pawn Magnus
moves in one more step ahead and now the
bishop comes back to attack it and I
think he's making he's creating his
chances if that a passer is on the board
it's game on yeah an Under Pressure
great song bad feeling and you see
there's a passport for black but white
is ready to take away the A5 pawn and
credit pass Arizona so we look at the
clock situation uh Hikaru back to nearly
a minute lead and it's not easy choices
from here on out so I feel like Magnus
has to be nervous given the
circumstances because got to mention the
whole day magnus's air quality has been
great but as the pressure has increased
his air quality has got worse and worse
and worse and that might be affecting
his play and uh look at that suddenly no
green circles there for him if he goes
down to defeat maybe that would have
been one of the reasons meanwhile a set
of Rooks have been traded and blacks
pawns up all week they're right for the
picking Magnus he's just been playing
too slowly right now if he had better
air quality maybe he would be a bit
faster and every second counts at this
level the margins are so small the one
thing that he's relying on is if white
does pick up that A5 Pawn the black Rook
will swoop over to the a file hit that
bishop and along with that also win the
A4 Pawn if these a pawns get traded then
life is good for Magnus Carlson he goes
easy towards that job but it's all about
whether Hikaru can create that a passer
or not but I think that black has an
idea of his own Max will slide his Rook
one square over to d8 use the king to
protect the bishop and then bring his
Rook d8 to D4 and go after the C Pawn we
did see Magnus us just bring his Rook to
date after his car stole a pawn so
magnus's plan is now clear will they
have enough time to execute it that's
the essential question but two plus
minutes on this clock I do think it's
looking like a task that he is capable
of handling yeah two minutes so on the
board he's fine but is the clock gonna
tell the decisive Factor here I think
you can jump in there we go the black
Rook has landed not just as this brought
up for grabs the pawn behind it and
white has to bank everything on this
past Pawn you have to run it through
somehow you have to break the blockade
somehow evict this black Bishop kick it
away and somehow cause some problems for
the black king but on the board it
definitely looks like Magnus is in full
control and uh here we go position
progressing white Bishop is actually the
one being kicked around black has two
connected past pawns Hikaru doesn't look
happy at all and the clock is not even
so hikar doesn't even have his lead on
the clock he's down material that is
terrible news for someone who needs to
win this game yeah he needs to win it
but actually he should be the one
defending look at the evaluation bar
dropping down in Black's favor those are
two Runners those two black points
they're going to cost quite some
material and there's no stopping them
and we see Hikaru that he is worried
about his position but he's still wow
what just happened things are turning
again this will happen a lot throughout
this time scramble but the black pawns
are running they look quicker to
normally run it slower than one but
those two connected plus pawns are so
close to becoming Queens well I can give
a check and move his own Pawn one square
closer to the queening uh point at eight
but blackstroke just saves it and you've
got these two pawns which are
unstoppable how do you fight these two
Central pawns devastated Hikaru looks
like he's actually ready to resign
almost all you need to do is Magnus
steps and pawns forward if you don't get
flagged you're guaranteed to win this
Armageddon and now we have kind of a
blitzed game where it's about even on
the clock and Magnus only needs a draw
and we saw the bar go about level but I
think the reason that it wasn't actually
equals because a draw is bad for a car
it might have been a forced draw and he
can't have any part of that yeah hikar
is simply a pawn down now neither of
those pawns became Queens but it did
come at the cost of more trades more
exchanges and look at this classy move
from Magnus he's just trying to swap
things off he's now managed to get rid
of the Bishops rid of a set of Pawns and
Hikaru is he going to try and flag
Magnus the answer is no it's a draw
Magnus takes this Armageddon and the
match and believe it or not Hikaru is
actually the one who offered a draw
that's the ultimate sign of respect he
wasn't going to try to flag somebody he
was 10 seconds behind on the clock
against that is a good show of
sportsmanship wow we see a big smile on
Magnus Carlson's face and he got her
shaking his head the big match is over
Magnus Carlsen wins the winner finals
with a draw in Armageddon he cared
Nakamura what a fight he gave it but he
had to win and the Armageddon with a
draw it means he loses loses the winner
is final
what do you think is going through his
head right now Robert disappointment but
I do think that Magnus played the better
chest between the two it was close uh
but I think that when we had this final
game set up a Magnus was never really in
trouble over the board so Hikaru
probably upset he didn't maximize some
of his chances it just wasn't meant to
be yeah
should we take a look at what events
in this game David there were many
twists and turns in this one Magnus did
play a really exemplary game we should
mention Hikari tried everything he tried
to throw at Magnus off balance he tried
to hustle on the clock but to no avail
and it was actually here that Magnus had
a winning shot he didn't spot it it was
difficult we should mention it was
Knight takes Pawn just to open up a
check against the white king this check
would have been deadly if the Knight had
been recaptured a check the king moves
in maybe the one that Magnus hadn't
spotted is that you first have to push
this Pawn forward to break the white
Bishop's connection with this H6 Square
next The Rook slides across to win and
uh if we fast forward to the end game
magnet here was in full control he had
these two running pawns he should have
been winning for black but he found a
really nice way to guide it to safety
and Hikaru never got a chance to win on
the board
what a match this has been Magnus
Carlsen wins the winner finals and goes
through to Friday's Grand Final Hikaru
Nakamura he goes down to uh tomorrow
play the loser is final there is still a
chance Hikaru Nakamura can win the air
things monsters what do you think of the
match we've seen between these two
giants Tanya that's exactly what we
expected right so much drama on the
board Magnus had his chances in the
rapid potion as well I think overall
today Magnus was perhaps just slightly
slightly the better player in this match
if anyone had the chances in Rapid it
was him and in the Armageddon What was
amazing to see was that one second win
by Magnus to get the black Pieces Just
goes on to show how much they have the
understanding of each other's mindset
here and then playing with the black
pieces I think that was a brilliant
Armageddon game uh Hikaru tried his best
he tried to create chances made a mess
made a chaotic position on the boy it
but Magnus was completely in control
today yeah we raised our eyebrows when
we saw the bids Robert Magnus with eight
minutes and 58 seconds How brave was
that to bid that little time against
Hikaru extremely brave because in the
game that we saw Hikaru almost put
Magnus under incredible duress uh Magnus
thankfully for him was able to open the
board up and his plan became easier but
it almost worked to Perfection for his
cars that little time that's dangerous
against someone as Speedy as a car yeah
definitely
we are hoping to get reactions from the
two players Magnus Carlsen is the winner
of the match how will you sum it up
David this whole match between these two
oh it's just fantastic to watch first of
all as a chess fan myself it was so
close very high quality both kind of
trading blows with each other he covers
only blunder today I would say was
bidding uh eight minutes 59 rather than
eight minutes 57 but uh yeah fair play
to Magnus he took its uh small margins
but uh he did did deserve the win and
we're joined by Magnus Carlson big
congratulations on a big match win
yeah thank you I think what I deserve uh
the most credit for is my bid but that
was the soul read definitely take us
through your uh thinking they're bidding
eight minutes and 58 seconds
I thought it was one seconds less than
855 which I thought was going to his be
his bit so there you go impressive
impressive but did you feel that was
taking a risk bidding that little time
against someone as Speedy as he car
Nakamura
yeah I think playing Armageddon is a
pretty big risk to begin with uh and uh
I believe that he's a lot more
comfortable playing Black in these
situations so I thought uh playing Black
uh would be um the main goal and this
was uh
I thought
um this was I thought the amount of time
that I could the most amount of time
that I could bid and still be black aha
now did you have a plan for this bid
from the get-go today or was it
something you came up with just in those
minutes before the Armageddon started
The Drifter told I was thinking about it
before the fourth game because I was
sure that he had forced to draw and
um because of that I was not focused on
the game and I just made the wrong move
in the opening which could have cost me
dearly aha yeah there were a few missed
opportunities for you today Magnus how
will you sum up the match as a whole
um you know what uh this is one of the
days that I I mean I woke up uh after a
long long sleep
I I had some breakfast maybe some too
much breakfast because afterwards I was
spent and I could not recover
for the whole game so I think
uh the match was of
really really poor quality
uh and I think he probably would agree
as well uh so normally uh especially the
second game
I get an opportunity which I should
never in a million years Miss and also
in this first game I was was much better
and it didn't feel like he was playing
it nearly his his best so uh I think the
chances are
pretty high that I'll be facing him
again and then I think we'll just we'll
uh we hope that I hope that we both can
a bit better because this was I think
how much that it was not
representative of any hour of our levels
okay and uh Magnus you mentioned that
the breakfast uh kind of caused some
issues this morning what do they serve
at the chatsborough house for breakfast
no we actually went went out you know I
had some uh uh I had some eggs some
bacon and some uh some veggies so that's
you know close to what I normally eat so
I should have been fine the other days
I've so I've come out come out here uh
without eating breakfast and then I felt
a lot better so like then I've been just
you know munching on some some uh nuts
and raisins during the games and some
carrots in between games and that's
worked a lot better so maybe I should go
back to that
and Magnus was the good breakfast that
you were having was that the reason why
you were still slightly late for the
start of today's match and did you read
David's text that he sent you right at
the beginning
no I didn't see them it's text so I I
thought it was going to start at 12 45
so I was a bit shocked when
when I was told uh that you know
we're starting so I I I I should have
been ready of course but also like not
having set starting times is less than
ideal for the players and Magus now that
you're a streamer you know chat isn't
always focused on the chess so a big
question that was coming from them is
what is your favorite Pokemon
Psyduck oh same as me Yay good one
Magnus now yeah
the whole Chess World has really enjoyed
this battle between you two today
together you hold all the big world
championship titles with Hikaru being
the fish random world champion you've
had so many awesome battles in online
chess over the last few years is the
Rivalry with Hikaru something that keeps
you motivated
uh yeah I mean
the games are a lot of fun and
especially
especially in the last few years they've
felt very very important so yeah anytime
I get a chance to play him it's uh it's
a privilege yeah and winning today you
get a day off tomorrow you are already
ready for Friday it's the big Grand
Final so how will you spend the day of
tomorrow
I'm not telling you that's for sure
respect that Magnus big congratulations
on a big match win today and good luck
on Friday
thank you enjoy your day off
all right what do you think Mike this
will be up to tomorrow you guys
might have the answers I don't know I'm
not there in Canada but uh maybe
studying some chess they play some
Pokemon you know he seemed pretty happy
to answer with Psyduck so maybe he'll go
do some Pokemon go maybe you play duck
chess if you love Psyduck
it's a good one yeah I don't think it's
going to involve a lot of Chess let me
just
enjoying his time with the chess Bros in
Canada Magnus Carlsen is ready for the
Grand Final in the air things monsters
let's take a look at the bracket we are
done with uh three days in the air
things monsters two days to go we
started today with the losers
quarterfinals Wesley so was dominant
winning two games against Serana to
knock sarana out and to go through to
the losers semi-final it was an intense
battle between Arjun Eric icy and yukash
the two young Indians eventually our
guysi made it through to the Lutheran
semi-final he will face Wesley so
tomorrow the winner of that match best
of two rapid games will go through to
face Hikaru Nakamura and the losers
final so that is what is coming up
tomorrow the winner of the losers final
will may meet Magnus Carlsen in the
Grand Final on Friday so we do have
Wesley Seoul still in here we do have
Hikaru Nakamura still in there Magnus
Carlson's still in here and Arjun Eric I
see I guess the the underdog yeah to
make it all the way to the final now
definitely an underdog but somebody who
we saw great chess from today he's
playing with confidence with passion as
fireworks all across the board so he's a
dangerous opponent for Wesley so who
prefers a solid game yeah what chances
do you give Arjun that you guys you know
Tanya too
Brave and upsets against these Giants in
online chess what I'm doubtedly on paper
Wesley is a big favor going into that
match fit you know what Kaya last year
if anyone would have predicted that we'd
find Arjun aragassi in the finals of the
Champions Chester few would have
believed it but there we had it we saw
him make his way through through that he
had a brilliant performance he's capable
of it he needs to believe it and of
course everything that he's been showing
so far he needs to come in with that
same energy same effort same precision
and fearless play yeah what do you think
so far David of the Champions Chester
2023 well I was expecting a lot and it
really has lift up lived up to those
expectations we're really lucky to be
enjoying the Giants of modern chess
playing in our tournaments and uh yeah
whoever wins this double limb uh will
prove that they are at the moment in
time uh the best rapper chess player out
there yeah fantastic day of Chess thank
you so much to our experts for excellent
commentary remember that in actually 25
minutes the grand
is doing and ask me anything and he's
going to focus on his new chessable
course that is out starts in 25 minutes
on chess.com Discord so check that out
and join us again tomorrow for more
chats it's been so much fun today we'll
see you again tomorrow bye for now
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]